foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
it is week two of the cop 26 climate
Summit as negotiations continue in an
attempt to hop
[Music]
foreign
Sky News climate live at cop26 today's
top stories
the race is on that the cop President
says pledges must be delivered on as the
summit goes into its second week the
former U.S president Barack Obama will
bring the star power here on a day
focusing on adaptation loss and damage
and the UK government pledges 290
million pounds to support countries
dealing with the impact of climate
change and we're in the Isles of silly
where the land could become
uninhabitable without urgent action
the majority of the population lives
here in Hue town but it's also one of
the most vulnerable parts of the Isles
[Music]
a very good morning to you now the
pressure is on here in Glasgow with less
than a week to go until these
all-important negotiations wrap up and
the cop president alok Sharma has
insisted that those pledges are
delivered to meet the goal of halting
global warming at 1.5 degrees Celsius
and today the focus switches to the
Nations that are already being severely
affected by climate change with rising
sea levels and droughts making lands
uninhabitable over the next week Sky
News climate live is your dedicated
channel for all climate news and the
live events that are taking place here
at The Summit in Glasgow coming up at
quarter past nine we're going to bring
you the first event hearing from the
front line but first Anne-Marie
trevellian Secretary of State for
international trade also the UK's
International Champion on adaptation and
resilience for cop26 spoke to Sky news
this morning about that pledge to help
island nations
we're going to be announcing an extra
290 million pounds to support the least
developed countries in small island
states to help tackle the Urgent
challenges that they need to be
resilient and to adapt to the climate
shocks that are coming now even if we
fix the CO2 emissions challenge today we
would see the heightened climate impacts
continuing to affect those most
vulnerable countries for up to 100 years
to come so adaptation to the changing
climate in their own locally LED
communities is critical and this is
something we're going to be discussing
in depth today and hearing from voices
across the world about how they're
adapting and how they're becoming more
resilient to the day-to-day challenges
of these climate shocks
now Australia has said that it will sell
coal for decades into the future that's
after refusing to sign up to a deal
pledging to phase out fossil fuels
Adcock 26 in Glasgow when our southeast
Asia correspondent Siobhan Robbins is in
Sydney for us uh Siobhan it appears
there's a lot of public support for
policies that address climate change in
Australia but it feels very much like
the government just doesn't want to show
up
well there's been a lot of pressure on
the Australian government coming into
cop26 it was just days before the
conference kicked off that they finally
managed to announce a commitment to net
zero emissions by 2050 then last week in
the first week of the conference we saw
that they failed to sign up to the
methane cup pledge they failed to sign
up to the list of countries and
organizations which are pledged to phase
out for coal power and today the
resources Minister has said very clearly
in an interview that they will not be
closing coal mines and they will not be
closing coal-powered fire stations now
he was speaking to ABC the broadcaster
here in Australia and he said that
there's still a huge demand for coal
around the world they said that they
expected that increasing demand to
continue till at least 2030 and in his
words if they want it we will sell it
and he said that if Australia wasn't
selling the coal which he claims is some
of the highest quality in the world than
other countries would step into the
breach he also doubled down saying that
they would meet the commitments that
they've made for 2050 but in his words
they wouldn't destroy the economy trying
to meet those commitments earlier and
that 300 000 people around the country
rely on coal now we've seen a very
similar message coming from the coal
communities that we've been visiting
over the last week saying that they
shouldn't be cutting coal mines now that
people need the money that is well paid
jobs that there's still demand that if
Australia steps back then someone else
will just step into the breach but the
big problem is that even though
Australia isn't a big Global emitter
emits around 1.3 percent of global
emissions it's a massive exposure of
coal it's the second biggest export of
coal in the world so in that sense
climate campaigners say it's essentially
like a world dealer of the dirtiest
fossil fuel in the world so how is the
rest of the world meant to step up and
meet emissions if Australia won't step
up and cut coal
and Siobhan cities in Australia like
around the world we have seen people
taking to the streets haven't we to
demonstrate for their government to be
doing more
yes that's right and there's a real
division between different communities
so for example over the weekend we saw
campaigners in Sydney and Melbourne
taking to the street saying they wanted
immediate action on climate change and
then when we're in communities that rely
on coal they're saying no the
government's doing the right thing and
then we spoke to some farmers who
believe that they're being hit by
drought by
that more needs to be done on climate
change from their point of view so it's
a very divided nation here I think the
other thing to really bear in mind is
that Australia is heading towards an
election cycle and if the reports are to
be believed then it took a lot of
wrangling from the Prime Minister Scott
Morrison to even get some of the more
conservative elements within his party
to blow back that Net Zero pledge for
2050 so it seems that they're stepping
more carefully as they head towards that
election year
all right Siobhan thank you
now with ministers arriving for the
political stage of negotiations here at
cop26 we've been to an area of the UK
which could become uninhabitable if
action isn't taken to tackle climate
change our west of England correspondent
Dan Whitehead reports now from the Isles
of silly
28 miles off the tip of Cornwall a
climate emergency is unfolding less than
a thousand years ago the Isles of silly
was a single landmass now it's 140
islands and 2 000 residents are battling
the impact of rising sea levels and
intense storms this is our the main
defense of our water supply which is
just the other side of this Bank
protecting the Island's water from sea
contamination is just one of the plans
to ensure that future Generations can
still live here what's the worst case
scenario for the people of the House of
silly well evacuation basically because
it wouldn't be able to live here I'm not
talking about the next 10 years 20 or
even 100 years but it could eventually
lead to evacuation the council says it
must robustly defend the islands and is
spending Millions on protecting its
Coastline Homes and businesses the
majority of the population lives here in
Hue town but it's also one of the most
vulnerable parts of the Isles at its
narrowest it's around 130 meters wide
sandwiched between two beaches climate
change is literally squeezing and
eroding this community
things
[Music]
20 minutes by boat and we arrive at
Saint Agnes population 80. Farmers Aiden
and Grace rear cattle but also grow
crops for oils and gin so normally we'd
be harvesting these plants and they'd be
they'd be up like this intense dry
spells are making business difficult
Summers like this summer have made us
have to rethink completely we're going
to we're having to look at investing in
permanent irrigation systems now to see
us through It's Just Happening too often
for us to risk year on year the crops
failing
but climate change isn't just impacting
those on land
the wildlife trust says in 2017 nearly
all seal pups died after being swept out
to sea too soon by a series of ferocious
storms
uh this is the main entrance to the
school fifteen-year-old will Schwartz is
a climate champion at the Island's only
school he's passionate and fearful about
the future of the sillies it definitely
worries me the future Generations won't
be able to have the same experiences
over here than than I did than my
generation did
um which is a little bit sad and it's a
bit worrying because
um it we might already be too late
This Island community is taking action
now knowing climate change is posing an
urgent threat to its very way of life
Dan Whitehead Sky News on the Isles of
silly
well of course climate change doesn't uh
just go on pause while the delegates are
discussing what measures will mitigate
it and we are keeping a constant look at
those key numbers for Great Britain here
with our data dashboard well this shows
you the level of global warming since
industrialization in 1880 remember that
goal of 1.5 degrees well look already at
1.23 and that keeps that number keeps
moving up you can see while I'm talking
to you here at this very interesting
this gives us a snapshot of what our
current real-time power mix is this is
to generate electricity and we can see
and it's worth noting that those numbers
do Bounce Around the the shift between
Renewables and fossil fuels does change
according to the time of day and the
time of year getting about 50 just under
53 coming from gas so this number coal
here that tends to bump around around
some somewhere between zero one or two
percent that's higher today we're not
entirely sure why that is yet we've got
to call International grid to find out
why this uh here the proportion coming
from Renewables a lot of that wind and
solar and low carbon energy generation
as well coming from nuclear so that
gives you a sense of where we are at as
we're speaking to you now here in terms
of our electricity generation
now the UN estimates that methane gas
has accounted for 30 percent of global
warming since the Industrial Revolution
the oil and gas industry are well known
to be big and unregulated emitters of
methane with the cattle industry too
often criticized but another key emitter
of the potent gas is our own rubbish
well Mark Stone reports now from Texas
where they are trying new ways to
capture the methane from the mountains
of refuse that we produce
foreign
we all contribute to landfill but up
close there is something overwhelming
about a place like this and in
consumer-obsessed America the scale is
quite something
so too the lack of effective recycling
just look at the plastic and the
cardboard here
space is cleared for more and more
because the average American produces
nearly a ton of rubbish every year
that's three times as much as the
average Britain
we are seemingly Unstoppable generators
of waste which is why management is so
vital so this is the most interesting
work I've ever done
Zachary Peterson manages this vast
landfill outside Houston America's
fourth largest city and he's proud of a
process that despite flaws caused by
consumer culture and poor regulation is
he says sustainable my passion for
landfills is I can affect change and it
affects you know our community it
affects you know being a good neighbor
it affects the environment you know I'm
directly affecting the
the world my daughter's going to grow up
in by doing proper landfilling
under this pasture is tons of waste
among the huge challenges of landfill is
methane without effective management
methane seeps out of the earth as the
waste decomposes and it is a greenhouse
gas that short-term warms our planet
faster than any other in America alone
landfill accounts for nearly 20 percent
of human-caused methane emissions but
here a solution we've watched the trucks
coming in through the morning tons and
tons of waste flattened and compacted on
top of a plastic shell that already
lines the landfill site eventually that
shell will be sealed the waste within it
will decompose and from that the methane
can then be extracted
these stumps are the methane Wells
dotted across the landscape they are the
heart of the operation and they are the
success story the example I like to use
being if you imagine a milkshake you
have a straw in the milkshake the
milkshakes your landfill the straw is
the extraction well you exert the vacuum
using your mouth or in our case a blower
system and you know the content is
removed at some point
on the edge of the site the gas which
would otherwise seep out of the earth is
piped into a Refinery cleaned and then
sold on to power cars and heat homes
this methane capture is a technology
used increasingly around the developed
world yet Beyond it is literally an
ever-growing Challenge and while this
may be a success of sorts the troubling
fact is that even here so much of this
will never decompose Mark Stone Sky News
in Texas
well adapt
damage are today's themes here at cop26
and adaptation is vitally important for
many countries not least the Republic of
Armenia it's a country on the front line
of the climate crisis and its government
is working it is here negotiating for
ways to improve what is going on there
in the country or joining me now in the
studio is here a pet to hackabian from
the environment Ministry of the Republic
of Armenia really good to see you this
morning now your country is very low
down in the rankings in terms of world
emitters I think you contribute
something like .01
of global emissions and yet you are at
the front line of what is happening with
climate so just talk to us about how
climate is impacting the country you're
absolutely right we are suffering from
climate change so if you take a look at
the global warming it's already you know
one uh tell one degree Celsius Global
temperature increase worldwide but
Armenia itself is already registered 1.3
Celsius degree increase so you can see
there is a you know more effect of
climate change in Armenia and other
agriculture other Water Resources our
health sector are suffering a lot from
climate change and in that sense we need
to adapt to climate change otherwise our
economy will be more vulnerable to to
the to the consequences of climate
change and our government has already
made commitment under the Paris
agreement it submitted us many other
parties Under Paris agreement it's indc
but recently we updated our NDC and it
it set up an ambitious Target by 2030
of 2013 and it said 40 40 the you know
percent reduction compared to 1990 so in
dance science we need uh climate Finance
to to direct it to mitigate our
greenhouse gas emissions come on to the
financing side because of course it's
a bit more of a picture of what's going
on in Armenia I've had a look at your
power mix and you're doing quite well
already on the renewable side of things
I think what's something like 30 more
percent coming from renewable energy
talk to us about how the country has
made that shift that's right so our
energy mixer is composed mostly from
nuclear power plant it is responsible
for one or third of our whole Energy Mix
and the rest of one-third is coming from
Hydro energy which you mentioned as
renewable energy and also thermal power
plants but our government also made a
strategy in energy sector and we we are
looking forward to also increase the
share of solar panels in Armenia because
it has all the you know potential to
increase solar station station capacity
in the country we already registered
like two or two percent uh from from
solar but our strategy energy sector is
expects to set about 15 percent of total
energy mix in 2030 from coming from
solar panel then this is how we see to
meet our updated NBC Target and this is
how we see to contribute to the gold
Global efforts to to meet Paris
agreements a Target so you know exactly
what you'd be doing with the money and
where it would need to be invested it's
worth pointing out isn't it and we
shouldn't forget that your country has
not only had to deal with ongoing
climate pressures you've had the
pandemic and you've also had the ongoing
conflict in nagorno-karabakh yes and how
has that impacted the the situation on
the ground
despite the fact that we we are
suffering from double crisis as you
rightly mentioned about the war conflict
and pandemic we are still the government
prioritize climate change in its agenda
because this pandemic not for only for
Armenia but for the rest of the
countries in the world show that we need
that sustainable uh development approach
when it comes to when it comes to
mitigate impacts on our planet
specifically on to the environment and
economies so we need to ensure green
recoveries that's why we are working
hardly and fruitfully with our partners
like International donor community and
by foreign true bilateral Channels with
the countries like Germany this is how
we see and green recovery and climate
resilient development is are the are the
most you know prioritized approaches of
our government when it comes to deal
with the consequences of climate change
you your president is here
really make
eight million dollars a year for
developing countries is is Armenia at
the table for that because there's been
a lot of focus about getting the money
to Global South countries do you feel
sometimes the Amina perhaps gets a bit
forgotten uh I would not say that we are
we feel that we are sometimes forgotten
but I think it's not only about our
minutes also about other developing
countries not on X1 countries mostly
under unit Triple C's so we we suffer a
lot from the to be honest with you from
bureaucracy uh you know but we are
running good out of time already we need
to make this climate Finance mobilize as
soon as possible uh to meet that 100
billion at least you know uh Target set
under the Paris Accord otherwise we are
running off time and we need that money
not only just like to have money and
make investment this this money is
needed for capacity building for
technology transfer and to educate and
enhance capacity of our Specialists and
institutions that there they become
capable enough to deliver our uh
ambitious climate agendas financing
there is always a challenge isn't it for
countries that have not a great
Sovereign credit rating which Armenia
doesn't I think you're classified as as
high credit risk and that makes tapping
up finances and financing from the
capital markets very expensive that's
right you're making a really good point
but in in on the other hand we are we
are very transparent with our debtors
and we we also working closely with our
kid debtors on on climate that swept
mechanism as you mentioned president was
here he also raised this topic in in his
statement by saying that we are we are
eager to work with them with with
countries like French Japan United
States Russia Germany to ballarately a
bilaterally think how we can Channel
this money that we did to them to to
direct them to to address impacts of
climate change and mitigate climate
change and final question to you what
what is your view of what has been
achieved so far at cop 26 do you think
it's been a good conference or are you
disappointed uh because it's not my
first call but my already my fourth I
didn't have like um I had like a much
expectation in the previous course but
this one I was more realistic but you've
learned the hard way yeah exactly but to
be honest with you I think the the first
week was not bad at least I can say and
although unfortunately regarding the
article seat six of the Paris Agoura the
carbon Market we could have you know
more uh procedures and mechanisms
settled during the first week's
negotiations but I hope that in the
second week we will have more uh you
know positive outcomes and this is these
are article six issue is very important
also as we already discussed about
mobilizing enough climate finance and
this is very important for developing
countries uh themselves all right well
perhaps you'll come back and see us
again when we get further through the
week to let us know how that has gone
for Armenia thank you very much for
coming in to talk to us this morning
coming up on Sky News climate live today
is all about adaptation and loss and
we're going to be bringing you all of
the sessions taking place today here in
Glasgow at cop26 stay with us
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Sky News climate live we
are of course bringing you uninterrupted
coverage for two weeks of all of the
sessions all of the twists and turns the
highs and the lows of this un climate
conference taking place here in Glasgow
now agriculture has a big impact on
climate change land is cleared to grow
crops greenhouse gas emissions are
produced by livestock and fertilizers
can also pollute water supplies but it
is possible for Farmers to move towards
a more sustainable system that protects
the environment where we can bring in
our guest I was going to say our first
guest of the day but we did swap you
around got Fernandez co-founder of the
land workers Alliance a very good
morning to you jetty what are you
looking for today well I'd like to see a
real focus on Farmers being able to
adapt to be able to deal with a
tremendous variations in climate that
are going on because of climate change
you know we must see a reduction in
emissions because we won't be able to
produce food for the planet as Farmers
I'm a farmer myself unless we do I have
a mixed Farm we've got livestock we've
got cows and sheep but we've got also
got loads of vegetables arable crops and
loads and loads of fruit you can do
cider an apple juice endorse it okay and
in terms of the impact that climate
change has already had on the way you do
business just just give us a knife a
flavor of that well every year we see
the climate really changing in terms of
variability so sometimes we see it
staying warmer for much longer than it
should then we get loads of rain and
then we get loads of drought Farmers all
over the world are really at the front
line of this climate crisis and we're
noticing that so much is changing that
we can't predict the weather patterns in
the same way that we would so we've got
to have maximum diversity in our farming
systems in order to be able to deal with
that and that's all about adaptation and
in terms of the adaptation that you've
already had to implement is that
something where you had to really
scramble and think we need to radically
change this overnight or have you been
making gradual changes well the farmers
that I represent are small-scale farmers
around the world people using
traditional knowledge systems systems
like agroecology organic farming you
know indigenous knowledge systems that
have always used for centuries
knowledge of the land and how it works
knowledge of the natural environment
around them use many many biodiverse
agricultural crops and livestock and
those are systems that have always
worked with nature and so we're building
on those to build our adaptation and our
resilience because you know we know how
to adapt proper varieties from every
year you can look at what you know takes
place on your farm and you can change
those varieties so that they adapt even
further and become more resilient and
more robust and we have diverse farming
systems which means we have so many
different things going on that on a bad
year something will still work and on a
day yeah yeah we don't have all our eggs
in one basket and we believe though
that's true adaptation the problem here
is at this conference there's a lot of
big agribusinesses industrialized
farming systems corporations that are
talking about adaptation and they have a
very very different message they're
saying industrialized farming robotics
vertical Farms genetically modified
seeds they say those are the keys to
adaptation and we feel that's a very
false message in fact those sorts of
farming systems are the ones that have
driven the climate crisis those are the
ones that have caused all the emissions
caused the Sawyer to be replacing our
beautiful rainforests you know those are
the ones that we actually need to not be
making stronger but here they're saying
oh we're the solution where we really
know that we've got Solutions in our
hands and you've just got to listen to
the small-scale farmers that have been
doing this for those businesses dirty
and you'll know this more than anybody
yeah have a louder voice don't they
because of their size yes they do and
and the money involved in it you know
when you produce genetically modified
seeds you sell those to Farmers and you
make money off of it and those companies
have a lot of vested interest and the
money they can make from Agriculture and
so they have a louder voice because they
can get the advertising space they have
more of a direct line to government and
a lot of times you know the voices of
small-scale farmers are some of the most
marginalized on the planet despite the
fact that it's almost half the
population of the planet
what do you think of the way that that
they frame The Narrative you're sort of
hinting at it there but um you know the
Whole Net Zero narrative how is that
different coming through their voice
than from yours from agribusiness well
there's a scenario that we call land
sharing versus land sparing and what
intensive agriculture says what the
story they try to say about you know how
they feed the world is that we're going
to produce a lot of crops with very very
high yields with loads of input you know
lots of chemical fertilizers and
herbicides so that we can get maximum
yields and if we do that then we can
produce all the food we need on less
land and you can have loads of room left
for forest and for wildlife that's the
story they say that's when shown not to
be true because really when Farmers
invest in all this technology to make
their Farms very big that intensive
agriculture there's no actual limit on
how much they can produce so they
actually just produce more and and you
know and we have more and more soya more
food that's being produced that's going
into the food waste you know part of our
food system which is a very sad thing
that's happened with globalized
Agriculture and industrialized Food
Systems we talk about land sharing and
it's something we've done for a very
long time and we're very good at which
is having nature across our Farms
sharing with the forest sharing with the
trees sharing with the creatures and
making sure we provide wildlife habitat
on our Farms we sequester carbon in the
soil we sequester carbon in older you
know biodiversity that we have on the
farms and so we don't need to set aside
room for nature nature is in the Farms
it's in our food production systems it's
there feeding us as part of that
a lot of the big business that are here
whatever sector they're in it's not just
agriculture but they have these massive
Global Supply Chains Don't They yeah do
has there been enough focus on moving
away from that and just having
everything a little bit more local not
enough at all you know there's still
this story that we can trade our way out
of this and you know we see the
governments all over the world pursuing
free trade agreements constantly UK
government included and you know as as a
UK farmer these trade agreements
directly undermine my livelihood if I'm
trying to do the right thing and farming
an environmentally friendly way because
you're in direct competition with
factory farms in other parts of the
world that have to ship you know with
planes and refrigerated you know trucks
and all these things and bringing
livestock over borders you know these
crazy systems that is a huge contributor
to climate change whereas Local Foods
localized food systems are a real
solution not only do you get to know the
farmer and get involved you also reduce
food miles and you're supporting these
biodiverse systems where you're not just
producing monocultures you know all the
time and those monocultures are really
flawed in how they are for the
environment the supermarket chains as
well have a lot to answer for in terms
of all the refrigeration all the
packaging all the miles that food is
shipped all over the place really the
solution is local and we've got to think
about that and stop being thinking the
industrialized globalized food system is
going to feed us all consumers have
shifted though haven't they I think
consumers care a lot more now about the
provenance of what they're putting on
their table and it also appears that
people are getting that whole price
trade-off as well do you is that how
it's felt to you people are happy to pay
you really are for good quality food
that's not damaging the planet yeah I
think people are and it's really really
important to do that but also there
needs to be some centralized planning
about where our food system is going it
can't just be all about consumer choice
because there's some people who can't
afford to buy the very best you know
pasture-fed meat or you know try and you
know grow low you get loads of organic
vegetables not everybody can afford that
but there's right to food that's out
there there's the planet we need to
think about you know we need to think
about the climate government actually
needs to think very strategically about
where we're going with our food system
and make plans for a local food supply
make plans to support Farmers properly
for doing a good job for what they're
doing and make sure everybody can access
affordable good healthy local food all
right Jody really interesting to talk to
you I hope you get what you want out of
this conference we're going to take you
now to our first event which is getting
underway here in Glasgow we're hearing
from the front line Let's uh have a
listen in
lost cultures
droughts in hella province in my country
a land rooted in culture that people
cannot resettle there because the bodies
of our people lay there
maximized magnitudes of natural
disasters from across the Pacific
lives and homes lost all adding to 26.4
million affected in 2008.
these numbers have grown and I cannot
bear to say it
help from the EU the U.N superpowers of
the world supporting tiny Island states
such as mine how can this land truly
change when we fight constant battles
this generation of Fire
full of ideas yet not given space or
time to share
we will inherit the future
but don't ever say give me a seat
or give me a corner of the room I do not
mind standing
a space is more than enough to start
to make decisions to help policies get
to the finish line so that we can adapt
well
let us use the knowledge of our
forefathers our ancestors our tumblenas
to revive the oceans the Seas and the
rainforests let us use local solutions
to adjust the global problems
once that affects us greatly
give this generation of fire the space
remove the timelines my people are the
solution
This Is Our Land we understand the ocean
and we have the connections let us work
together
not away from each other but together
let us let our story be told
of a battle one and not lost
stop me from drowning
trust us to lead our Solutions locally
and act now thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much francella and uh
that was a really incredible story from
the climate Justice perspective
what we've seen over Rich ecosystem and
the destruction that is happening and
the need to bring people in the spaces
for procedure Justice and recognition of
what they know that's really really
excellent and uh
so uh vanzel in addition to being a
spoken word artist
she's also a consultant of the women
make the change project with undp in new
papagini thank you very much
a round of applause for mezilla really
it was really touching for me at least
so it's a pleasure to welcome you here
in Glasgow
to the first event of the UK presidency
adaptation loss and damage day
uh hearing from the front lines
um I'm Tracy kajumba I work as a
principal researcher with the
international institute for environment
and development in the climate change
group
and in this session we will save videos
from Kenya India and Chile highlighting
the work of local leaders in their
communities and the organizational
mechanisms that they are using to
address Grassroots leadership for
adaptation
we will take each video in turn
are followed by questions including from
our co-hosts and from the audience
and they'll have time to ask more
questions at the end
so without further Ado I want to
introduce my co-hosts it's a pleasure to
be joined by the Secretary of State and
Mary travilion as the UK's International
adaptation and resilience Champion for
cop 26. so over to you
[Applause]
good morning everyone I'm very excited
to be here you shouldn't be I should be
much more grown up
um it's just wonderful to be kicking off
uh the first cup 26th presidency event
of adaptation lost and damage day
something that is uh very important to
me personally so thank you to our
panelists and everyone else who's going
to be joining us here for this
discussion
um shortly I'll hand over to my co-chair
Emily to introduce herself
um that she's having the joys of
security to get here so we hope to see
her very soon but first of all I'd like
to provide a few remarks to set the
context for what I know is going to be a
really valuable and insightful session
as the UK's International Champion for
adaptation and resilience for the cop 26
presidency I've had the privilege of
speaking to people across the world over
the last year who are dealing with the
impact of climate change on the front
line
disasters and extreme weather events
devastating lives and communities right
now
but what has struck me time and again is
the Enterprise the Ingenuity and the
ideas that people have to deal with
these impacts
so why should we focus on local action
it's the right thing to do and it's also
the most effective way to see the change
that we know is needed
adaptation with or by local communities
rather than to them helps us all learn
how to ensure a more Equitable future
that is climate resilient for everyone
so that's why the UK is using its cop 26
presidency to prioritize locally LED
adaptation
this January at the global Commission on
adaptations climate adaptation Summit
the UK endorsed the principles for
locally LED adaptation
these principles provide a framework for
how adaptation can be delivered more
effectively
we are urging all countries and
particularly donors to follow suit
over the last few months in partnership
with the UN high-level Champions team
and Regional Partners we have held a
series of dialogues looking at
successful examples of adaptation around
the world
that means peer-to-peer capacity
building devolves decision making
support for indigenous lead action and
the promotion of innovative practices
of course we need to underpin this
approach with Finance which is why it is
crucial to get it to those who need it
most
the cop26 presidency with Fiji and other
partners launched the task force on
access to climate Finance to align
support behind National Climate plans
and to improve local level access to
financial flows and at this critical
time we know that more needs to be done
to ensure that the people at the
Forefront of climate change have the
tools and the support that are needed to
allow them to take further action
because too little support is reaching
the local level
and that local level is often thought of
last so our responsibility is to put the
last first
today we will hear from people
representing communities across the
world about their experiences of climate
change how their communities are working
together to cope with those impacts and
what the barriers are to taking further
action
this event is about their ideas their
change and our support
so thank you again for joining us today
thank you very much Secretary of State
and next I will invite our second
co-host Emily bohobosedola
Emily is a facilitator of the adaptation
working group of the official youth
constituents of the unfcc and also works
as a storytelling program director at
youth for nature over to you Emily very
welcome
hi all um good morning and I believe for
coming late I guess late is better than
never I think that kind of also applies
to like what we are doing here today
with adaptation because as probably we
have all heard for a few days now um
Finance is not reaching enough
application is not going far enough in
terms of planning and support for the
less developing countries so let's apply
this idea of like better life than never
to what we're doing today particularly
celebrate
um the goal of adaptation and I'm really
excited to be here today as a young
person but also as someone who works
collecting a series of young people
living and work on the ground and that
includes stories of adaptation is
stories of loss and damage and stories
of resilience
so you can imagine how sometimes you get
some really impactful stories about what
going on on the ground which can be
really inspiring and motivating to see
that you know young people are really in
this fight and giving it all but at the
same time you also get those stories
that are like more poignant and
sometimes like more critical and on the
narrative side about so many impacts
happening already but young people don't
have like enough support or resources to
scale up their projects as well as other
local community groups which is why I
was really excited to be able to hear
today for this event because it's the
first event of the day and it is about
Frontline communities and I found that
really good because it's a good way to
frame how this whole golden adaptation
and the whole adaptation should be we
should always be with focus on Frontline
communities first and on supporting
local communities on the ground both
through International mechanism as well
as to like National governments
um so yeah I'm hoping to be here and
here more of this amazing cases that we
have from on the ground and the last
thing is um I saw that all of you hurt a
boy before and I want to reiterate that
story telling can be really powerful way
to like communicate the stories but also
to communicate like messages and action
that needs to happen so I hope that the
words you hear too that you heard today
and you might hear from the rest of the
day I really stuck with stick with you
and you go back to your institutions to
your governments to your countries to
really be able to like help level up the
goal on adaptation and to really be able
to also level up all the finance we need
for like loss and damage
[Applause]
it's very exciting to see the presidency
really focusing on Frontline voices and
different mechanisms as Emily is
elaborating storytelling and all the
knowledge that is resident there
so in this session now we are going to
have a three speakers
we'll have two they are supposed to be
three uh I want at this moment to
welcome Dr Wilbur ochitilo governor of
vehicle County in Kenya
and uh Nasim Sheikh joining us virtually
from India Nasim is associate director
of soyam shikshan prayoga an
organization which promotes inclusive
sustainable Community Development
through women's empowerment
our other speaker is not available but
we are going to watch the video as well
uh she's executive director for table
and Indigenous organization focusing on
Research education policy advocacy
so I welcome you all on to the stage at
this moment
Governor will turn to you shortly but we
want to show the video first from Kenya
and thank you all to our speakers and
organizers for providing this
so uh please come on stage
so the video please
[Music]
[Music]
adaptation is the key because in any
case climate change now is with us
and he's not going to go away
we are going to stay with it for many
years to come
so we must adopt adapt to its vulgaris
and how we can live with it
therefore as kinds of Governors
we have resolved that we have to
mainstream
climate change
challenges
and opportunities in all our sectors of
the economy and as a result of that
we resolved that the county governments
must
enact policy and legal Frameworks
to be able to govern the mainstreaming
of climate change in all our sectors of
the economy
we will allow one to three percent
of our budget
to be
allocated or set aside for climate
change activities
five Counties have already enacted
this law and its operational and I'm
happy to know that my County Vega county
is one of the counties that has enacted
this
act and his become operational
foreign
would have to come up with the project
proposals real fundable project
proposals and then these proposals will
be evaluated independently using clearly
laid down guidelines
and from there once they approved the
word the climate change uh committees
will have to access to that money and be
able to execute their projects so this
is a project this is a program that is
going to go direct to the to the to the
Village to the people
this is the best way to mainstream
climate change to the local people
because it is the local people that are
suffering the bla the brand
of climate change yeah
at least
Uber
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you lots of transformation I see
there
from the first picture of uh pastoral is
drawing water from the ground they are
now able to irrigate and have lots of
water
so I think that's the change that people
want to see
so thank you very much governor
and uh
for joining us here today and hearing
about the climate the county climate
change funds and what it is doing to
enable change at the local level
so at this moment I'll ask the Secretary
of State if you have any follow-up
questions for the governor in terms of
what he has presented
in the video climate change is going to
be with us and with those communities
for many years to come so that that
mainstreaming of uh climate change
across all sectors is now the priority
um how has the county climate climate
change fund really worked drawing an
experts from different sectors to help
really get that down to the local level
foreign
first I want to take this opportunity to
thank the organizers of this meeting
it's a very good opportunity for me to
attend on behalf of the Council of
governance
who have given me the opportunity to
come and represent them I would like to
say that in Kenya we have two forms of
government the national government and
the county governments we have one
national government and 47 County
governments we work independently but we
are interdependent and therefore
we as kinds of Governors we have
realized that climate change is
a challenge that is going to remain with
us for many years and we found out that
it was going to be exceedingly difficult
for us to continue waiting for funding
from the national government and
development Partners so we chose we made
a resolution that we must put climate
change as part of our budgeting process
so what we agreed is that we come up
with the legislation and policy on how
to establish County government
climate change policies and laws and
that's what we have done so far 32
Counties have enacted both the policy
and the law and within that those legal
instruments we are who have established
County County climate change fund and
this allows each of the counties to set
funds aside
to to fund a climate change activities
at a local level and in our case our
local level is the world
and that's where all the activities are
to take place so I would like to say
that in the last two years we have seen
a significant development and
Improvement in the establishment of the
county climate change France and so far
I would say up to about
30 counties are already
operationalize the funds
um thank you Governor uh we have one
minute for this uh
so yeah we can hear the second question
and then move on thank you
um it's I think it's really exciting to
hear that you're leading from the front
and using that interestingly in the
video you show of course how women are
included in your prioritization and
indeed helping to design uh the projects
uh how are you working with other
marginalized groups as well in vahiga
County to make sure that their voice
needed their skills are or made best use
of
yes we within the legal framework of our
County a Government Act and policy we
have um created various institutions we
have the county climate change committee
and then we have the county
um the world Community Development
committees to mainstream climate change
so I would like to say that we work with
various stakeholders even the the Civil
societies we work together we have
brought them in this legal structures so
that we can bring everybody on board so
I would like to say that um apart from
the counties having their own funding
mechanism we through a project proposal
writing and so on we are receiving
support from various civil societies and
other stakeholders to ensure that um
climate change is mainstream
in all our sectors of the economy and
currently the main key area of focus is
on capacity building and creating
awareness among the people on the
importance of climate change and how
they should take it very serious
thank you very much Governor we will now
move from Kenya to India and uh what
Nasim is not with us but we'll watch the
video and after that we'll open up to
the audience for questions don't ask
them so as you watch please watch what
you want to ask for yeah thanks
foreign
associate program director since last 30
years we are working across seven states
of India which are disaster prone and
climate climate affected regions we
reached 500 000 women in last 30 years
2009 we realized after the severe
drought in Hawaii
we realized women are struggling for
food and while your security because
their man farmers are giving more
priority to the cash crops and women are
not having any say to in the agriculture
planning or decision making so we evolve
a model called women-led climate
resilient food and value security with
the help of community resilience fund to
do five things in in a model one we even
can recognize as a farmer in their
family and in agriculture sector second
women should be involved in a
agriculture planning for food security
and landlord security by diverse
diversifying various food crops third
they should be uh evolve the agriculture
to for the land and water security
by adopting organic agriculture organic
farming methods as well as the water
water management Technologies in their
Farms
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
good morning it is 10 o'clock you are
watching Sky News climate live we are on
the first day of the second week of the
UN climate conference cop 26 taking
place here in Glasgow and today it is
all about adaptation and loss we are
listening to the opening session taking
place hearing from some of the smaller
Nations
and their realities living with climate
change and the adaptations they have had
to make in order to survive just
listening in on this session now and
take you back
director
[Music]
does told she was not connected but
she's back now with us I thank you so
much I think we see lots of lessons here
of Entrepreneurship diversification one
woman having six to seven businesses
those are approaches to deal with the
climate impacts and it's really
impressive
so we will take two questions from the
audience each one of you has numbers and
you need to put on your microphone
and then we'll take two questions in the
same uh Nasim can you hear us
hello Nasim you might need to unmute
yourself
um
I hope she's not disconnected again
but we'll ask the questions
um
and the hopes will be able to answer
maybe
from the team that is here
I'm not sure if Nasim is still connected
if anybody knows if she's still on or
unmuted I'm not able to see that
so I think we'll take the two questions
now because we want this to be
participatory to share a reflection of
what you've seen
uh any if you want to ask a question
please put on your microphone
and
um
so uh that should be the one one six
hi am I Audible
yeah yeah thank you so this is uh lamia
mohsin from Bangladesh and uh I'm
speaking on behalf of uh you young the
younger constituency so
um my question to you is that um well
they seem to be having a little bit of
difficulty there getting some of their
planned speakers up to talk to us all so
we're going to drop out of that for a
moment and uh just a reminder we are on
day one of week two here in glasgow's
and the UN climate Conference of course
cop 26 and the pressure is on here in
Glasgow with less than a week to go
until the negotiations wrap up and the
cop president alok Sharma has insisted
that pledges are delivered to meet that
goal of halting global warming at 1.5
degrees and today the focus has switched
to the Nations that are already being
severely affected by climate change with
Rising levels and droughts making lands
uninhabitable we'd be hearing from some
of those who have been most affected
well over the next week Sky News climate
live is your dedicated channel for all
of the climate news and live events that
are taking place here at The Summit in
Glasgow but first Anne-Marie trevelyn
Secretary of State for international
trade are also chairing that session
that we were dipping into there and the
UK's International Champion on
adaptation and resilience for cop26
spoke to Sky news this morning about
that pledge to help the island nations
we're going to be announcing an extra
290 million pounds to support the least
developed countries and small island
states to help tackle the Urgent
challenges that they need to be
resilient and to adapt to the climate
shocks that are coming now even if we
fix the CO2 emissions challenge today we
would see the heightened climate impacts
continuing to affect those most
vulnerable countries for up to 100 years
to come so adaptation to the changing
climate in their own locally LED
communities is critical and this is
something we're going to be discussing
in depth today and hearing from voices
across the world about how they're
adapting and how they're becoming more
resilient to the day-to-day challenges
of these climate shocks
well Australia has said that it will
continue to sell coal for decades into
the future that was after refusing to
sign up to a deal pledging to phase out
fossil fuels at cop26 in Glasgow
Australia produces just four percent of
the world's thermal coal it's some of
the world's highest quality and that's
why we'll continue to have markets for
decades into the future and if they're
buying Hamish well we are selling demand
is increasing prices are up and we
expect that that increase in demand to
continue out to around 2030. we don't
expect countries will immediately go and
close down their coal-fired generation
particularly where they're new and in
fact some are still under construction
and if we aren't still in that market
somebody else will I would much rather
it be Australia's high quality product
all southeast Asia correspondent Siobhan
Robbins has all the letters for you now
from Sydney
well there's been a lot of pressure on
the Australian government coming into
cop26 it was just days before the
conference kicked off that they finally
managed to announce a commitment to net
zero emissions by 2050 then last week in
the first week of the conference we saw
that they failed to sign up to the
methane cup pledge they failed to sign
up to the list of countries and
organizations which have pledged to
phase out for coal power and today the
resources Minister has said very clearly
in an interview that they will not be
closing coal mines and they will not be
closing coal-powered fire stations now
he was speaking to ABC the broadcaster
here in Australia and he said that
there's still a huge demand for coal
around the world they said that they
expected that increasing demand to
continue till at least 2030 and in his
words if they want it we will sell it
and he said that if Australia wasn't
selling the coal which he claims is some
of the highest quality in the world than
other countries would step into the
breach he also doubled down saying that
they would meet the commitments that
they've made for 2050 but in his words
they wouldn't destroy the economy trying
to meet those commitments earlier and
that 300 000 people around the country
rely on coal now we've seen a very
similar message coming from the coal
communities that we've been visiting
over the last week saying that they
shouldn't be cutting coal mines now that
people need the money that is well paid
jobs that there's still demand that if
Australia steps back then someone else
will just step into the breach but the
big problem is that even though
Australia isn't a big Global emitter
emits around 1.3 percent of global
emissions it's a massive exporter of
coal it's the second biggest export of
coal in the world so in that sense
climate campaigners say it's essentially
like a world dealer of the dirtiest
fossil fuel in the world so how is the
rest of the world meant to step up and
meet emissions if Australia won't step
up and cut coal
now with ministers arriving for the
political stage of negotiations here at
[ __ ] 26 we've been to an area of the UK
which could become uninhabitable if
action isn't taken to tackle climate
change our west of England correspondent
Dan Whitehead reports now from the Isles
of silly
28 miles off the tip of Cornwall a
climate emergency is unfolding less than
a thousand years ago the Isles of silly
was a single landmass
now it's 140 islands and 2 000 residents
of battling the impact of rising sea
levels and intense storms this is our
the main defense of our water supply
which is just the other side of this
Bank protecting the Island's water from
sea contamination is just one of the
plans to ensure that future Generations
can still live here what's the worst
case scenario for the people of the Arts
of silly well evacuation basically
because we wouldn't be able to live here
I'm not talking about the next 10 years
20 or even 100 years but it could
eventually lead to evacuation
the council says it must robustly defend
the islands and is spending Millions on
protecting its Coastline Homes and
businesses the majority of the
population lives here in Hue town but
it's also one of the most vulnerable
parts of the Isles at its narrowest it's
around 130 meters wide sandwiched
between two beaches climate change is
literally squeezing and eroding this
community
[Music]
20 minutes by boat and we arrive at
Saint Agnes population 80. Farmers Aiden
and Grace rear cattle but also grow
crops for oils and gin so normally we'd
be harvesting these plants and they'd be
they'd be up like this intense dry
spells are making business difficult
Summers like this some have made us have
to rethink completely we're going to
we're having to look at investing in
permanent irrigation systems now to see
us through It's Just Happening too often
for us to risk year on year the crops
failing
but climate change isn't just impacting
those on land
the wildlife trust says in 2017 nearly
all seal pups died after being swept out
to sea too soon by a series of ferocious
storms
uh this is the main entrance to the
school fifteen-year-old will Schwartz is
a climate champion at the Island's only
school he's passionate and fearful about
the future of the sillies it definitely
worries me the future Generations won't
be able to have the same experiences
over here than than I did than my
generation did
um which is a little bit sad and it's a
bit worrying because
um it we might already be too late This
Island community is taking action now
knowing climate change he's posing an
urgent threat to its very way of life
Dan Whitehead Sky News on the Isles of
silly
well we understand that some of those
technical problems have sorted
themselves out now so we're going to
take you back to that first opening
event here on the first day of week two
all about adaptation and loss so the
hearing from the front line looking at
the communities who are dealing with
severe impacts of climate change already
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
study thanks to Victoria and others who
contributed for this to happen
so we've had three excellent examples of
what could happen if people at the front
line are supported and empowered
uh so I would like to really go deep and
understand uh and ask questions from
what we've heard we know that there are
challenges in trying to drive action at
the community level people who are
working at the front Lanes will have
really experiences of what that means
what they are struggling with all the
action we are hearing about uh working
at the front Lanes climate Justice is
about the daily struggles that everybody
is going through
so um
we could now we'll take some questions
from the audience to the panel to the
audience that is here and have more
discussion
and dive deeper into what this means to
support adaptation at the local level so
if you indicate on your microphone
um
that you need to ask a question then
we'll come to you unfortunately this
discussion could go on and on it's very
interesting but we don't have the time
so we have five minutes but we could
take one or two questions as well any
burning question 96
good morning everybody am I Audible
brilliant my name's Gabby and I'm here
from the international Committee of the
Red Cross I've been really grateful to
all the panelists and thank you for your
really interesting points I'm concerned
by the lack of inclusion of conflict
affected communities in conversations
around adaptation and I'm wondering if
the panelists have any ideas about how
we can improve and support adaptation
measures for people living in conflict
contexts because it's harder for them to
adapt and these communities are among
the most vulnerable to climate change
but the least able to adapt any ideas on
how we can support these communities
thank you I leave the panel to decide
who is well sorted Emily
hello yeah you can hear me
um yeah I think that's a really good
question I think that's also why often
within my working youth fortnite Channel
So within the work with other young
people in Django the official
constituency we often focus on having a
holistic approach to adaptation doesn't
mean that we have to consider the
context where application as action is
supposed to is meant to be set and
trying to understand how the communities
what is the makeup the community is
there and different challenges they face
Beyond just climate physical has also
impacts and that definitely includes a
conflict
um I believe that there are some
examples of ready of like Refugee
communities in different places and
these Place Community is trying to adapt
not only because they're trying to meet
the global golden adaptation but because
they have to uh you might have seen many
times like refugee camps being inundated
with flooding or like uh sometimes um
days like out of like storms and it's
very cold so they are just being forced
to adapt um so I think the question is
we can strengthen the collaboration
between like humanitarian Aid and
humanitarian organizations and policies
and like adaptation climate action which
is why we always Advocate to like
integrate climate within all sectors of
society and all plants uh I think that
the answer to this will be we need
better work between a humanitarian
um organizations and agencies and like
working together with the climate
adaptation bodies in terms of like
funding but as well as support and
capacity building on the ground so
trying to integrate and synergize those
will be really important
thank you for the trusting assembly yeah
out
yeah we have one minute sorry
so uh that time has run so quickly as I
said we could be here forever
very interesting issues but we don't
have the time unfortunately
so um I think we'll not be able to take
more questions
um
but just to wrap it up from what we've
seen from the poem really
we saw the rich ecosystems and the
people at the local level struggling
really on what could be if we look at
the future what could happen if we don't
do enough it was very touching very
emotional to see that we are likely to
lose that if we don't do more than what
we are doing now
and the local governments from the
governor decentralization and Devolution
of funding to the lowest levels and the
impact it could have the leadership that
emerges in the community the
prioritization of projects that are
informed by local voices is really
important and from India we see the role
of women the entrepreneurial skills
supporting Food Systems and consumption
patterns and all that which is really
key then the value of indigenous
Knowledge from Chile is something that
we really need to focus on on the
recognition point of view from climate
Justice angles so all this put together
we believe that we can drive local
action and we can make change happen
thank you very much for joining us today
it's really exciting to see this coming
together and together we continue and
fight on until the planet is saved thank
you
[Applause]
I'm going to come out of that we're
going to come out of that temporarily I
have a guest here with me in the studio
Aaron Mayer Wilderness Campaign director
Adam Adirondack Council in New York very
good morning to you tell us a little bit
about Adirondack Adirondack region or
the Adirondack Park in upstate New York
is the nation's largest Wilderness
protected area it's over 6 million Acres
you can actually fit uh most of the
nation's major national parks inside of
the Adirondack Park and you can fit the
state of Vermont inside of the
Adirondack park that's how massive it is
and more importantly it is also our
front line weapon and Tool in the battle
against climate change yeah so tell me a
bit about what you'll looking for
particularly today all about adaptation
and loss of natural habitat well one of
the critical pieces in with regards to
adaptation is preserving Wilderness
areas and equal green spaces last week
as you know there was the movement on
anti-logging and protecting uh forests
within South America Asia Etc but little
is being done in the First World
countries France England and the United
States on protecting Wilderness within
these countries but more importantly the
significant Wilderness areas can be our
bulwark in the fight against
anthropogenic climate change so for
adaptation aspects when we talk about
biodiversity and species protection
these are one of our front line tools so
front line Nations while they are going
to be facing the burden and shift with
regards to rising sea levels we can do a
lot more within first world Nations like
Britain Scotland United States and
France with regards to Wilderness
protection but also that adds into
biodiversity action as well the other
piece of this is also again we're going
to have to deal with whole populations
having to move so a lot of people talk
about top visas to countries that have
technology experts but right now we need
Wilderness experts we need Farmers so
some of the oldest skills known to
humanity land stewardship are actually
Frontline skills that we need in the
battle against anthropogenic climate
change we can absolutely make our
Nations much more welcoming and fun and
welcome up countries of diverse cultures
and as they have the superior skills
with regards to Wilderness protection
and adaptation so this can absolutely
deal with the burden of migration the
issue is how can these populations be
rolled into civil societies that have
the need and the need for people who
have those new unique skills to protect
Wilderness and Wilderness protection you
blew my mind when you were telling me
about how big it is there and you forget
actually that New York state is actually
a massive State isn't it so what what um
if you could
um sort of crystallize the benefits of
having that protected area and say what
what you've seen come out of that and
talk to the leaders of the world about
the importance and the benefits of doing
that well one of the things that they
talk about right now is financing and
financing mechanisms for technologies
that are going to so-called save us from
the brink but actually can also invest
in Wilderness areas and create jobs
expand Wilderness and these Wilderness
areas are essential for Bio diversity
protection which is there are cops on
biovert diversity protection but also
they are the source and Protectors of
our headquarters our freshwater ecology
depends upon these massive Wilderness
areas and the wetlands within them so
protecting massive air areas like the
Adirondacks or Wilderness around the
country or Wilderness in the UK you
actually are protecting Source Waters
you're actually protecting species
biodiversity but more importantly you're
creating the thousands of jobs so you
don't necessarily need work for factory
trees and see solar panel plants but we
definitely need Foresters Woodland
experts Trail Builders and more
importantly these areas become wonderful
places to hike and explore while doing
their function that have they were
created for since the beginning of the
dawn of time do you think that the
narrative suffers from a kind of a
false impression of trade-off between if
we're going to preserve this then we're
going to lose something in terms of our
you know our GDP growth in terms of jobs
we need to shift our mindset well the
thing is is that investing in Wilderness
is actually protecting and investing in
GDP think of wilderness as a green acid
just like they think of carbon and oil
and coal as a carbon rich or dirty asset
the question is asset shifting what are
you investing what are you putting the
market incentives toward either you're
going to put P toward the incentives
toward carbon and carbon killing Planet
killing activities such as gas oil and
coal or you can take those same billions
and trillions and invest them in
Wilderness and equal protection that
also deals with the current pending
crisis with regards to biodiversity and
species loss so would we not want to
invest in green assets that a protect
Humanity protect biodiversity protect
our source and Headwaters but also
provide a powerful economic incentive as
they say for Farmers Wilderness and even
average landowners we can absolutely
right now begin and investigate
investing in conservation easements
right here in the UK and France and the
United States that a provide income to
homeowners it's the same way of
providing and investing in Wells that
are pumping out oil to investors and
landowners who own Wells and have coal
the issue is the focus if our nations
are serious about really beating back
the worst effects of climate change you
want to invest in the biggest asset it's
actually right now accountable for
taking 23 percent of carbon out of the
atmosphere which is Wilderness
protection of course and Adirondack
where do you get your funding from is it
a mixture of federal of state and where
does it come from well because we are a
Wilderness advocacy organization we take
no government monies because one of the
things that happens with politics you
then have to as I say the he who pays
the Piper plays the tune we want to pay
a the tune of human ecology so we rely
upon donors and Foundations and so those
folks who really have priority with
regards to really a clear message on
Wilderness protection and not incentives
that pull you toward muting your message
to allow for carbon investment and
continuous continuation of business as
usual in the words of Greta thunberg
blah blah blah if you want to invest in
blah blah blah that's the way to do it
but we go to the people and as Greta
pointed out it is the people who in
their voices and their actions and their
donations that make wonderful
organizations like the Adirondack
Council powerful Mighty but equally more
importantly a asset that is rewarding us
with carbon sequestration within its six
million Acres fascinating talking to you
uh carry on talking to you all morning
but I'm being told that the cop 26
president Alex Sharma is on his feet and
he is addressing the headline events
which we understand is in time thought
the informal stock taking so presumably
we're going to hear a little bit about
where we are a week after these
negotiations have begun
the need for Vance climate action that
allow for more ambition on all issues
[Applause]
as you know the subsequent SBI have now
closed their sessions here in Glasgow
and I want to pay particular tribute and
really thank Marianne and tusi for their
great leadership last week and indeed
over the past two years and I give that
thank on behalf of the team indeed all
delegations
actually I don't know what this is uh
you can do this but uh could we have a a
a a a show of uh appreciation
thank you very much for this now this is
of course a good time to reflect on the
progress that we have made together and
assess whether we are on track to reach
the objectives that we have set for this
conference
so I proposed this morning that we hear
from the chairs of the subsidiary bodies
regarding the outcomes of their work
including those issues on which parties
were not able to conclude discussions
and following the update by the chairs I
will invite Archie young my chief
negotiator to update on the work in the
governing bodies and on the
consultations of the presidency that I
announced during the opening plenary I
will then outline how I see the work in
the second week of the conference moving
forward so let's get started and let me
first invite the subset chair to update
us on the work of the subset so chosey
you have the floor
good morning Mr President Madame
executive secretary French colleagues
thank you for this opportunity to
provide a brief summary report on the
work of the sub star
following or closing sub-supplanary on
Saturday night
during the past week parties engage in
negotiations on 19 items and sub items
of the substar agenda parties worked
constructively from the outset towards
producing draft text and overcame many
of the challenges that we Face due to
the covid-19 pandemic and the high
volume of work at this first in-person
session since almost two years
[Applause]
at all closing plenary on Saturday the
substance concluded its work on many
agenda items and the outcomes of the sub
staff work here in Glasgow will set the
direction of various activities in the
years to come including further
activities under the Nairobi work
program the Cornelia trying to work on
agriculture the sources of input for the
global stock Tech research and
systematic observation and the second
periodic review of the long-term goal
under the convention and overall
progress towards achieving it along the
many mandated and other events held at
this session
I'm also pleased to inform you that the
sub star also concluded this
consideration that provide further
guidance to the constituted bodies and
recommended draft decisions for
consideration and adoption by the cup
and CMA on the joint annual reports of
the technology executive committee and
the climate Technology Center Network
and the facilitated working group of the
local community and Indigenous peoples
platform which also include the proposed
second three years work plan of the fwg
on the report of Jacksonville Committee
of the warsawing international mechanism
the Surfside SBI recommended a set of
functions of this entire network and how
to advance it effectively including ways
to further develop its institutional
arrangements as well as further scaling
up action and support for the
implementation of relevant approaches to
averting minimizing and addressing loss
and damage in developing countries
I want to take this moment to thank all
of my co-chairs and co-facilitators and
the Secretary of teams for the hard work
I also take parties showing flexibility
and cooperation particularly in the last
two days of our work to reach agreement
on many outstanding issues under the
sextile
Mr President as we proceed to the second
week there are some outstanding issues
that will require a further technical
work and or political interventions when
closing the sub star on informed parties
that I will bring these issues to the
attention of the president for its
further guidance these issues are the
following
on article 6. negotiations progress well
and there is a determination to find
Solutions and compromises I've issued
four iterations of text on article 6.2
on article 6.4 and on article 6.8
respectively with the able help of my
co-facilitators
I've met with the head of delegations on
multiple locations and I hope that
further high level engagement will help
to further bring parties together
my texts have been bold and I believe
they can be bolder still there are some
areas where convergence is apparent and
resolution can be found with a little
further work there are limited number of
remaining difficult issues I have been
in close coordination with the
presidency in order to facilitate a
smooth transition of the world on these
matters from the substance to the CMA
the mood and tone in the room has been
very constructive we all know that
article 6 is a complex set of
instruments with many linkages and a
broader context
parties are aware of the delicate
linkages between items and we mess we
must remember that we are coming
together to develop a larger package
on transparency
at the technical level discussions have
been positive and focused the work
carried out by parties over the last one
and a half years has been brought into
the formal discussions as the starting
point at this session work on sub items
14 a to e was brought together under the
contact group into an overall decision
tax with technical annexes which have
been forwarded to the CMA
three main issues remain which are
application or flexibility
how flexibility should be reflected in
the methodological guidance on reporting
under enhanced transparency framework
reporting of the structured summary
whether it must be the table or could
also be in a narrative or other format
and program of support
many developing countries indicate that
well we're going to come out of that for
a moment many references there to
article
six you can get a little lost in all the
jargon there but we're going to talk
through what all of this means and what
the wider ramifications of it are and
joining me again in the studio is Aaron
Mayer Wilderness Campaign director at
Adirondack Council in New York article 6
all about carbon markets basically
trying to find a market solution to what
we're doing to the planet it's had a lot
of opposition hasn't it since since
Paris and it's taking up a lot of air
time what do you think well this is the
crisis since Paris as you know since
Paris a lot of the global governments
have made a shift in a turn to the right
many of the right are heavily connected
to free market Solutions but as we know
the market really isn't free there are
Port there are costs and when the cost
they call externalities which they tend
to dismiss from economic models an
externality is soil depletion is water
contamination whole rivers and whole
ecosystems destroyed and depleted those
are externalities so they're not
factored into market cost and one of the
big incentives for banks who want to
everybody wants to get in on the
financing of the solutions toward trying
to save the planet so if you try to
privatize This Global efforts to save
humanity and species that's the very
trouble that got us to where we are
right now there's one economic model
that that tries to describe everything
that's happening with the environment
and the planet called The Tragedy of the
commons whereby everybody wants to take
something out of it but there's no
Collective responsibility for those
negative externalities shuts off the
water who preserves it for the next
people to come along and have equal and
fair use when there is no incentive to
do that and when you put it in terms of
markets there are tremendous as they say
concentrations for the few at the
expense of the many and then all the
other systems that depend upon it one of
the things with carbon markets when they
talk about cap and trade or carbon you
know Carbon trading it allows polluters
to continue to pollute and make profits
it's like they say well it's an umbrella
hedge against the coming storm it's only
the mechanism the shaft with the
spindles but there's no cloth the rain
will still drench you the range of
climate debt destruction and damage will
still drench us all so carbon Market
Solutions while sounding sexy but as
they say in economics in the long term
we're all dead so those folks who have
short-term interest in investing in
carbon markets it's a distraction from
the action that states must take you
mentioned that it's a tendency of the
right of course to want to go back to
hang on to free market ideals exactly
it's also a tendency of the right isn't
it to be
influenced by big business interests a
lot of which are fossil fuels yes and
fast fuels have corrupted our democracy
the investment in lobbyists when we talk
about dark money that has altered our
democracy not for the better but for the
worst America right now is in the crisis
of just trying to protect voting rights
and these voting rights are critical to
elect representatives who will actually
act in the interest of not only the
American people but in The Sovereign
Global interests of the United States so
you're going to either elect officials
who recognize 97 percent of the Sciences
on climate change are right or you can
elect a right-wing band that says well
the three percent are right and so
therefore we're going to shift our
Global and National policy toward a
three percent interest that is
scientifically unsound and furthering us
along the path of Destruction some of
the oil companies are before Congress
aren't they at the moment and they're
having to answer to the millions of
pounds at dollars I should say hundreds
of millions of dollars that they've
poured into advertising can campaigns
effectively on social media a lot of
it's sowing misinformation absolutely
one of the downsides we're having a
national conversation on Facebook and
its influence and these very companies
can absolutely sell an argument and
package an argument to the gullible that
actually get people to operate against
their own interest and so not only are
we dealing with the investment in
shifting Congress and to protect their
assets remember
they have trillions of dollars in carbon
assets and if they just burned one half
of that investment we as a species are
gone we as a species are Instinct so
they have a market incentive to keep
business as usual because they're making
a profit but yes in the short term they
will live high off the hog but in the
long term seven generations down our
grandchildren our great grandchild our
great great grandchildren will be on a
planet as they say that may not be
inhabitable and as they say and puts
their existence as they say in serious
serious doubt so we are arguing for the
long term and organizations like the
Adirondack Council and pushing back
against corporate funding and that
Corruption of democracy not only just in
the United States but globally to move
us into say the disincentifies real
serious action so putting out terms like
carbon markets and all these other
monetized terms sounds like progress and
and it's easy for a politician to stand
on the stage and say we have Solutions
again the borrow credit statement blah
blah blah those are not Solutions those
are Whispers of death and more
importantly we know better we're not
listening to the scientists we're not
listening to the ecologists we're not
listening to those folks who have sound
Investments but that requires a shift
from the market based economy that's
anchored in carbon to shifting to a full
Market based economy that's anchored in
ecology they don't they don't own the
forest they don't own the Wilderness
they don't own the watersheds and so
that is sadly still in the public domain
and an individual holder hands so I love
a farmer that we can incentivize versus
a oil Baron I love a uh uh a as I say a
family that has a large holding of
forests that you know it to me is more
significant than a coal Baron and what's
so interesting about this forgive me for
interrupting is is that you've got a
president in the White House that stood
on a pretty big policy platform of
supporting the environment exactly and
he's having to row back isn't he on a
lot of the things that he's wanting to
do namely because one individual one
Senator his own his own that's one of
his own party but his senator who was
anchored and call Rich call controlled
West Virginia so you essentially have is
it president Mansion or is it President
Biden President Biden has a very
powerful and ambitious 30 by 30 agenda
what does that mean he wants to protect
30 percent of America's wilderness
okay within the next 30 Years so that is
the proper investment but unfortunately
his build it back better program is now
being compromised and rolled back now
just to get it went from uh 3.7 trillion
now it's down to maybe a million a
trillion and a half and they keep
throwing the trillion dollars up but
they don't realize it's just that's over
10 years but when they talk about our
military budget they talk about in terms
of year to year it's about 700 million
so annualized seven years that's seven
trillion we're we're no longer at War
but we're putting 7 trillion in our
defense expenditure and we just rolled
back a safety net that would have been
the largest the most significant step
forward and a market signaling point in
Direction and changing direction of
investing in Wilderness investing in
those ecologies that actually helped
save the planet and it all is held up by
again the market influence the market
dominated the market control law
lobbyist who controls one senator who
right now has more power than the
president of the United States but it's
not just the United States and balances
should work it is
Boris Johnson right here in the UK it is
from Francois macron in France these
corrupting fluents of lobbyists and
backdoor deals and remember it's not
just putting them out lobbyists it's
giving little jobs the corruption is
like things and jobs and incentives to
their children their friends you know
they're finding many ways to take care
of people to get a policy outcome that
they desire but a policy outcome that
jeopardizes all Humanity all right Aaron
don't go away we're going to take you
back to our headline event now and the
international trade secretary Anne-Marie
trevelyn is speaking
of the adaptation committee and
especially work on the global goal for
adaptation is indeed needed
further
I did forward the membership of the
adaptation fund parties did not agree on
the A Way Forward
however I did also pick up a substantive
exchange among parties on this on this
matter
with regard to the methods relating to
the form of the impact of implementation
of response measures serving the
convention the Kyoto Protocol and the
Paris agreement parties were indeed
quite close to a resolution however
they did run out of time and would
benefit from a few more hours together
some of these issues as I mentioned
would need only a little more time to
cross the finance line and for others
they are indeed a part of the political
process that will take place this week
I trust that you can continue to work on
Solutions under the guidance of the
presidency and I'm confident that you'll
find a way for the forward as you so
clearly have demonstrated this week
when concluding I would like to thank
the presidency the soapster chair and
the secretaries I've been told that we
have got some sound issues and perhaps
you might be thinking there that the
voice speaking to you is not Anne-Marie
trebellian so apologies for that but the
good news is that I still have Aaron
Mayer here in the studio with me now
Aaron you've come a long way yes you've
come across the Atlantic for this
conference what are you looking for
specifically right now the hope
the belief is still to Lobby on the
floor pull aside members of our
delegations members from New York
State's delegation is here today
commissioner basil segals on behalf of
Governor Kathy hulkel is here to talk
about efforts that are happening in the
state of New York uh governor hulkel in
the state of New York and commissioner
basil their sagos they are absolutely
bullish on protecting more Wilderness
areas so where our government is at the
federal level is diverging New York
State like many local States and small
towns and Villages that Bloomberg has
funded and supported are actually taking
very very positive steps and actions but
they're not enough we need to do more
but the fact is is that we have an
opportunity to elevate the voice of the
trees in the forests as Dr Seuss in The
Lorax says I speak for the trees because
they can't nobody else and they don't
speak for themselves so speaking for the
tree speaking for bidens 30 by 30 we
actually have a federal policy on the
ground so it's not wishful thinking the
issue is that there is a plan there is a
policy there right now is the issue of
the politics and the will of whether or
not they will invest in protecting 30
percent of America's Wilderness and lead
by example to inspire England
France Germany and Australia to also
follow that suit we are at a significant
Crossroads the ipcc report says we are
at that red line and that red lines what
we do now in the next three years is the
most critical years in human Destiny and
so pushing for that Wilderness
protection right now and knowing that
Wilderness protection can create jobs
protect it again provide a carb massive
carbon sink again 23 percent of the
carbon that's sucked out of the
atmospheres by Wilderness all right the
other the other percent is is ocean but
we have ocean acidification as a result
but Wilderness and oceans are the
biggest carbon sinks known right now and
they are much more affordable and they
are much more resilient but equally and
more importantly they are a
labor-intensive efforts that would
create more jobs and so the issue is you
know is if government takes the
incentives from the carbon markets by
incentives that means American taxpayers
are spending tens of billions annually
for oil companies Coal companies and if
that could be redeployed toward
Wilderness we would have the 30 by 30 it
wouldn't be 30 by 30. it would be 30 and
10. okay so you can actually protect 30
or even more percentage even greater but
it's a market shift and governments do
create markets people got this that big
myth that the private sector creates
money all government has to do is get
out of the way that's the myth they tell
the average taxpayer but actually what
they're saying is taxpayers plug your
ears government give us the money that
the taxpayers are giving you and we will
do things you're going to see some
change and so we want our democracy
where the taxpayers investment is
getting the best return on dollars and
that is saving the planet okay Aaron
thank you very much I'm told we have now
sorted out our sound issues there on
that opening session apologies for the
technical problems
previously let's have another listen in
community
plans
representing
helping to share best practice and
mobilized action
but a step change is needed to address
the gaps in ambition or mitigation on
adaptation and on finance
to support the delivery of the Paris
climate change of women goals
as the only international organization
dedicated entirely to accelerating
adaptation action
to Global Center on adaptation GCA with
the doctor of fair Cohen and to help is
ready to pray as a part in this
transformation
to urgently accelerate climate action
and ensure Finance is Flowing to support
this transition especially for the
protest and the most vulnerable
there is no time to waste thank you for
your commitment and Leadership
thank you so much Secretary General
Banky moon for your strong words of of
guidance let's move to the next uh
speaker Deputy Secretary General of the
United Nations Amina Mohammed we're all
nowhere we're all over she has been a
very strong Advocate on adaptation
particularly also for Africa and also
calling for this 50 50 splits between
mitigation and adaptation Finance so
let's listen to Amina thank you
communication around the world people
are struggling with climate change the
signs are all around us floods droughts
heat and catastrophic storms the human
toll is devastating lost lives and
livelihoods displacement and migration
and young people losing hope in the
future
and the burden will fall
disproportionately on the poor and
vulnerable who contribute at least to
this problem
as we discrete emissions we must also
increase ambition on adaptation
all countries but especially developing
ones need to support to build climate
resilient and green economies
the adaptation Finance Gap is
considerable
the latest oecd report shows that just
over 20 billion dollars about 25 of
total climate Finance goes to adaptation
this is a fraction of the expected 300
billion dollars needed by 2030. that's
why the Secretary General continues to
call on all donors to allocate at least
50 percent of their climate Finance to
adaptation
multilateral development Banks should
start as soon as possible support for
adaptation and resilience not only saves
lives and livelihoods it can also help
countries recover from covid-19 by
investing in green jobs and
infrastructure
step by step we are moving towards a
more resilient future and the
implementation of the sdgs
but we must do more we must accelerate
and scale up Solutions like these and
that's what this meeting is all about
I look forward to hearing the results of
your discussion let's continue joining
forces to boost adaptation finance and
deliver the green economic
transformation that Humanity requires
for our planet for our children and for
our future thank you
thank you so much Amina Mohammed deputy
secretary General also reminding us this
is a growth agenda this is a jobs agenda
this is a opportunity agenda but also
let's not be naive those who are
suffering the most as we said are living
in the global South but also it's the
youth constituency we already see
massive impacts across the globe but
that will also increase over time so let
us hear from a youth voice and a message
of urgency Emily Dola please
foreign
good morning good afternoon or evening
depending on where you are live
streaming or seeing from thanks so much
for being here and I really mean that
because I think that throughout the last
week all of us has been hearing a lot of
frustration out of like protests about
how action on the applications and
damage is moving really slow however I
just came from like the first meeting
for the presidency which was on
Frontline communities and I realized
that we can still win this great you can
still do this but it really depends like
how fast can we mobilize funding and
resources for like adaptation action led
by local groups on the ground and by
local governments which isn't getting
there fast enough
I also realized that we really need to
make sure that we break through to some
negotiation items particularly around
how to better operational like Santiago
Network for loss and damage as well as
how to better support countries to
develop personal adaptation plans and
Communications this includes support
from finance and resources but we must
be careful with climate Finance we
really want to advocate for more climate
Finance be given in the forms of Grants
and not simply in terms of loan science
economic equity is really important for
the academic capacity of countries and
that has been highlighted in reports by
the ipcc as well
uh more or less but not least we want
all countries our ministers to consider
when they're thinking about
vulnerability to climate adaptation and
to lose and damage they might look as
communities as like diverse members in
which some groups are more affected by
the impulse of climate change and others
from women and girls to disabled people
to the early
um through young people that means that
any adaptation plans must be responsive
to these differences around social
marginalization and discrimination they
must consider this and also at the same
time we know that nature has been a
really big theme in this scope as we
really hope that countries and ministers
across all apartments are planning for
development and energy infrastructure
plants they consider how those might
affect nature and in turn might be late
to like less electricity capacity across
their own country so please do keep that
in mind when you take back your
countries and try to take all these
words we're speaking here to plan some
action happening on the ground thank you
so much months
thank you so much Emily also for being
so forward-leaning and calling upon all
of us to be bold speaking about boldness
I would like now to invite a very good
friend and my brother president adashina
of the African Development Bank last
week you sir you launched this Africa
adaptation acceleration program and
together we also brought forward an
Africa adaptation youth Council so that
the voice of Emily and all the other
emilies in the world will not only be
listened to but also be used as an as an
agent of chains president abashina
foreign
brother Patrick and thanks for your
Global Leadership on this crucially
important issue of adaptation
it's horrible ministers ladies and
gentlemen
climate change is having devastating
effects in Africa
droughts
plots and climate-induced local swarms
are devastating farmlands and increasing
food insecurity and destroying
livelihoods or smallholder Farmers
majority of whom are women
Africa loses seven billion dollars to 15
billion dollars a year to climate change
and this could rise to 50 billion
dollars a year by 2040.
let's have no doubt about it
climate adaptation is Africa's main
priority
yet Africa has very little resources to
adapt to climate change as he received
only three percent of global climate
finest
but we are not deterred
the African Development Bank is taking
the lead in tackling Africa's climate
challenges
we will double our climate Finance to 25
billion dollars by 2025 and I will make
40 percent of our total investments in
climate
I'm very pleased that the Afghan
Development Bank is the only
multilateral developing Bank to have
achieved an exceeded parity for
adaptation
we surpassed 50-50
parity between adaptation and mitigation
in 2018 and we reached 20 55 percent and
63 percent for climate adaptation in
2019 and 2020 respectively
we are greatly honored by United Nations
Secretary General Anthony Gutierrez
endorsement of the bank's leadership
on climate adaptation in his speech to
United Nations General Assembly
we have raised our ambition even further
together with Patrick and for my U.S
Secretary General benkimoon the African
Development Bank and the global Center
for adaptation launched the African
adaptation acceleration program
our goal is to raise 25 billion dollars
for adaptation
it's the largest the boldest and the
most transformative climate adaptation
ever put forward for Africa
the African Development Bank has
committed 12.5 billion dollars of this
amount and we look forward to develop
partner countries uh to help us to
deliver on the 12.5 billion dollars
balance
this support will have amazing impacts
it will deliver a climate advisory
services to 30 million farmers and
pastoralists
it will support one million Youth and
unlock 3 billion dollars in financing
for them are cop 26 just last week
Friday Patrick and I unveiled a one
million dollar prize for you to adapt
that was awarded to 10 businesses run by
young people on climate adaptation in
Africa and 70 of the winners are women
that's very good because when women win
Africa wins
to build the voices of young people you
know Africa's climate adaptation the
African Development Bank and the global
synapro adaptation is announcing the
launch of the African youth climate
Council
the council will amplify the voices the
ideas the Innovations and the businesses
of young people on climate in Africa it
will help to increase adaptation Finance
to over five billion dollars a year
including from the private sector
we're already delivering massive impacts
for the most vulnerable that I mean and
my dear sister talked about who are
actually the smallholder farmers of
Africa the African development Banks
Technologies for African agricultural
transformation we call it rtaat has
provided 11 million farmers in 29
countries with climate resident
agricultural Technologies all that in
just two years
this includes heat tolerant with
varieties on 1.8 million hectares in
Ethiopia Sudan and six other countries
areas warming from climate change
and it is supported 5.2 million
households now growing drought tolerant
maze on 840 000 hectares in South Africa
in southern Africa to support and
deliver support for climate adaptation
at scale for farmers and to feed Africa
in the face of climate change African
heads of state and global leaders agree
to create What's called the financing
facility for food security and nutrition
in Africa
this facility will walk within the
framework of the African adaptation
acceleration program with the aim of
raising a billion dollars to allow
African agriculture to adapt to climate
change the facility will deliver a
climate resilient Technologies for 40
million farmers and produce an
additional 100 million metric tons of
food this will be enough to feed 200
million people and reduce hunger in
Africa by 80 percent as I close let me
say the facilities Vision can be
summarized in our action slogan one for
200 meaning one billion dollars to feed
200 million Africans the African
adaptation acceleration program is
Africa's bold solution to climate
adaptation let's show our support for
Africa by providing the 12.5 billion
dollars needed to meet the financing
Target for the program Goodwill Equity
Trust and support are critical let's
deliver that for Africa thank you very
much
[Applause]
thank you so much Akin for your strong
words and also for reminding all of us
of your three agenda items action action
action indeed and putting women at the
center the next speaker is really
speaking uh to that agenda and approach
straightforward Murray pluginsu World
Bank managing director the World Bank
has been in the adaptation Finance Arena
foreign many many years it was the first
one to announce in katowic a few years
ago the 50 50 splits madam here's the
floor
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
brothers and sisters Emily and all the
youth that you represent good day thank
you secretary ban ki-moon and the global
Center on adaptation for the opportunity
to join you today to put a spotlight on
the adaptation agenda on this Eighth Day
of the cop adaptation day it's an
important moment for our shared
commitment to building resilience on in
climate vulnerable communities
especially women who are most affected
around the globe we know why climate
change could push 132 million more
people into extreme poverty by 2030.
216 million people will also have to
suffer from internal migration across
all regions because of emerging hot
spots this is why climate finance that
drives more ambitious and adaptation
action on the ground is at the heart of
our climate and development work
in 2020 the World Bank adaptation
Finance amounted to nine billion dollars
also in 2020 the World Bank accounted
for over half of multilateral climate
Finance to developing countries and over
two-thirds of adaptation finance a lot
of that goes to Ida our poorest
countries at Grants with grants as well
as very concessional terms
this translates into tangible outcomes
that benefit people for example in
Ethiopia about 900 000 hectares of land
is now being sustainably managed
benefiting some 2.5 million people this
work has led to better water access less
soil erosion improved food security
higher yields and diversified sources of
income result resulting in more
resilient livelihoods a more interesting
example is what we call the green fiscal
stimulus which has the triple winds
programs cash for work programs that
rest restore degradation on in
Landscapes and seascapes in various
countries in various of our client
countries achieve a triple win it
creates cash for work for the
communities that are being affected by
the pandemic and at the same time as
they restore the land or the seascapes
they're improving their livelihoods and
lives in the future and also obviously
contributing hugely to adaptation and
resilience
it will take more to deliver real change
as all of you have said
for adaptation is essential to Growing
investment in resilience over the next
decade we have a key role to play in
this endeavor
another exam
[Music]
a World Bank
100 million from International
commercial lenders to improve access to
portable water service reducing the
population's exposure to climate-related
shocks and water scarcity that's an
example of public private partnership
and at the national level the bank has
made concerted efforts to help countries
develop and Implement Financial
Protection strategies against climate
shocks and help countries respond and
recover more quickly to disasters the
adaptation forward development approach
is rooted in our new climate action plan
which is a guide for our climate lending
35 percent of our financing will go for
climate and half of that will go to
adaptation and we are contributing a
quarter of this 100 billion that
everybody is talking about and uh on
youth I just wanted to mention we have a
useful climate program in the bank they
recently created a connect for climate
youth program at The pre-cup Summit in
Milan and I encourage all youth to also
participate in that we are committed
partner to this GCA and this ministerial
dialogue from as a means to reach our
shared goal of global adaptation action
that reduces the vulnerability of the
millions of people in developing
countries I thank you
thank you so much Mary also reminding us
that it is also about access to finance
and unleashing the Firepower of the
private sector indeed so we heard from
framing speakers global leaders setting
the scene this is a ministerial dialogue
so let's now turn the table and hear
from the ministers it's going to be a
little bit of a dance I would like to
invite a set of ministers the first set
to come to the stage sit here and then
you you make your remarks from the
lecture so the following countries
please Canada Denmark France Costa Rica
Ghana and the Netherlands
please I
mean so when honorable ministers are
taking the seat it gives me also the
time to introduce our next speaker who
has just been appointed in his in his
job as the new minister of environment
the climate change in Canada Stephen
Gilbert please the floor is yoursos
thank you very much Patrick
[Music]
last week prime minister Trudeau
referred to a town in Canada that was
obliterated by wildfires earlier this
year every country here has a community
like litten drowned or burned or Blown
Away by some freak weather event that
has somehow started to become routine
climate change is happening it's here we
must adapt
it's one of the key themes of comp26 and
we are committed to doing our part in
Canada like elsewhere across the world
climate change is disproportionately
impacting those who are the most
vulnerable four of every five people
displaced by changing climate are women
earlier this year we double our pledge
for international climate Finance over
five years from that we've also
committed to put at least 40 percent of
our 5.3 billion dollars toward climate
adaptation
foreign
first Canada is re-upping with 37.5
million dollars over five years that the
least developed countries funding to
help some of the most vulnerable
communities adapt second Canada will
make its first ever contribution of up
to 10 million dollars to the adaptation
fund and third Canada will provide up to
10 million dollars for the national
adaptation program Global Network but we
cannot talk about fighting climate
change and adapting to its impact
without talking about nature
this we know in Canada nature stores
carbon it both takes the brunt of
climate change impact and buffers us
from the worst of it questions
this is my 19th cup I attended the first
one in Berlin as a wide-eyed activist
I'm still an optimist because I know
that we the people here at car 26 have
it within us to ensure adaptation action
reaches those on the planet who need it
the most thank you miss you
thank you so much Stephen also or for
your government being so determined to
drive adaptation action uh globally
let's move to the next speaker Minister
for development and Order cooperation in
Denmark Fleming Muller mertensen also a
chair of a board member of the GCA
thank you very much
climate changes Define it's really the
defining challenge of our time
the consequences are already disrupting
food production and water supply
coastal zones and cities are threatened
in particular Africa and small island
States the people who are hit the
hottest often have the fewest resources
to adapt to the consequences therefore
it is key that the developed countries
collectively rise our our climate
Finance
Denmark will walk the talk
through the benefit of the poorest and
most vulnerable countries and people by
2023 we aim to deliver more than half a
million a half a billion US Dollars
annual in the grant-based financing for
climate action on top of that Denmark
will continue to mobilize climate
Finance from other sources including
private Investments
in total we expect to contribute at
least one percent of the collective
Target of 100 billion dollars on top of
that
I have just launched a pilot gym with
State guarantees a shame has the
potential to mobilize an additional 450
to 600 million US dollars in the pile of
face
climate change adaptation is a necessity
floods broads and Cyclones are becoming
more frequent poor people scrubs
livestocks and houses are threatened
this is why developing countries as well
as U.N Secretary General guterres call
for increasing financing for climate
changes adaptation the Danish government
is stepping up we will dedicate at least
60 percent of our grant-based climate
finances to adaptation we also need to
link implementations of adaption action
with inclusion and equality to ensure
that the we prioritize the vulnerable
communities women and employment
creation not least for young people
we must step up our efforts to assist
people in the front line of climate
included
included catastrophes and devastating
weather events let's all rise our
financing we need all hands on deck
thank you very much
thank you so much honorable Minister
also for your government stepping up the
share of adaptation finance and
particularly also the grand Finance
component to it very much appreciated
indeed and thank you for your big
announcement on this today let's move to
another part of the world Central
America Costa Rica we have with us a
bold Minister a very forward-leaning
Minister who basically is sort of the
adaptation Champion not only at home but
for the whole world Andrea Messer please
thank you Patrick excellencies and thank
you for the invitation this is a very
important date in the cup we're talking
about the adaptation date and it's so
important because
um probably adaptation is the agenda
that will allow us to really address
inequality and we cannot solve the
climate crisis if we don't address
inequality so this is a very Central
aspect and for this reason we really
appreciate all the commitments that we
are hearing all the work I see
um Minister travilion here thank you for
all your work and what you're doing
because it is critical to attend all the
vulnerable regions and let me share with
you some specific data about Central
America which is also a very vulnerable
region in the world Central America has
been hidden by two hurricanes in 2020
first hurricane itta early November 2020
and then Eureka hurricane Iota just a
couple of weeks after
has been considered one of the world's
weather-related disasters in the region
in the last two decades and it generated
devastated
impacts in infrastructures in life and
and this is just to remind us that it is
so critical to not leave any region
behind this is a call for that to also
considered every region when we are
addressing and talking about adaptation
and we have the vehicles we need to
generate capacities we have the national
adaptation plans and the adaptation
Communications we need to transform
their into investment projects and we
need to continue accelerate the
mobilization of
investments in infrastructure in
agriculture and in those areas that are
critical tri-corridor in the region and
also remember that investing in nature
is probably the wisest investment that
we can do in America
effective manner to generate resilience
thank you
thank you so much Madam Minister
reminding us let's leave no region
behind and let's work with nature not
against it
um let's go to a different region in
these Africa we spoke about it quite a
bit so president other scene already
introduced the adaptation imperative for
Africa let's to the minister from
environment of Ghana Dr cuckoo please
foreign
excellencies
I'll protocol dearly observed
on behalf of my president
as the President of the Republic of
Ghana and another
I am pleased to address this high level
climate adaptation and laws and damage
day of our ad cop 26 years
it is important to note that all
speakers
have been happening
on the point that the lease emitters are
the worst
hits and thus Africa continent
very unfortunate indeed but what we do
less species flora and fauna have many
times born had a cause to adapt to new
ecological Energies
now it is the time
of mankind to adapt
to a biophysical environment that has
been so damaged
by mankind itself
so we find ourselves here
Mr chairman the major climate change
impacts affect all sectors of Ghana's
development
Dan has been our ability to climate
change is in large part the defined by
its exposure to the various impacts
such as droughts floods
and sea erosion
and it has become almost an annual event
with great
consequences on agriculture
energy production and distribution
water
Forestry
among other sectors
however
we in Ghana are happy to partner Global
Center on adaptation which has set a
global adaptation agenda purposely to
support vulnerable countries on
adaptation
it is therefore first of its kind
of global centers who believes
and also have plans for implementation
of adaptation actions of climate
vulnerable countries
as we speak now
GCE has two major studies in Ghana
looking for opportunities for investment
in nature-based and City infrastructures
and also planning to include Ghana
in
its adaptation education program
and just for your information that Ghana
has a high priority in climate change
education as education tends to improve
understanding and appreciation of
climate change impacts
on our communities and on our people as
a whole
what we've learned
from the ipcc's latest report is that
Africa is warming faster than any
continent of the world and this comes
with a loss and damage associated with
climate change
in this respect Ghana stands with a
common positions of the African group
and climate vulnerable forum that major
emitters come has to come with
additional ambition in this cup 26 to
further reduce their emissions and
support the 50 50 adaptation and
mitigation balance
it is of great importance to the
vulnerable climate change countries that
this dream is realized
additionally
because we are already living inside a
western climate emergency
ambition raising must now Encompass
adaptation as a major priority
we have a battle on two fronts and we
need to constantly and also accelerate
adaptation action to keep us safe
it is very disheartening to note
that
the global
goal on adaptation GCA
as per article 7.1 of Pari agreement
is still non-operational
and at this current negotiation rooms
African negotiators are finding it very
difficult pushing this agenda through
and
goes to
emphasize the fact that
what has been said at the higher levels
of commitment by our colleagues in the
g20s and the developed countries
are far different from what is happening
in the negotiations rooms it's very
unfortunate and sad indeed
how to make progress
to save the planet and to save the world
it is now
we from Ghana and Africa calls on the
entire Committee of Nations
to truly
commit ourselves to the fight of climate
change adopting adaptation as a major
ingredient and a major step thank you
for your audience God bless you thank
you so much Dr kokufu also putting
people at the center and investing in
human capital indeed let's go to a
different part of the world again let's
come back to Europe we're going to come
out of that for a minute we've got our
guests with us still in the studio Aaron
Mayer Wilderness Campaign director at
Adirondack Council in New York listening
there Aaron to lots of
representatives from some of the you
know development banks around the world
talking about how they're going to get
money to these countries that need it
for adaptation for protection what do
you think of some of these Solutions is
it a step forward are they as good as
they're making them sound well they are
definitely a step forward but there
needs to be more in fact these steps are
actually where we should be running this
is where the direction should be
a lot of the models are treating this as
an aside or you know the we have to do a
little bit of something here while we
take care of this big problem but the
big problem is actually in the areas of
many of these developing nations that
have significant uh Wilderness and
forests that are huge assets and they
actually happen to be in the tropical
region I mean to the extent that we are
able to invest and protect the
Wilderness in Brazil Colombia Venezuela
uh Central and South America these have
huge ecological assets that right now
are as significant an investment to
protect and save that will create jobs
in these local economies and provide
tremendous incentives for people not to
migrate out but to stay there and
protect these assets and be front-line
Warriors as they say in the worst
effects against climate change right now
financing other mechanisms and solutions
such as carbon trading and all these
other schemes you know the other side of
Finance is how does bankers and
investment companies make money it's the
fees it's just like a broker so you get
fees and one or two percent of 100
future 100 trillion dollar investment
this could be it's a big money for Wall
Street it's big money you know for Fleet
Street in here in uh in the UK there's
big money there but see this is the
perverse incentive because again people
get caught up that it's okay only if we
divert a significant portion of global
assets to the market solution versus the
direct line communities that are as I
say facing the change and also are the
vital resources of bulwark against the
worsening effects so the adaptation
models if done right if scaled right
could absolutely be protecting against
out migration because we need people in
those countries to protect the
Wilderness to protect species in those
areas and yes do them at as I say living
wage jobs not as little token handouts
here and there are charitable handouts
here and there but treat them as as the
as I said the ecological Factory workers
that they are they are just as important
as an assembly line worker in a Nissan
Leaf plant or any green vehicle plant
these communities are just as essential
the issue is The Vision by which how do
we look at and frame and monetize these
incentives and monetize that direction
Aaron I've got a bit of a bit of a
surprise for you we're going to put it
here oh on the screen you don't know
what it is do you here it is
look it's you and some guy
who's that that is President Obama and
this is what I call that Summit of Hope
just uh right after Paris and taking him
into the Wilderness and getting him to
see the power of the Wilderness and not
only being a barometer of the impacts of
climate change that there is some of the
oldest growth forests some of the trees
in Yosemite in the wilderness uh in the
Sierras you know has seen the birth of
Jesus Christ I mean they've been around
that long uh when you have an ancient I
was born in Yosemite
you know one never knows but uh we do
know from The Book of Genesis the spirit
of God moved upon the waters and so we
do know that spirit and secretary but
he's here he's here today
what role do you think he can play how
important is it that somebody like
former president of the United States
comes to Glasgow
again re-emphasizing the message and the
hope that he spoke back at comp in Paris
again telling the world the moment is
now then we were talking about having
serious investment in Nations living up
to their commitments and pledges the
Nations have not delivered globally our
Nations have not delivered and the
damage and loss all the things that
we're talking about today we're five
years in arrears and remember
the planet has the last vote Obama
hopefully coming today will rally and
Inspire folks to live on and deliver on
their commitments to humanity to save
the planet uh I know he gets it when he
saw the damage what keeps him awake at
night listen he was there in the
wilderness and he sees the Power of the
Wilderness infrastructure but he also
saw the Wilderness being that barometer
he saw the damage of the drought on
trees that literally literally thousands
of years old he's seeing them die so
they've they've survived all sorts of
threats and risks and storms Etc but the
effects of anthropogenic climate change
is what's killing them now and so he
gets that and that sense of urgency in
him seeing it with his own eyes being in
the wilderness really moved him and
moved him even more much more so to
action could he have done more during
his presidency remember he is facing the
same all threat that President Obama
Biden is facing that is our domestic
politics with an unhealthy democracy we
can't save the planet where the
unhealthy democracy we can't focus our
national priorities on our Global
priorities such as saving the planet
such as fighting back climate change
right now people are you know that are
in power that he face denied the
existence of climate change in fact they
cheekily said well the climate is
changing every day yes the weather is
changing every day but climate is that
massive Global planetary system by which
influences the weather and it's more
moisture more heat more drought more
wind more damage but equally more
importantly it is something that had we
acted on aggressively five to six years
ago we would not be in the state we are
in now so him being here today reminding
the world of action to do but also his
administration is a reminder of how
right-wing politics and the politics of
climate denialism is killing the planet
what was what was like working in the
environmental ad sey
it was horrible you have a president
that was dismantling the very agencies
the very scientists that were actually
doing the math and the modeling so they
figured just like they dismantled our
postal system that if you can dismantle
the science
you can now be gone and and just deny it
so out of sight and out of mind so this
past administration was the worst
environmental disaster known to humanity
and history were recorded as such it is
just a matter of fact and the receipts
are there of the scientists of the
panels that he dismantled of the
regulatory regime of the global
commitments remember to put a period on
his sentence or his epithet is that he
pulled out of Paris it can't get any
worse than that when your denialism and
your ignorance takes you to the point of
saying what me worry about Humanity he
pulled out so it was a disaster but
hopefully now uh we while we cannot
really make up for lost time it's also
difficult isn't it to criticize China to
criticize Russia when the U.S was absent
for four years well listen to be honest
is that all global politics
and the competition for Global markets
plays out on areas where we need
International cooperation
pulling apart right now over issues of
trade and the standard Politics
undermines the global effort and the
global will for us to act collectively
on behalf of humanity this is the time
we need to be working and collaborating
with China with Russia with India we how
do we regain that Paris Spirit of where
we work and move away from the politics
of Destruction again another Legacy of
the Trump Administration these economic
fights which have now spilled over into
public and international policy fights
are now putting us all at risk we can
see how a faltering or a failing
democracy can destabilize important
International efforts such as to fight
against climate change all right Aaron
it's been really interesting talking to
you this morning thank you for all of
your time with us here on Sky News so
let's take a look at some of the key
developments of the summit so far well
on Monday India of course the world's
third largest to put a date on reaching
Net Zero by 2070 but Prime Minister Modi
promised though that his country would
get half of its energy from renewable
sources by the end of this decade well
Tuesday saw more than 100 countries 85
percent of the world's forests signed up
to end deforestation by 2030 and more
than a hundred Nations also promised to
cut methane emissions by at least 30
percent before the end of the decade
well money came next of course crucial
to underpinning all of these pledges and
financial institutions announced that
130 trillion dollars in assets would be
available to invest in the push to Net
Zero and then on Friday we saw more than
40 countries committed to phasing out
coal the dirtiest fossil fuel that there
is however the world's biggest coal
dependent countries including the US
Australia and China didn't sign up to
that pledge and 45 countries pledged to
shift to sustainable farming methods
that was during nature day on Saturday
well adaptation is becoming increasingly
important in the fight against climate
change and today the UK government is
calling for Urgent action to help
developing countries become more
resilient to our warming World we're
joining me now in the studio is David
Jackson local development Finance
director at the un's capital Development
Fund a very good morning to you David
what have you made of what you've been
hearing today well so far so good but I
think we're still stuck in the old
mindset and we need to move to climate
Finance 2.0 if you like if you think
about it human beings we've always
adapted to climate change if and if you
go to the North Pole you wear different
clothes and if you go to the Sahara
Desert so adaptation and houses look
different in different parts of the
world adaptation is not new to us but
the scale of the upcoming adaptation
that we're all going to need to do is
very significant we need to move Beyond
projects it's not going to be solved by
a project it's going to be sold by
mechanisms systems new ways of life this
is just what my previous guest was
saying as well he was listening to some
of the contributors there from some of
the development Banks and saying well
it's good but actually we need to
rethink this and it felt a bit on
finance day that we were hearing about
you know an evolved way of financing it
seems more Blended Finance more bringing
together public and private but you're
saying that actually beneath that we
still need to see another thing it was a
good step forwards because I think on
finance day people understood again that
it's not like I've got this project here
I've got that project there it's about
systems of Finance some of which have
yet to be invented as new ways of
transferring resources for both
mitigation and adaptation when it comes
to adaptation we're too late we're not
going to hit the 1.5 degrees but let's
be positive we're going to have to
really invest in new ways of living
across the world developing countries
and developed countries and that's going
to need new types of financial
incentives new types of systems and
we're finally going to need to
understand that adaptation is inherently
local even the way Glasgow adapts will
be the way that different from the way
that London exactly adapt so local
authorities local governments local
communities local businesses are going
to need systems and financial systems
they can connect to to take this
adaptation to scale it's not going to be
a little project here a little project
there I mean there's plenty of money out
there isn't there I mean if you look at
the savings glut that's built up over
the last few decades there's trillions
that's right out there how do you get
hold of that money and get it where it
needs to go I'm just thinking here very
high level very basic stuff not complex
fine it has to be adapt locally reported
globally because the the the local ad
the problem with adaptation is it's so
localized even one Street's different
from another Street the adaptation
actions have to be defined very locally
but then the criteria the methodology
the way in which it's done has to be
done in a way that you can then
aggregate that and Report globally to
capture that those resources and that's
what we're setting up over the United
Nations Capital development and our
partners and many others in the UK
government too mechanisms that enable
multiple local adaptations but
Consolidated Global reporting to be able
to capture that Finance because if
people are going to pay for it they want
to see the results they're just going to
say I mean
estimating what the return is going to
be on those things must be very
difficult right yes but risk comes in
here because if you're adapting you're
reducing risk and you can look at the
insurance industry they're a little bit
ahead of the curve you know now they
need to be in the risk business well
that's right yes nowadays if you want to
build a con a beachfront condo in Miami
good luck getting the insurance so that
shows that the world is waking up that
some you know it's going to be a
different climate in the future
adaptation is now part of the game so
that's if you can get the global
reporting if you get the methodologies
that are accepted globally the standards
then you can see reductions in risk and
that's the way that the private sector
Finance comes in because if you're
investing in reduction in Risk you're
investing in creating opportunities
country risk is also important isn't it
because a lot of the countries that need
this money I was interviewing a
representative from Armenia this morning
and that that country's credit rating is
such that it's very expensive for them
to tap up Global Capital markets so how
do we get around that well I think the
way around that there's two levels that
we get around that one is that you're
talking about the Sovereign there the
sub the government's own risk but within
that at the sub sovereign level you can
have individual projects individual
Investments that are not necessarily
attached to that and if you can then
make sure that those Investments are
truly green they are truly having an
effect on adaptational mitigation you
can get the investment rated with a
credit rating for the investment for the
investment vehicle which can be a better
credit rating than for The Sovereign now
when it comes to the Sovereign level we
need to look again a little bit at the
way that those in those those credit
ratings are calculated so that it's
possible to free up a little bit of
balance sheet to be able to invest at at
the local level one of the things we're
also working on is something called
securitization yeah so which means you
you take from the balance sheets of
banks that are already invested in
things you take some of that you you
farm that off to the Pension funds and
then you free up that balance sheet for
fresh investment Into Climate green
infrastructure do so in a better way
than the securitizations were done just
before the financial crisis hopefully
similar methodology but totally
different application and and here
you're doing it with a solid basis
because that was based on property price
speculation here we're based basically
on investing in the future so actually
the assets are going to grow in value
because this is the future so you heard
Boris Johnson talking about follow the
sun together with nahendra Modi where
they were saying you know why can't
sunny places export their energy to
cloudy places
you have to get the systems to get that
kind of investment done at the local
level it'll be multiple local
Investments David we're waiting to hear
from former president Barack Obama who
is going to be addressing this session
that you can see hasn't yet gone
underway behind behind us there
um
does having him here make a difference
well of course it's wonderful to have
former presidents here but I think the
most important thing is the future this
is really about the Next Generation they
are the people who are going to drive
this forwards it's our children our
grandchildren we have to build a future
for them and that's why it has to be
Finance 2.0 adaptation 2.0 new ways of
working understanding the importance of
local the importance of local
governments local institutions local
businesses and that mechanisms systems
that maybe don't exist yet are going to
have to come into existence to do this
at scale it's similar to the recovery of
it I mean it's bigger than the recovery
of Europe from the second world war it's
a big thing that needs to be done and so
I think the Young Generation get that
and you know it's great that people are
here but it's good it's the Next
Generation the ones we need to look to
as we make that shift David we're going
to see a lot of what were very valuable
assets become worthless that's right
quite quickly what happens to them well
that's a very very good point so that
again has to be Blended in so what
happens to them let's make use of them
let's find ways that that's that we can
rethink repurpose reimagine how they are
used and that they can imagine a coal
mine well there's lots of different ways
you can reimagine it I mean there's lots
of needs out out in out there in in
Britain and in many other parts of the
country there's lots of skills that can
be reinvested in there's a there's a
physical lands that can be used there's
the buildings that can be used there's
the skills that can be used as a
community that can be used you know
there's a lot of local qualities local
skills local assets
you you don't think of how do you
reimagine the coal mine because that's
gone you think of how do I reimagine
this community here with all itself
before it became yeah or what it could
be in the future because maybe it was
before it was a coal mine it was also
something else so we need effectively a
bad bank for old economy assets that we
do need something like that I know
that's been spoken about and I think
it's a good idea and that bad bank then
needs to be plugged into the new bank so
that you know the resources can also not
only go to rehabilitate that type of
thing but also feed into investing into
the new areas maybe the coal mining
Community could be the first thing in a
new agreement wouldn't that be
interesting all right well look we're
going to take us now to plenary one
we're hearing the opening remarks
they're getting underway we are
expecting to hear from President Obama
let's listen in government in case it
wasn't already apparent the U.S is back
at the cop and we are here to live up to
President Biden commitment to listen to
the science expand equity and inclusion
in climate at this critical moment
and work to ensure to keep warming to
1.5 degrees
the effort that we are undertaking now
to mitigate and adapt to climate change
is especially urgent in fact it's an
existential threat to island nations
it reminds me of the Voyage of the
Hokulea a type of traditional Hawaiian
sailing ship that first brought
Hawaiians to their Island home these
ships and the brave Islanders who sailed
them thousands of miles without
mechanical propulsion or navigational
instruments connected the islands of the
Pacific across vast distances
it required courage Ingenuity and an
unshaking belief that we are all
connected on this planet and we are
better off together
no man is an island as John Dunn's
Famous poem reminds us and in that
Spirit last week just a week ago
President Biden announced a new
initiative called prepare the
president's emergency plan for
adaptation and resilience
under prepare the U.S will focus its
adaptation and resilience work on
locally LED efforts to increase
knowledge improve planning and mobilize
resources to meet the climate challenges
and increase the adaptation needs of the
world today
I am very excited to announce that as
part of our prepare commitments we will
be providing an initial nine million
dollars to support something called the
local 2030 Islands Network
the local 2030 network is an Innovative
island-led Coalition of Partners
committed to achieving net zero
emissions and adapting to climate change
it advances Community Driven adaptation
by building on the traditional knowledge
of the early Polynesian voyagers and
their historic resilience in adapting to
climate change
so please so I'm so pleased that the
leaders the initial leaders on our panel
today are here to help us explain about
the the network and tell us why it's so
important to them so let me introduce
them first we have the prime minister of
Fiji Frank by nimarama
we also have the minister of climate
resilience and environment of Grenada
Simon Steele
and the climate Envoy for the Marshall
Islands Kathy jitnall Kitchener these
are founding members of the local Island
2030 Network
I'm also pleased that the state
department will be partnering with NOAA
my former Agency on the local 2030
network and on the 7th annual our oceans
conference along with the mighty nation
of Palau that will be held the 15th or
the 16th and 17th of February in Palau
I also want to introduce the moderator
of the panel the administrator of the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration and the under Secretary
of Commerce Dr Rick spinrad
and now it is my great honor to
introduce a giant in Ocean and Global
conservation who really needs no
introduction
he took the concept of fully and
completely protected Marine protected
areas in the U.S and he's supersized it
greatly expanding the papahana makuakea
Marine National monument in Hawaii
the Pacific remote Islands Marine
National Monument throughout the Pacific
and he even created the first Marine
National monument in the Atlantic Ocean
called the canyons and sea mounts
National Monument off the coast of
secretary Kerry's home state of
Massachusetts
he's our first island president his
leadership on Marine protection is so
significant that a newly discovered
species of tropical fish was named the
Obama basslet in his honor
so everyone please join me in giving a
warm Hawaiian Islands welcome to
President Barack Obama
[Applause]
well thank you so much good morning
everybody it is wonderful to be here
um
let me just first of all point out that
that fish that Monica mentioned was a
very small fish
uh
uh but but it meant a lot to me uh I am
so pleased to be here with all of you
for this important discussion about how
to support efforts to
promote Island resilience
as probably all of you know at this
point I have been shaped by my
experience growing up
in Hawaii and I know that uh
our outstanding Governor from Hawaii uh
governor ige and first lady are both
here and and uh I'm grateful for all
that they've done to protect
our Islands I am an island kid
and while I was President I was proud of
the work that we did uh
to work with island nations who were
most vulnerable to changing climate
even as they did far far less if
anything than the larger Nations and
actually causing the climate crisis and
I remember in Paris
uh we had a meeting of a group of
Island leaders
to hear directly from them about how
climate change was already having an
impact and
the the the the
effect of that meeting uh was outsized
it it had a huge impact in part because
these leaders were able to communicate
in very concrete human terms uh what so
often is
a bunch of abstract numbers
people were being affected in very
specific and immediate ways and tragic
ways and so it put
images and and faces and emotions and
moral Authority behind
the efforts to form the Paris Accords
it was a reminder that
um
that in many ways our islands are
uh
the canary and the coal mine in this
situation uh that that they are
sending a message now
that if
we don't act and act boldly it's going
to be too late
um and it also highlighted the fact that
this is not something that's 10 or 20 or
30 years down the road this is now and
we have to act now to help with
adaptation and resilience which I know
is a theme of cop 26 today
um
so I don't think I I genuinely think we
would not have gotten as ambitious an
agreement
in Paris had it not been for the
willingness and the capacity of violent
Nations to step up and be hurt
and for that we want to thank you
but I also think that it's important for
us to recognize that as was true
five years ago
we have not done enough
and our islands are
threatened more than ever
and that's part of the reason why I'm so
proud of the fact that the US government
and Joe Biden is giving the issue the
attention that it deserves uh his
commitment to provide an additional
three billion dollars
to
extend a hand and support those who are
most vulnerable to the impact of climate
change including Islands can make a
difference
that's a substantial increase in support
it's an investment in our common
Humanity it's an essential piece of the
work that's being done here
in Glasgow and I think it is
representative of
an essential element of anything that
we're going to do collectively on the
climate crisis a recognition that all of
us have a part to play all of us have
work to do all of us have sacrifices to
make but
uh those of us who live in big wealthy
Nations
those of us who helped to precipitate
the problem
we have an added burden
to make sure that we are working with
and helping and assisting those who are
less responsible and less able but are
more vulnerable
to this oncoming crisis
also as a Hawaiian
and as American I was proud to see the
Biden Administration embrace the local
2030
Island Network through this initiative
U.S islands like Hawaii Guam
and Puerto Rico will connect with Island
Nations and islands around the world as
they take the lead in pursuing
sustainable development and adapting to
climate change you know initiatives like
these help provide badly needed
resources but they also Forge
connections
by sharing best practices and forging a
Unity of purpose they offer a model
of what's needed around the world if
we're going to make sure that the
promises
in Paris and the promises that are made
here in Glasgow are actually kept and
that we are continually increasing
ambition until we get a full handle on
this problem
I'll close just by saying there's an old
Hawaiian proverb uh
that's uh roughly translated into
unite to move forward
it's a reminder that if you
want to paddle a canoe you better all be
rolling in the same direction and at the
same time
every ore has to move in unison that's
the only way that you move forward and
that's the kind of spirit that we need
to protect our Island resources that's
the kind of spirit we need to protect
our people it's a different mindset
it's an open spirit and that's what all
of you bring to bear in this discussion
some of you are small countries
don't have large populations but you got
a lot of heart
and you are protectors and preservers of
what is a vital link for all Humanity to
this planet
um
your voice has to be heard and uh I'm
glad you're here representing those
Nations and making sure that the rest of
the world is listening
all right
[Applause]
thank you President Obama
let me start by thanking assistant
secretary Monica Medina for that very
warm introduction and opening remarks
and a special thanks to you President
Obama for joining our Island event and
providing these insightful remarks that
we've heard drawing from your own
personal perspectives growing up in an
island nation
your leadership on climate change and
issues strongly reflected by your
actions as presidents including the
expansion of the papahanama kuakea
national Marine Monument to become one
of the largest protected areas in the
world is just one example conserving our
marine and Coastal ecosystems protects
vital blue carbon
and provides additional support to
climate stressed resources such as coral
reefs
we're also very fortunate as you heard
from assistant secretary Medina to have
a panel of leaders and Visionaries for
our discussions here today and I have
the privilege of serving as a moderator
for what I'm sure will be a very
fruitful discussion we're joined by The
Honorable prime minister of the Republic
of Fiji Frank bynemarama
who has been a powerful voice on climate
change issues in the Pacific and for
islands around the world for many years
thank you sir
I'm also pleased to introduce Minister
for climate resilience and environment
Simon Steele from Grenada an outstanding
champion of climate actions in the
Caribbean thank you sir
and I'm especially pleased to introduce
Kathy gentill Kitchener co-founder and
director of the Republic of the Marshall
islands-based non-profit jojikum
dedicated to Youth and environmentalism
and an Obama leader Asia Pacific and
member of the inaugural design cohort
are among the most vulnerable to climate
change but they're also at the Forefront
of efforts to adapt and develop Pathways
to climate resilience and sustainable
development today's event is an
opportunity to highlight the unique
challenges and opportunities facing our
island nations and ways we can share
Solutions and learn from one another
knowledge and information particularly
that which is co-developed and tailored
through Community engagement are key
elements of efforts to address climate
risks and vulnerabilities and Foster
adaptation Solutions
climate products Services decision
support tools and early Warning Systems
enable us to better prepare for and
respond to climate change the more we
know the more we can do
this information is most useful when
it's developed through scientific
collaboration and Partnerships local
Ingenuity and sharing of experiences
across National borders I would like to
affirm reaffirm the commitment of my
agency the U.S National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration to working
with the global Community to Foster
adaptation and resilience we are pleased
to be part of Partnerships that bring
people together to address the climate
challenge such as the local 2030 Islands
Network that you heard mentioned by
President Obama and assistant secretary
Medina
and the new Pacific Regional Training
Center for ocean acidification a
critical issue
hosted by Fiji
it's a good example of countries and
organizations coming together to Monitor
and understand changing conditions in
the environment toward this end I'm
honored to have this opportunity to
moderate today's Roundtable to learn
from three renowned champions of Island
adaptation and resilience so let's begin
and I'd like to start by asking a
question that is specific to what's
going on here in Glasgow these two weeks
the questions for the the question for
the panel is what Paris promised the
world we are charged to deliver here in
Glasgow with one week of this Milestone
Gathering behind us now what has most
excited you about the global pledges and
actions announced both for your Island's
Clean Energy Future and for adaptation
and resilience prime minister I'd ask
you to start please
thank you and good morning to you good
morning Mr President
Mr President uh seeing you here remind
me of cup 21 in Paris
they are the American and Pacific
leadership rallied the world
to produce the Paris Accords then we are
now here in Glasgow
to turn into action Mr President thank
you for making the tip
to be with us in Glasgow
we all know that you are the son son of
a Pacific
and I need not remind you of the threat
excuse me our region faces from a
changing climate
alongside the late great uh Tony De
Broome and I understand
a great niece is here with us
you help to deliver the Paris Accords
that we are here to enact that Legacy of
leadership is at stake here in Glasgow
and so is the very existence of fiji's
low-lying neighbors of tualu of Kiribati
and the Marshall Islands
we welcome the new commitments
made last week
but with due respect Mr President I can
feel any excitement for them because
they are timid and inadequate
several major players of course as you
know are missing in action
and others have shown up with
insufficient commitments
that have succeeded only in erecting
speed bumps on the road that leads to
the wrong side of 1.5 degrees of warming
developed nations are failing us
we are the ones with the resources and
the technology to make a difference
yet they have left potential
for clean energy and Temptation on the
table by missing the 100 billion pledge
two years running
among others the USA is woefully short
of paying his fair share of climate
Finance
now we
are the most vulnerable are told to suck
it up and wait until 2023.
there's no delay
Mr President to build resilience across
features over 110 populated areas
Islands 13 Cyclones 13 Cyclones have
stuck Fiji and struck Fiji since we
redified the Paris agreement
13. and through our uh and through our
carbon emissions are negligible
we are embracing the opportunity of Net
Zero and the good green jobs and energy
Independence can create
but Money Matters plain and simple
these changes require upfront
Investments we cannot always Mount alone
we are doing all we can
Fiji is creating
an entire economic sector that is
dedicated to building climate resilience
through a groundbreaking climate change
Act
we have legally empowered ourselves to
become Net Zero
hana's nature-based Solutions
fortify our infrastructure and hold the
private sector accountable while also
unlocking its uh Innovative potential
that is all good
but we're also breaking ground in tragic
ways we never wanted
Pacific Nations uh have collectively
agreed to a declaration to preserve the
sovereignty of our Waters even if land
masses are Lost in Thailand
Fiji has a trust fund
for relocation that finances the
movement of communities and
infrastructure to Higher Ground
and we have offered Refuge to the people
of Kiribati
to value in the event their nations are
lost to the rising Seas
so to answer your question sir
no I'm not excited I'm not prepared
along with every Vision to do what is
necessary to secure our future and
ensure we can grow our Island economy in
a warmer world
we have Solutions
we're developing more
and we are always Keen to share our
experiences just as we are Keen to grow
small island development stage share of
access to finance
thank you sir
thank you prime minister
for that particularly insightful and
cogent comment and very candid
observations very much appreciate that
Minister Steele would you care to
comment
thing is like yeah
so thank you thank you chair and
recognizing President Obama Island kids
fellow panelists
what we've seen over the past week are a
string of announcements and initiatives
whether that's on call phase out the
global methane pledge commitments to end
public financing for the fossil fuel
sector
new initiatives and signatories on
Forest deforestation clean Technologies
nature
agriculture
these are all important for ambition and
action
for the global financial markets for the
private sector
and it's important to recognize the
leadership of the UK presidency in
driving
um that the process to get us here
and for my great ocean state of Grenada
future of countries like mine depend on
whether or not coal seams around the
world are left as they are so these are
all important steps that we are seeing
here in Glasgow
however
we also need to see the promises trickle
down to meaningful action on the grounds
in countries and communities that are
working hard to transition to clean
energy and a more resilient future
across different sectors energy
transport Waste Management Etc
call for a just transition is very very
real
now back to the international stage
let's be clear
our job here in Glasgow is far from done
political heavy lifting is needed in
this second week if we are to
collectively deliver
on keeping truly keeping 1.5 Within
Reach
the science tells us we still have a
long way to go the latest NDC synthesis
numbers tells us we're tracking to a 14
increase in emissions rather than a 45
reduction by 20 30. and that we are on a
2.7 degrees C of warming trajectory not
the 1.5 that we here we and the islands
so desperately need the global Community
to hit
so efforts need to continue immediately
after this cop and our decisions here in
Glasgow need to translate into more
ambitious EX accelerated
starting in 2022
as
President Obama said you know climate
change for us in the islands is not an
abstract thing it's real and it's lived
every single day
and if mitigation is a marathon getting
us to that 1.5 degree Target
adaptation and resilience building is
the Sprint as we battled the daily
impacts of intense hurricanes more
frequent floods droughts and the urgency
to protect lives and livelihoods
challenges are still before us the
announcements heard promising
but we need to deliver still on very
very concrete actions sure thank you
thank you Minister Steele
director General Kitchener would you
care to comment on the question of what
has most excited you halfway through cop
26.
um
thank you excellencies President Obama
um I'm really grateful to be here and to
be able to speak on behalf of Marshall
Islands I think it was a Paleo for the
Tongan scholar who said smallness is a
state of mind and I think that's really
applicable to the ways in which
Islanders despite being small in land
mass has been really holding their
weight throughout these conversations
and holding the line in these
negotiations so we're really grateful to
also be a part of the local 2030 Islands
Network that will allow us to continue
to exchange knowledge across Islands
um as far as uh this this week and and
the pledges that have been coming
forward we are excited about the
different pledges like the deforestation
pledge and the global methane pledge
um I think that a pledge is a good start
however we are more looking closely at
implementation so what comes after these
pledges what comes with action uh and
that's where we'll really be holding the
larger States accountable for how they
will deliver on these commitments
um as chair of the as convener of the
high ambition Coalition we're also
really uh excited about the statement
that has been put forward
um that includes doubling adaptation
commitments and I was I was also
appreciative of the announcement that
was just made from the US about
um increasing adaptation uh funding uh I
think the thing that I'm most concerned
about coming into this cop was
increasing funds for adaptation
specifically for the Marshall Islands
we're looking at several billions of
dollars for implementing our national
adaptation plan we've received
preliminary studies that show us
estimates and it's tens of billions
for reclaiming land for elevating parts
of our land for internal migration
within our islands and these are really
extreme hard adaptation solutions that
are coming down the barrel and they're
coming down quite soon considering the
fact that we are passing the 1.5 degree
threshold very very soon
so for us adaptation implementation is
is key the funding towards that is what
we really need so it was really exciting
for us to see that the signatories have
committed to doubling adaptation within
the high ambition Coalition statement
and another important thing that commits
signatories within the statement is when
we negotiate the new Target in 2025
these targets will be based off of
science as we know the 100 billion
dollar Mark was made was sort of just an
estimate that wasn't based off of real
science and if we look at the science
and the costs it'll probably be a lot
more than the 100 billion that we have
right now and so seeing that and and
being able to base it off of science I
think that will really help with
managing uh the type of funds that that
small island States really need to be
able to implement the adaptation
structures that that we're planning the
adaptation Pathways that we're currently
planning so um I think I'll just close
with that and uh thank you again for
having us here thank you
thank you director
I wonder President Obama if you want
make some comments based on what you've
heard
I do
uh
first of all
um
let me start with Kathy who I had a
chance to know uh
some of the work we've been doing in the
foundation I think she is an example of
the kind of next generation of leader
that is
on the front lines of this fight and
whose voices are necessary us old folks
the gray-haired
types or the no hair types
um you know uh sometimes I think make
excuses for
why things aren't happening as fast as
they should and this and that and the
the youthful impatience and willingness
to
speak truth to power and and do the work
I think is is
absolutely vital I'll be addressing that
a little bit later both in plenary
speech I'm making and then a round table
with young leaders from around the world
um two themes that I I heard discussed
that I think uh are important
um
the first is the importance of
follow-through look uh you know I've
been talking to John Kerry and others
who've been involved in in pushing as
hard as
we can
in in this process
and
I know that
as was true in Paris
the current national plans cumulatively
and pledges made still don't get
to
1.5
um
and
so there are times I think when that
makes us feel discouraged naturally
um
on the other hand
if everybody follows through with just
the commitments that have already been
made at this conference
the latest
data indicates that we'd get to about
1.8
now that's a big if
that's still not enough
on the other hand there's a difference
as
the prime minister of Fiji mentioned
the number 2.7
2.7 and 1.8 makes a big difference for
island nations
and then 1.8 and 1.5 that makes a big
difference so every degree to which we
can
mitigate counts and I think that
uh as Kathy indicated as both the
ministers uh implied
if we are following through on all the
bold pronouncements and steps that and
pledges that have been made
uh then that's real progress not enough
but it moves Us in the right direction
but that does require ongoing activism
in between these cup conferences
and it means
citizen pressure
on both public sector and private sector
actors to ensure that there is actual
follow-up and that we're actually
documenting that and island nations I
think have a story to tell because
they're on the front lines
of making sure and calling larger
Nations the main emitters into account
if they are not following up so and you
know what I'll give you a platform for
that if that's the case
um
the second point I I very much liked uh
What uh Minister uh still
uh talked about when he says mitigation
is a marathon adaptation resilience is a
Sprint I I I think that is a good
framework to think about this
um
that the truth is is that
uh organizing
a lot of Nations around the world
all of whom have you know Legacy Energy
Systems vested interests politics Etc
coordinating all that to move
the entire planet's energy Grid in a New
Direction
uh
is not going to happen overnight
uh
it has to happen and we have to push but
they're going to be you know we're going
to go forward they're going to be some
setbacks they're going to be laggards
right Nations that don't follow through
um and so we just have to be determined
and have
massive patience and
just continually pound away at the
problem
um but resilience and adaptation that
has to happen now
and I think having that parallel
time frame
recognizing that in in assisting island
nations particularly those that almost
by definition had nothing to do with
this problem and are bearing the effects
most severely
um
there there is a a
documentable finite amount of money that
can go to helping those countries right
now and the sooner we start helping in
fact
uh the better off we're going to be and
in some cases the more money we'll save
rather than waiting until
things are crumbling and you've got
crisis
um so I I do think that it is
worthwhile
for
uh
countries to
think about green funding
both in terms of long term but allocate
and and be definite have a have a clear
plan about what is it that we're doing
to help those who are In Harm's Way as
we speak
um and and that's something again that I
would be uh
I would be open to uh championing as as
we go forward so uh I appreciate very
much the input
I think I'm going to get dragged to
another uh portion of this Gathering so
I'm going to be taking my leave at the
moment I may see you I'm sure I'll see
some of you in the next
thing I I do want to say one last thing
and this is
uh for Richard and Monica
um
the politics in the United States are
not always easy as you may have noticed
um and uh
my successor
maybe wasn't as interested in climate
science as I was it turned out
um
but there are a lot of people in the U.S
government
who care about this deeply and work
really hard and are invested our
politics are not always easy
and uh yeah we're not unique in that
regard but but I think it's a it's a
good time now because most of the time
when you are dealing with
uh and and sometimes expressing
frustration towards U.S delegates at
these cop conferences I just want you to
know that they're the ones who are
championing your cause
back home it's just that you know we got
our own politics that we got to deal
with but these are outstanding public
servants and scientists who really care
about these issues and are listening to
you sometimes it'll feel I I guess
specifically to the the point that the
prime minister of
Fiji mentioned sometimes it may feel
like the United States
like some other countries are not always
moving as fast or following through on
their commitments as much as we'd like
it's it's
um
it's not because it's not for lack of
trying by the kinds of people who you
are working with here
um but you know we've got our
we've got our contentious uh battle
it's one of the things about democracy
it turns out you don't always get your
way
um
but uh two chairs for democracy as they
say I think that was Mr Churchill who
who said that
um so so I I I want to say that because
both Richard Monica John Kerry
um
those folks are really working hard and
care about this issue a lot uh and and
so that's not to let us off the hook
when we're not doing what we need to do
but it's just uh for you to know that uh
uh oftentimes you're preaching to the
choir when it comes to the delegations
that are represented here so
all right see you guys in a bit thank
you
thank you President Obama for your
strong clear-eyed leadership throughout
and also for that shout out to the civil
servants around the world who are
working hard to solve the problems
[Laughter]
you got some Applause for that
thank you sir that's not unique to the
U.S
we have
um just about 10 minutes we have another
important question that I'd like to ask
of the panel and it as I was listening
carefully to your comments uh there was
a statement that you made Minister
Steele about having a core for a just
transition and so this question deals
with the progress that we have made and
I'd like to ask you specifically in that
regard we have together made grade
strides in our understanding of climate
change and its impacts on people and
places as well as options to address
them we've improved information tools
and decision Support Services how have
these approaches helped Island
communities cultures economies and
ecosystems adapt and become more
resilient
prime minister
thank you
thank you for that statement I'd like to
say that today
no Nation can claim connection not of
ignorance
we have known about this threat for
decades
and the most recent ipcc reporters put a
mountain of evidence behind the
experiences
my people have lived and confirmed our
worst fears
the latest science shows us we must have
Global emission by 2030.
uh half Global emission by 2030 and
achieved Net Zero by 2050. if we fail
the 1.5 degree aspiration of the Paris
agreement will be our epitaph
one arena in which Fiji has made
remarkable progress is our work to
reduce disaster risks I have mentioned
about Cyclone Winston often in 2016.
Cyclone Winston struck Fiji as the
strongest Cyclone to ever make landfall
south of the Equator
claimed 44 lives and wiped out one third
of the valuable GDP in 36 hours
by improving Community Readiness to this
new breed of super storms we've saved
the countless lives through the 12
storms that have followed on Winston's
Hills
our forecasting tech technology have has
been upgraded and communities now know
what to do and uh where to go and most
importantly
they know how to treat advanced storm
warnings with deadly seriousness
uh building of new and existing science
Fiji is working with the UK space agency
and NORAD
to enhance our ability to map sea level
rise improve Coastal development
manager climate induced human migration
and perform hydrological and wind
modeling to better understand
our Island's renewable energy potential
our economy
however is still extremely vulnerable
our networks of infrastructure will take
years and massive levels of investment
to properly adapt our roads schools
homes utility infrastructure all of it
must now meet new standards of
resilience
and we know that adapting now is more
affordable than rebuilding from the
rubble of cyclone-driven devastation
nature is one way
we're delivering solutions that work and
that we can afford
the number one request I hear when I
visit Fijian communities is for new
seawalls
concrete civils are a major investment
they take time
and they demand huge resources but we've
learned that Eco walls made of Boulders
big boulders mangroves and vetiver grass
work just as well if not even better
the cheaper
communities already have much of the
expertise needed to do the work to build
them
and we are also beginning constructions
on an Eggroll uh
photovoltic Farm on our fourth largest
island in pursuit of 100 renewable
energy generation
we recognize that the healthy ocean
makes for a healthy climate
and we have committed to bring all 1.3
million square kilometers of fiji's
ocean under sustainable management with
30 percent as Marine protected areas
the ocean has been our Shield against
the worst of climate change
by serving as a carbon sink
we believe that paired with the mission
cuts it can become a solution to energy
generation
and a source of resilient Economic
Development thank you
thank you prime minister Minister Steele
thank you
just heard from the Prime Minister Fiji
we'll hear from the Marshall Islands
Grenada you'll hear from all of the
islands in this room some of the great
work
that is taking place in islands all
around the world small island developing
States continue to demonstrate real
leadership in these very and
increasingly challenging times
Grenada was the first in the region to
establish a dedicated Ministry of
climate resilience focused on building
resilience in
um on our Island Progressive policies
programs one of the first to submit a
new NDC globally mainstream climate
change
across the whole of of government
projects in relative terms one of the
more successful Islands within the re in
the region in terms of resource
mobilization and information tools
supports all of those things are Central
to the decision-making processes that
have gotten us to to where we are
a small size
um gives us a very deep understanding of
the problems that um that that we face
and how to tackle them whether that's
from an environmental perspective social
economic technical
we can see the cause and effect of
positive actions negative actions and
the respective outcomes and with all of
these challenges that we Face
we're also presented with a massive
opportunity an opportunity to be a
global Exemplar to be able to
demonstrate to larger more developed
Nations what can be achieved with real
political will
but there's a however to this
without the right support and we come
back to the points raised in the earlier
um
question
without the right support
we will always be the victims in this
story
but with the right support and we are
far away from that we can be a part of
the global solution also
and this is all that we ask to be given
a chance not only to save our island
nations but to be that Exemplar of
leadership
and action to the rest of the world
thank you
thank you minister
director General Kitchener please
uh thank you
I think um I want to talk about our
national adaptation plan
um that's been a real key focus of
everything that we've been discussing
out here when we've been a cop and and
for good reason
um our national adaptation plan is is
what we're calling our survival plan uh
it's our most comprehensive uh
plan that we've developed so far that is
including a community consultation and
including science that we've collected
on our own already it's based off of
surveys and Community plans that were
developed by each island conservation
plans called I know that a local 2030
Network looks at not just climate change
but also environmental all around
environmental issues and the remala
conservation framework is a framework
that was developed by Marshallese people
within our Marine Resources Authority
department and each of these framework
has the community has the members of the
memorand staff going to different
islands and working with the communities
there to develop their own conservation
plan now these conservation plans ended
up being the basis for our national
adaptation plan because they do touch on
the conservation issues that they're
looking at but they also look at social
issues and they look they touch very
briefly on adaptation now besides this
conservation plan and all of that kind
of science that forms the basis of the
national adaptation plan we're now
embarking onto our community
consultations and this is really
exciting for me to be a part of as
climate Envoy but also as director of
our non-profit joachigum the community
consultations is going to be our biggest
widespread sort of public Outreach on
climate change what people don't know is
the Marshall Islands has over 20
different Islands within our island
chain each of them have different
histories different communities nobody
ever says I'm from the Marshall Islands
within the Marshall Islands they say
what island they're from specifically
and they hold it very proudly so with
that in mind we have to go to each of
these islands and get their perspectives
on what kind of adaptation pathway they
would want so instead of a top-down
approach for planning our future we're
actually doing a human rights-based
approach that takes into consideration
what our community actually needs and
what they actually want so and that
involves actually working with
non-profits who will Target different
vulnerable groups and so our non-profit
joachigum will be leading the youth
engagement on these Community
consultations and we're actually
training the youth we work with to lead
the workshops and the consultation so
it's youth-led and youth voiced within
that consultation and we also have
women's groups leading some of the
consultations and the conservation
groups to make sure that each of the
different vulnerable voices are
highlighted within our national
adaptation plan and so I think this is
there's a lot of areas in which Marshall
Islands is has been leading the way in
declaring our climate emergency early on
in developing our energy roadmap which
we're working on implementing right now
but right now this is a consultation
that's underway right as we're speaking
here at this conference the agency which
is delivering it the international
organization on migration is working on
that as we speak and our our youth my
youth that I work with are are helping
to develop that as we're talking on this
panel so I think that's probably what um
the world could really learn from is the
ways in which we engage with our
community in a much more holistic and
Community Driven way and uh I think the
rest of the world can incorporate that
into their own adaptation planning
because it really shouldn't be top down
the most vulnerable groups will be hit
the hardest and they need to be voiced
and they need to be heard as we're
planning for our futures thank you
thank you director
this brings to a close our session here
today I'd just like to make a personal
comment on perspective and thank the
panel for some very uh particular
approaches one is the specificity of
your comment uh one is the seriousness
of the issue as you presented it to us
issues and the third and probably the
most important in closing is what I
would characterize as the guarded
optimism of the solutions oriented
actions that each of you addressed
combating the climate crisis is a
challenge but reflecting on what we've
heard here today in this session and
this week I am optimistic that working
together we are stronger in moving in
the right direction to help our Island
communities I'll close simply by saying
that I look forward to continuing this
very important discussion even as soon
as at the our ocean conference in Palau
in February with that I say Mahalo Aloha
and ask you to thank our distinguished
panel thank you very much
and so that panel comes to an end
entitled Island resilience sharing
Solutions in the great ocean States
panel you can see the lineup there it
included the prime minister of Fiji
Grenada Simon Steele and also Kathy
gentnell Kitchener of the Marshall
Islands you can't see President Obama
the former U.S president of course but
he did speak earlier he had to leave
he's got a very full day today and we'll
be picking up on some of his other
commitments a little bit later on but he
talked about the importance of the
island nations he said he was an island
kid himself and he said that in many
ways the islands are the Canary in the
coal mine of the climate crisis he said
they're sending out a message that if we
don't act and act boldly it's going to
be too late he said this is something
that's 10 20 or 30 years down the road
this is now and we have to act now to
help with adaptation and resilience I
should say he said it's not something
that's 10 20 or 30 years down the line
it's something that's happening now so
let let's discuss what he said and what
impact that might have with Aaron Meyer
whose Wilderness Campaign director at
the Adirondack Council in New York and
I'm also joined by Jerome Ringo a
Goodwill Ambassador an advocate for
environmental justice and clean energy
from Louisiana in the United States so
welcome gentlemen so good to have you
here with us uh Jerome if I can start
with you I mean hearing from former
president Obama there speaking about the
plight of island nations and how they're
dealing with the climate crisis right
now with some powerful words but how
much political weight would you say that
President Obama brings to this
discussion I mean what was his own
legacy like has he got real credibility
on the issue of climate change President
Obama has established himself as a
leader and a champion on climate during
his time as the President of the United
States and Beyond I can personally
relate to the island idea as often I
feel like I'm on an island I live on the
coast of Louisiana my home was destroyed
last year by a hurricane and my
community was hit by back-to-back
hurricanes in the same season first time
that's ever happened in recorded history
two category four hurricanes hit a
community within six weeks of each other
so we often feel like we're on an island
as well disproportionately impacted
communities poor communities of color
communities so what President Obama has
articulated about the impacts and the
now solutions that need to take place to
resolve climate issues that impact the
islands it also impacts the many islands
on the in the continental United States
as well as many cities and communities
around the world personally affected yes
I lost my home you lost your home my
home was completely destroyed by
Hurricane Laura and it took us a year to
get back into our home and uh now we are
ending a hurricane season uh and looking
ahead as to what might happen next
season because the temperature is rising
the climate impacts are greater and we
may be right back to where we were one
year ago when our home was destroyed
with 150 mile per hour winds you've
devoted your life to environmental
issues but having experienced that in
Louisiana and losing your home has it
added to your sense of frustration at in
action or how do you feel about it I
don't want to put words in your mouth
more than and adding to frustration it's
a call for Action uh I it has led me to
believe that advocacy is important but
we've got to uh go from Africa advocacy
to action we need now Solutions we need
now action we need now policies you know
I agree that there should be ambitious
goals in 2030 2035 some have mentioned
even 2070 but we need Solutions right
now because we're dealing with right now
issues right now impacts and the world
is changing right before our eyes so I'm
here because of that and
what do you make of President Obama's
intervention here I mean how much more
likely is he to amplify the issues how
much more likely is a figure like him
likely to be listened to well it's
really important because he is that
Global figure that still has credibility
on this issue and the world is looking
to United States for leadership but they
also are coming off of that last
Administration that dismantled the very
institutions that Obama had set up and
so now we have the current government
that's trying to reinstall you mentioned
the appropriate metaphor island nations
are the front line canaries in the coma
pervertible coal mine and what they
don't realize in the politics that Obama
was talking about the tough part and
structures within our democracy it makes
it difficult right now the current
manager of that coal mine is from coal
country and in his mind and he wants
more investment in coal and climate
killing carbon and so we are right now
not only needing Obama to inspire and
lift our nation up and lift up the
voices of activists Obama said the next
key line right now it's the pressure and
the power of the people and the
Grassroots on the outside it is those
voices from the island nations remember
this is one of the most this is an
island nation the UK is a very powerful
island nation and the extinction
rebellion and their voices people want
to write them off as crank and we are
inconvenient with traffic but that is
the alarm clock and the alarm Bell that
we now need to hear and act on brother
Jerome lost his home I was down in the
Lower Ninth with brother Jerome at the
end of Hurricane Katrina when you see
and witness the destruction in the loss
of life and then the government responds
after they are still dealing with
resilience projects from something over
a decade well over a decade ago so if
they're that late in the United States
with adaptation and we have now since
Paris is almost observed Us in action
when that adaptation and support for
these Frontline communities
it is the Sprint that they were talking
about that we must engage in the talk of
mitigation the talk of setting up the
funds is like a pause and that's a
political pause but the needs and the
will of the people and the risks that
they're facing right now we need to act
now on climate and Jerome America is is
a wealthy nation and if there are
concerns amongst people who's whose jobs
it is to look after the environment that
that America is not ready for climate
change do you find it easier to kind of
identify with those smaller Nations who
experiencing this right now there are
whole communities having to move they're
not able to farm land in certain areas
there are whole cities built on
coastlines that are being affected I
mean it does really focus the mind
doesn't it for sure and it's history has
shown us that the greatest attention uh
will be given by the people that are
impacted the most I remember when I
first went to my first climate
conference in Kyoto back then there was
not lots of talk about climate change in
the within the continental United States
more of the impact of climate in America
was felt by the people of the glitchen
tribe in Northern Alaska are those
people that lived in the Arctic regions
now California is on fire Louisiana is
being destroyed by hurricanes the east
coast is being hit by hurricanes like
that are unprecedented we're now seeing
the highest temperatures in recorded
history occurring within the continental
United States and Beyond so now it's
beginning to get the attention of people
because the impact is hitting home
hurricane Ida hit Louisiana and it made
headline news but when hurricane Ida the
same storm made its way and hit New York
it hit Madison Avenue and then it got
Global attention then you had the
president of the United States the vice
president you had the governor of New
York the mayor of New York all standing
side by side saying this is a real
problem and we got to do something about
it when it affects the the economy when
it affects the bottom line money of a
country of of continents it's going to
get people's attention well that's fine
and getting attention is vital isn't it
and President Obama was very interesting
there because obviously he remembers the
Paris agreement being signed at a cop 15
in 2015 and he said that without the
Marshall Islands speaking up and saying
this is happening now in our country
we're at risk of Disappearing underwater
it may it may have been that that
galvanized everybody to come together
around an agreement and and they will
complain along with other island nations
that they're not being listened to do
you think that the fact that there are
problems in other nations like America
is going to Galvanize people generally
to focus on the people who are most
effective now let's be clear there are
significant Island territories within
the United States U.S citizens sitting
on the Virgin Islands sitting on Puerto
Rico sitting on Guam so the impacts are
real Puerto Rico still hasn't been
rebuilt from the last Administration in
fact the politics that we're talking
about of finance and Aid to repair when
it is picked and chosen from political
uh donors who gets the contracts who
gets to do the resilience for billing
and not even looking at the impacted
populations those are harbingers that
people should be leaning forward and
monitoring it's not so much that the U.S
is a wealthy Nation the question is how
is the U.S as a wealthy Nation dealing
with people of color within its
territorial borders and within its
territories and Island territories that
are front line harbingers are what other
nations around the world will face
it is really tragic that in spite of all
of the signals that America to this
moment in its own domestic interest
protecting front-line communities of
colors on island territories that are
its possession that it has a duty to the
very Congress uh has not leaned forward
and as I said made it right as they say
in the terms of Louisiana make it right
right which is equal treatment under law
so when a hurricane hits Wall Street it
hits Staten Island the wealthy white
areas within the United States when we
talk about climate Justice and
environmental Global Environmental
racism that's when all of a sudden it's
a crisis but when it hits Nations or
territories made up of brown people
within the United States they are still
treated in finance as second-class
Citizens so this is a whole issue when
it comes to Global island nations and
Nations Global Nations living up to
their commitment because these are not
the Nations that created the global
climate crisis they are the front line
victims you both made it very clear that
money is needed and money was committed
for developing nations uh back in 2009
Obama I think was was just about
President by then and that money has not
been forthcoming in fact there was a
little protest I don't know if you were
sitting here listening while Obama was
speaking and they were saying show me
the money it's still not here I mean
that is absolutely crucial and crucial
to these talks isn't it right the 50
billion dollar commitment has not been
met I believe only nine billion dollars
has actually been put into the fund so
people must in countries must not just
talk the talk but they've got to walk
the walk and that's why I talk about
advocacy to action we've got to see some
real tangible action by countries by
Representatives by the negotiators to
not just come up with an agreement that
looks good on paper not just an
agreement that's going to make the
headlines of the news but agreements
that can be implemented quickly so that
we can see a change and and that affect
the people that are the canaries in the
mind but also those that are the most
adversely impacted and as was so
eloquently presented those are the poor
people and people of color but the other
piece is that we also need a healthy and
strong fourth estate you the media print
media are very critical the past four
years they have taken a pounding by
right-leaning administrations not only
domestically but internationally and
globally why is the media critical when
we talk about the financing or the fact
that the 50 billion hasn't been made
whole we also got a monitor who are
going to be the stewards and the
custodians of that 50 billion the big
battle that there's been since Paris or
banking institution and financial
institutions that are seeking to
monetize or who's going to basically
manage those funds so they're looking to
profit off of the climate disaster
because of the interests and fees that
they will generate there needs to
actually be These funds need to be
managed by the nation's States like
United States or the U.N and the
stewardship and accountability we need
to force the state to really shine light
on what's coming in and what's being
invested and with the for the fourth
estate right now being backed up by
regimes saying that your fake news and
you're not telling the truth the climate
crisis is here we're seeing the pain and
suffering right now when it comes down
to the financing we need that for that
fourth estate to focus in on
as they not show me the money but where
is the money and where is it going and
that's a critical piece of analysis that
we need a healthy Global media to help
Shine the Light on well transparency and
monitoring are clearly crucial things we
have had a number of pledges do you
think this cop will be any different you
say you've visited ones before do you
think that these promises could we
couldn't believe them that have been
made of this product I want to be
optimistic uh since I began at Kyoto I
believe that we're not where we were but
clearly we're not where we want to be so
we've got a long way to go hopefully
this cop will sort of take us to the
next step as we go into cop 27 that we
can begin to to move the needle okay we
can begin to see tangible amounts of
money put into the fund and of course
they've managed properly and distributed
properly hopefully this can be the
beginning of an answer to the problems
that we are having that our climate uh
uh are related uh one to curb the CO2 to
the atmosphere save this planet for
those Generations that are yet unborn
but at the same time make a real
difference in today's society to where
we create those Pathways out of poverty
but also reduce the impact on those
people as we mentioned already right now
disproportionately impacted so
agreements sorry to its agreements on
methane on coal on forests in the last
week
how optimistic are you Aaron well
President Obama's body language told me
a lot because you can see in it the
polite sense and the intense qualm of
intensity of urgency uh it was not a
body language of Hope but he did say the
right words of the sense of urgency we
need to act and right now when you talk
about those factors and those curbing of
funds right now we need to invest in
Wilderness Wilderness will create the
jobs it will employ the planet we have
to look at those financing mechanisms
and we want to make sure that the money
goes into the fight not in the pockets
in the so far as uh basis points in this
what I call the skim and the profits to
be earned off of managing the fund all
of that fun must go forward into the
fight so to the extent that this cop
shines a light on yes the financing but
the 52 000 question is making sure the
financing is not going going to though
managed by those who financed planet's
destruction Banks and funds that finance
and still support and invest in Coal gas
and natural you know and oil they should
not be stewards of these funds there
should be a clean energy funds new funds
that are not as I say feeding their
bottom lines but feeding the safety and
as they say the challenges that we need
to meet as I say and pledge through here
clock 26. okay but we must leave it
there arama and Jerome Foster so
interesting to get your take on it all
thanks very much indeed for your time we
appreciate it it's okay thank
you're watching Sky News climate live do
stick around we've got loads of events
to get you up to date on in just a
moment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
cars cash and trees that's being Boris
Johnson's Mantra at cop26 well one
country already making some bold
commitments on trees is the United
States the U.S Congress has approved the
infrastructure bill which includes at
least 5.75 billion dollars for restoring
monitoring and researching forests now
the package also includes policies that
could make it easier for local
communities to prepare for wildfires
well here with me to discuss just that
is Jad Daly who's President and chief
executive of American forests so tell us
why the forests and trees matter well
forests and trees don't only help us
slow climate change but they're right at
the intersection of our greatest
adaptation and resilience challenges as
well you mentioned wildfire and look in
the United States due to climate change
the extent of wildfire has doubled in
just the last few decades and that's
terrible for the climate because it
means more carbon emissions but it's
also a huge danger to communities both
wildfires are burning but then also the
the wreckage that's left in their wake
burned over areas that become mudslides
and dangers to water supplies and so
you're right I'm really proud that the
United States with this infrastructure
bill has put more than five billion
dollars into solving that problem in
partnership with communities and look
this build back better legislation
that's right behind it has an additional
24 billion dollars for that same purpose
so Wildfire is definitely a key
dimension of this and we're really
investing in leading on it in a big way
but but there are also Urban connections
too and other ways that trees can help
us become resilient to climate change
and and so that's I think important part
of the story as well absolutely so how
should the money be spent how do you
make sure that you protect your forests
well one of the things that we need to
do is drive our work with science and
make sure that we're using climate
science to understand how we actually
pre-storing forest for the condition of
the future you know we've tended to
think about how do we turn them back
into once they what they once were but
in reality we need to understand what
conditions will be in there in the
future and what types of forests Can
Survive and Thrive and so in the context
of wildfire that's really what we're
trying to do in some cases it means a
lot fewer trees because there just isn't
as much water to sustain those for us
into the future
why is that there are constraints on
water because of climate change you know
as I mentioned this doubling of the
extent of wildfire in the Western United
States in the last few decades it is
directly attributable to the way that
climate change is drying out our forests
it's hotter and drier and it's just
literally baking our forests tender dry
in fact this is remarkable in the past
year we had wildfire that jumped all the
way across the Sierra Nevada mountain
range out in California for the first
time and it happened twice so that's how
dramatically the impacts of climate
change on our forest are leading to
dramatically different risks like
wildfire so you can have fewer trees
sometimes because then there's enough
water to make sure the East tree stays
healthy it's not the thinking that's
exactly right we need to get the species
and genetics and our forests in balance
with what can be resilient to a future
climate
is it now appropriate to plant different
species in America just because of
climate change that's absolutely right
in fact we just released a to plan with
the Bureau of Land Management a U.S
government agency in which we're
restoring the worst burn burned area in
America the campfire it was the most
destructive wildfire in U.S history and
so now we're replanting this burned over
area and what we have realized what
science is telling us we can't just put
it back the way that it was or we'll
just burn again and be a danger to
communities and so we're adjusting the
species and the genetics of those
species some of the ones that are there
now bringing in some species from other
parts of California that are hotter and
drier and that we know will be able to
survive in this new environment but
we're also planting fewer of them so
that the Wildfire can pass through and
so you have small regular fires that
keep the forest in Balance instead of
these catastrophic mega fires that are a
danger of communities and they're also a
danger to our climate because of all the
carbon that they release so some fire
small containable fires are important
absolutely actually that's one of the
misnomers that fire is bad or good it
it's it's actually a mixture of the two
we need to avoid catastrophic fires that
damage our forest to a point where the
only way that we can bring them back now
is to replant them and so what we need
to do is actually do small regular
flowers in some cases lighting them
ourselves and keep our forests in
Balance keep them from being overgrown
internally so being overgrown to again
exactly right when our forests become
overcrowded when we actually prevent
fire from healthy fires from moving
through they've become too dense and and
then when all that dense material is
dried out by climate change it suddenly
becomes a Tinder Box and that's why
we're seeing this incredible change in
wildfire in the Western United States
right now and actually because of this
effect is so strong places in the United
States that didn't used to be known for
Wildfire are becoming increasingly at
risk including for example in the
southeastern United States and so that
manage our managing our forest so that
we get them to a new state of resilience
Guided by what climate science tells us
the types of forests that can be
resilient into the future under those
new conditions that's really the the
puzzle of wildfire resilience at this
moment in time and we have now the money
to do it with this new legislation and
we hope a whole lot more with the
buildback better act to come well yes
and we hear an awful lot about
um you know the importance of protecting
biodiversity and nature-based solutions
I mean it's the main point of keeping
our forest safe is for the absorption of
carbon dioxide or can they perform other
helpful thank you thank you so much for
that point I actually published a piece
on this this week with the world
economic Forum making the point that
forests are a uniquely multitasking
climate change solution they're great
for slowing climate change and they're
great for protecting us from its impacts
they're also great at addressing other
crises that we Face the biodiversity
crisis the water security crisis the
need to create green jobs for everyone
and Forest can perform in all those
areas and so the science that we're
using to make a forest climate resilient
what we're also making the resilient as
habitat we're also making sure that
they're going to provide the function of
filtering and collecting our water
supplies and so it's really healthy and
resilient for us is actually what we
need and if we get that right in a
changing climate we'll get that full
spectrum of benefits to slow climate
change down and to sustain our natural
resources into the future
I also know that you're a big advocate
of trees and cities as well yes thank
you so much for getting to that point
because there's something and for my
organization we we don't think about
this as an environmental issue we think
about it as a moral imperative we have
Matt in America the reality that a map
of trees in our cities is actually a map
of income and it's a map of race in ways
that transcends income and this is
literally killing people the lack of
trees in your neighborhood can make it
as much as 20 degrees hotter right now
today 12 000 Americans per year die
because of extreme heat we have
projections showing that within this
Century that's going to be a hundred
thousand people per year and they're not
going to be dying in leafy neighborhoods
where everyone has great air
conditioning and a platinum healthcare
plan they're going to be dying in these
hotter neighborhoods that by the way
also have more polluted air because they
have a lack of trees to provide natural
cooling to provide air filtration and so
by mapping these inequities of trees in
our country we've mapped every Urban
neighborhood in America something called
true Equity Spore we successfully made
the case to Congress to put 500 million
dollars into planting and caring for
trees in these underserved neighborhoods
through the infrastructure bill and we
have 2.8 billion dollars in the
buildback better act to do much much
more of it and I you know it's great
having President Obama here it's been
such a climate Justice Champion not just
climate action but he's been a great
voice for climate Justice President
Biden as well and all of our
Congressional leaders were here the last
few days and so I'm just so proud that
what America is doing with Forest it's
not just the obvious things like
addressing Wildfire but we're going all
in on this idea of trees for
environmental justice and in cities that
means tree Equity okay Jed thanks very
much indeed for talking to us Judd Daley
there thanks very much indeed for
talking us through the importance of
trees thanks
well our conversation there about
resilience and adaptation focusing on
forests but lots more of that discussion
across the day here on Sky News climate
life because that is the theme of the
day here at 26 in Glasgow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's week two of the cop 26 climate
Summit as negotiations continue in an
attempt to Halt global warming you're
watching a dedicated Channel live in the
heart of the conference this is Sky News
climate live
[Music]
thank you
you're watching Sky News climate live at
cop26 today's top stories protecting
island nations former U.S president
Barack Obama brings star power to the
call for climate action
those of us who live in big wealthy
Nations
those of us who helped to precipitate
the problem
we have an added burden
[Music]
the race is on the cop President says
pledges must be delivered on as the
summit goes into its second week
the UK government pledges 290 million
pounds to support countries dealing with
the impact of climate change
and we're in the Isles of silly where
the land could become uninhabitable
without urgent action the majority of
the population lives here in Hue town
but it's also one of the most vulnerable
parts of the Isles
hello good afternoon the pressure is on
here in Glasgow with less than a week to
go until negotiations wrap up and the
cop president Alex Sharma has insisted
that pledges are delivered to meet the
goal of halting global warming at 1.5
degrees and there's a real Buzz in the
room today with the arrival of the
former U.S president Barack Obama who's
been holding an event to encourage
protection of the small island nations
being affected by climate change and
it's all for a day looking into
adaptation loss and damage here at cop26
and we'll be here bringing you all the
latest news the debate as well as
special guests and Analysis from not
only today but right the way through the
week so let's take a listen then to the
form president speaking just a short
time ago
I have been shaped by my experience
growing up in Hawaii and I know that uh
our outstanding Governor from Hawaii uh
governor ige and first lady are both
here and and uh I'm grateful for all
that they've done to protect
uh our Islands I am an island kid
and while I was President I was proud of
the work that we did uh
to work with island nations who were
most vulnerable to changing climate
even as they did far far less if
anything then the larger Nations and
actually causing the climate crisis and
I remember in Paris
we had a meeting of a group of
Island leaders
to hear directly from them about how
climate change was already having an
impact and
the the the the
effect of that meeting
was outsized it it had a huge impact in
part because
uh these leaders were able to
communicate in very concrete human terms
uh what so often is
a bunch of abstract numbers
people were being affected in very
specific and immediate ways and tragic
ways
and so it put
images and and faces and emotions and
moral Authority behind
the efforts to form the Paris of Courts
it was a reminder that
um
that in many ways our islands are
the canary and the coal mine in this
situation uh that that they are
sending a message now
that if
we don't act and act boldly it's going
to be too late
um and it also highlighted the fact that
this is not something that's 10 or 20 or
30 years down the road this is now and
we have to act now to help with
adaptation and resilience which I know
is a theme of cop 26 today
um
so I don't think I I genuinely think we
would not have gotten as ambitious an
agreement
in Paris had it not been for the
willingness and the capacity of violent
Nations to step up and be hurt
and for that we want to thank you
but I also think that it's important for
us to recognize that as was true
five years ago
we have not done enough
and our islands are threatened more than
ever
and that's part of the reason why I'm so
proud of the fact that the US government
and Joe Biden is giving the issue the
attention that it deserves uh his
commitment to provide an additional
three billion dollars
to
extend a hand and support those who are
most vulnerable to the impact of climate
change including Islands can make a
difference
that's a substantial increase in support
it's an investment in our common
Humanity it's an essential piece of the
work that's being done here
in Glasgow and I think it is
representative of
uh
an essential element of anything that
we're going to do collectively on the
climate crisis a recognition that all of
us have a part to play all of us have
work to do all of us have sacrifices to
make but
those of us who live in big wealthy
Nations
those of us who helped to precipitate
the problem
we have an added burden
to make sure that we are working with
and helping and assisting those who are
less responsible and less able but are
more vulnerable
to this oncoming crisis
also as a Hawaiian
and as American I was proud to see the
Biden Administration embrace the local
2030
Island Network through this initiative
U.S islands like Hawaii Guam
and Puerto Rico will connect with Island
Nations and islands around the world as
they take the lead in pursuing
sustainable development and adapting to
climate change you know initiatives like
these help provide badly needed
resources but they also Forge
connections
by sharing best practices and forging a
Unity of purpose they offer a model
of what's needed around the world if
we're going to make sure that the
promises
in Paris and the promises that are made
here in Glasgow are actually kept and
that we are continually increasing
ambition until we get a full handle on
this problem
I'll close just by saying there's an old
Hawaiian proverb uh
that's uh roughly translated into
unite to move forward
it's a reminder that if you
want to cattle a canoe you better all be
rolling in the same direction and at the
same time
every ore has to move in unison that's
the only way that you move forward and
that's the kind of spirit that we need
to protect our Island resources that's
the kind of spirit we need to protect
our people it's a different mindset
it's an open spirit and that's what all
of you bring to bear in this discussion
some of you are small countries
don't have large populations but you've
got a lot of heart
and you are protectors and preservers of
what is a vital link for all Humanity to
this planet
um
your voice has to be heard and I'm glad
you're here representing those Nations
and making sure that the rest of the
world is listening
well I'm Marie trevelyn the Secretary of
State for international trade and also
UK's International Champion on
adaptation and resilience for cop26
spoke to Sky news this morning about
that pledge to help island nations
we're going to be announcing an extra
290 million pounds to support the least
developed countries and small island
states to help tackle the Urgent
challenges that they need to be
resilient and to adapt to the climate
shocks that are coming now even if we
fix the CO2 emissions challenge today we
would see the heightened climate impacts
continuing to affect those most
vulnerable countries for up to 100 years
to come so adaptation to the changing
climate in their own locally LED
communities is critical and this is
something we're going to be discussing
in depth today and hearing from voices
across the world about how they're
adapting and how they're becoming more
resilient to the day-to-day challenges
of these climate shocks thank you
indigenous people are particularly
vulnerable to the effects of climate
change with many of them forced to move
away as their traditional lands become
uninhabitable adaptation is becoming
increasingly important for these
communities to continue to live
sustainably off the land well joining me
now is Gideon sanago a climate change
coordinator for the pastoralists
indigenous non-governmental organization
so welcome to you thank you for coming
to talk to us
why have you come here what do you want
from this Summit I thank you so much uh
you know indigenous people in Tanzania
are mainly Maasai those are the Past
released and we have the
hunter-gatherers groups so we have two
groups in Tanzania who are the main
leadership in Tanzania and I am belong
to the Masai communities in Tanzania as
you said I work with pingos Forum I'm
here to represent the voices of the
marginalized and vulnerable groups of
indigenous people who are affected by
the impact of climate change we are
people who are friendly with nature we
are in the front line of the impact of
climate change so I'm here to present
their voices to make sure that all the
negotiations taking place here the
rights of religious people have to be
taken into considerations and this is
why I'm here and how are your people
your community being affected by climate
change right now yes we are affected by
climate change it's so different ways we
have the severe droughts that are have
been you know occurring in different
places of the country where indigenous
people are living we have weakness there
are a lot of diseases for both for
livestocks and the people and we are
people who you know have a kind of safe
for grazing management of of with our
livestocks which are cows shapes and and
gods so this uh our animals or cows have
been affected by the climate change in a
way that there's no enough uh grazing or
pasture and lack of water access to
water not only clean but access to even
water so we have been moving from one
place to another to search for you know
water and pasture for our livestock and
for the hunter-gatherers communities who
are I've already mentioned they are
really affected because they depend on
nature they depend on forests they
depend on honey collection of wild Foods
for their survival so because of the
climate change impacts they are now
really you know affected in a way that
they cannot access the Forest Products
as they used to so we are in the front
line of the climate change impacts by
these communities that we are presenting
their voices here so the other thing is
that the riverbeds one right so the
knowledge of indigenous people that they
used over time to predict weather they
are also you know affected we cannot
predict the way we used it too because
of this climate changes because we have
this amazing you know knowledge of
indigenous people in weather predictions
you know in all issues about the forest
and land so we are really really
affected by the climate change of course
also what can be done I mean if if there
was money that was given to Tanzania
could it be spent to help people the
first and foremost I think is a lot of
money is the issue of recognition of the
right of indigenous people we should
really be recognized in terms of land
ownership and our way of life you know
our way of you know living with nature
so that's the first and and the most
important thing to recognize the right
of the people to their land to access
their Forest Products to access to their
you know all sorts of livelihoods now
when it comes to money
we really need this money we need
funding so that we adapt to climate
change effect and uh this uh just
recently the the developed countries
announced 1.7 billions for for local
communities and Indigenous people so for
us as indigenous people we are
marginalized we are vulnerable we are
minority when you talk about local
communities there are so many the people
who called local communities so we need
this money to be specifically a channel
two indigenous people now the question
is how does money be channeled because
it has been the channel through
different you know ways like governments
or like other private entities we need a
kind of a specific mechanism to support
or to address this money and channels so
that DNA spoke can access easily
otherwise we'll end up just like
promises that there's a 1.7 billions
that are best have been sent to
indigenous people and supported the
local communities but at the end of the
day then they won't really access this
funding how confident are you that the
money will go to the people that you
want it to go to
um first and foremost I think
we must under this scope we must you
know uh lower our expectation I am not
too much optimistic so I think the money
that have been promised because it's
just a promise it should be really taken
into action we need Now actions than
ever not for tomorrow now we need
actions so we need this money but it
should be directed to a right channel
create a dedicated mechanism for
indigenous people so that we can easily
access this this funding you say you're
not too confident why is that do you
feel that you're not being listened to
here we are listened and uh I think the
way that we really need to be listened
is to reflect the human rights and the
rights of indigenous people within the
text for example the sub star
under the the corpse is discussion is
taking place we want to see the text the
the specific text that's addressed the
right of indigenous people that's why
because I'm saying money is just not
enough to say we are channeling money to
indigenous people what about the right
of business what about the human rights
based approach so this is what we are
really seeking and as well as the nature
basically Solutions that is another very
important thing that we need to be
addressing give us some idea of some of
the nature-based solutions that could
help uh you know like land and
territories of edina's people and our
knowledge
our knowledge to forests and Land
Management Water Management our
landscape because the remaining forests
today as we speak
there are many forests today for
instance in Tanzania our founded
indigenous people land so we are friends
to Nature we want to see all these
negotiations reflecting the needs and
concern and the right of indigenous
people and to what extent should
indigenous communities be part of the
conversation about change because
they're the people that know the land so
well do you have trust that they will be
included in decision making about what
happens next
uh we should build a kind of trust and
mutual
kind of working together to ensure we
attain the results so it's my hope that
at the end of this course or ongoing
discussions should really bring the
voices of religious people and at the
end of the cup we would like to see the
positive references of the issue related
to indigenous people within the the the
outcome of the school but we will wait
and see and perhaps come back at the end
of the week and tell us but um Gideon
sanago thank you very much indeed for
talking to us today thanks so much thank
you
now Australia has said it will sell coal
for decades into the future after
refusing to sign up to a deal pledging
to phase out fossil fuels here at cop 26
in Glasgow
that Australia produces just four
percent of the world's thermal coal it's
some of the world's highest quality and
that's why we'll continue to have
markets for decades into the future and
if they're buying Hamish well we are
selling demand is increasing prices are
up and we expect that that increase in
demand to continue out to around 2030.
we don't expect countries will
immediately go and close down their
coal-fired generation particularly where
they're new and in fact some are still
under construction and if we are still
in that market somebody else will I'd
much rather it be Australia's high
quality product
well our southeast Asia correspondent
Siobhan Robbins has the latest from
Sydney
well there's been a lot of pressure on
the Australian government coming into
cop 26 it was just days before the
conference kicked off that they finally
managed to announce a commitment to net
zero emissions by 2050. then last week
in the first week of the conference we
saw that they failed to sign up to the
methane cup pledge they failed to sign
up to the list of countries and
organizations which have pledged to
phase out for coal power and today the
resources Minister has said very clearly
in an interview that they will not be
closing coal mines and they will not be
closing coal powered fire stations now
he was speaking to ABC the broadcaster
here in Australia and he said that
there's still a huge demand for coal
around the world they said that they
expected that increasing demand to
continue till at least 2030 and in his
words if they want it we will sell it
and he said that if Australia wasn't
selling the coal which he claims is some
of the highest quality in the world than
other countries would step into the
breach he also doubled down saying that
that they would meet the commitments
that they've made for 2050 but in his
words they wouldn't destroy the economy
trying to meet those commitments earlier
and that 300 000 people around the
country rely on coal now we've seen a
very similar message coming from the
coal communities that we've been
visiting over the last week saying that
they shouldn't be cutting coal mines now
that people need the money that is well
paid jobs that there's still demand that
if Australia steps back then someone
else will just step into the breach but
the big problem is that even though
Australia isn't a big Global emitter
emits around 1.3 percent of global
emissions it's a massive exporter of
coal it's the second biggest export of
coal in the world so in that sense
climate campaigners say it's essentially
like a world dealer of the dirtiest
fossil fuel in the world so how is the
rest of the world meant to step up and
meet emissions if Australia won't step
up and cut coal
you're watching Sky News climate live do
stay with us we'll have all the latest
coming up from the Isles of silly which
is already feeling the impacts of
climate change
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Sky News climate live
we'll bring you all the latest climate
news from the heart of this un climate
Summit cop 26 and just to let you know a
few things that are coming up shortly at
two o'clock we're going to bring you
another event involving the former U.S
president of Barack Obama he's spoken
this morning about small island nations
we're going to hear from him again at an
event this afternoon and then in around
10 minutes time we're due to hear from
the cop 26 president alok Sharma he
holds a daily news conference here at
cop26 so we'll get the latest from him
and if you're not watching it on the
pop-up Channel I think you may well be
but if you want to it's Channel 525 on
your television and on Sky glass and Sky
Go as well as it's streaming online too
now with ministers arriving for the
political stage of negotiations here at
cop26 we've been to an area of the UK
which could become uninhabitable if
action isn't taken to tackle climate
change our west of England correspondent
Dan Whitehead reports now from the Isles
of Sydney
28 miles off the tip of Cornwall a
climate emergency is unfolding less than
a thousand years ago the Isles of silly
was a single landmass now it's 140
islands and 2 000 residents are battling
the impact of rising sea levels and
intense storms this is our the main
defense of our water supply which is
just the other side of this Bank
protecting the Island's water from sea
contamination is just one of the plans
to ensure that future Generations can
still live here what's the worst case
scenario for the people of the Arts of
silly well evacuation basically because
it wouldn't be able to live here I'm not
talking about the next 10 years 20 or
even 100 years but it could eventually
lead to evacuation
the council says it must robustly defend
the islands and is spending Millions on
protecting its Coastline Homes and
businesses the majority of the
population lives here in Hue town but
it's also one of the most vulnerable
parts of the Isles at its narrowest it's
around 130 meters wide sandwiched
between two beaches climate change is
literally squeezing and eroding this
community
things
[Music]
20 minutes by boat and we arrive at
Saint Agnes population 80. Farmers Aiden
and Grace rear cattle but also grow
crops for oils and gin so normally we'd
be harvesting these plants and they'd be
they'd be up like this intense dry
spells are making business difficult
Summers like this summer have made us
have to rethink completely and we're
going to we're having to look at
investing in permanent irrigation
systems now to see us through It's Just
Happening too often for us to risk year
on year the crops failing
but climate change isn't just impacting
those on land
the wildlife trust says in 2017 nearly
all seal pups died after being swept out
to sea too soon by a series of ferocious
storms
uh this is the main entrance to the
school fifteen-year-old will Schwartz is
a climate champion at the Island's only
school he's passionate and fearful about
the future of the sillies it definitely
worries me the future Generations won't
be able to have the same experiences
over here than than I did than my
generation did
um which is a little bit sad and it's a
bit worrying because
um it we might already be too late This
Island community is taking action now
knowing climate change he's posing an
urgent threat to its very way of life
Dan Whitehead Sky News on the Isles of
silly
well let's speak now to Dan Whitehead
who's there so Dan How concerned are
people there about the effects of of
climate change on their homes
well there is real concern we're in Hue
town which you saw in my report there
and you can see that the tide is out at
the minute but at high tide twice a day
you'll see the water crashing against
these properties and these homes and
these businesses now it's been like that
for a long time but what the people on
the aisles of silly are seeing here is a
change in weather patterns with those
ferocious storms becoming more frequent
that is causing concern about coastal
flooding and land erosion those are the
two real big worries for the islands
here and it's already having an impact
we've been speaking to Farmers who have
seen some of their land eroded as well
as those Farmers we spoke to in our VT
there talking about the changes in the
temperatures and how it's affecting
their crops so there is real uh concern
here and what's happening on the Isles
today is they are holding a virtual cop
26 Summit as they present their climate
change action plan which has gone out
for public consultation today right
through until December among the plans
are in that consultation is an ambition
for the Arts of silly to become zero
carbon by 2030. other things in the sort
of mitigation of climate change such as
solar panels and more electric vehicles
as some of their big AIMS in the next
couple of years but where the millions
of pounds is being spent here on the
Isles of city is when it comes to Sea
defenses so all around the islands here
there's 140 Islands five big ones which
are inhabited they are spending millions
of pounds on improving their sea
defenses and one of those porth helic is
under real threat because just meters
away from where the sea is and where the
waves are crashing is the only
freshwater lake which provides the water
for Saint Mary's here and there is a
real worry about sea contamination and
that would have an instant impact on
people being able to literally have
water to drink here just 28 miles as I
say off the coast of Cornwall so there
is big plans when it comes to mitigation
and adaptation and there is real real
concern this is not going to be a
community that erodes as we heard from
the councilor in the next 10 20 even 100
years but they are starting to see not
only in the wildlife but also in the
erosion the land erosion things starting
to change already there are projections
in the next hundred years of this
squeeze in Hue town here these beaches
getting narrower and narrower and that
will have an impact on where the vast
majority of people live on the Isles of
sillies it's basically it's basically a
sandbar where these buildings are built
and they are under threat in the coming
decades so that is why they are taking
this urgent and robust action is what
they call it to bolster those sea
defenses as well as mitigate against
their own carbon Footprints with other
initiatives
Dan thanks very much indeed
now the climate Action Network group is
warning that the goals of cop26 are at
risk if no progress is made on
adaptation loss and damage it comes as
the UK government is calling for Urgent
action to support developing countries
cope with the impacts of climate change
well joining me now is Caroline Lucas
former leader and co-leader of the green
party so welcome to you thank you I mean
first of all let's talk a little bit
about adaptation because that's the
theme of today the idea that there are
an awful lot of Nations who already
suffering right now from climate change
and need help to adapt to deal with it
so that people don't have to migrate and
lose their livelihoods how important a
part of the conversation is that do you
think and is it getting the attention
you'd like it is a massive part of of of
what needs to happen at this conference
and it's not getting the attention that
it needs we know already that the famous
100 billion pound uh billion dollars
that hasn't been forthcoming yet 50 of
that is supposed to be for adaptation so
far only 25 of the money that's been
raised has been earmarked for adaptation
it is so crucial for some of the poorest
countries to be able to get the funding
they need to be able to transition their
economies in such a way that they're
more resilient and make their their
infrastructure more resilient too so
adaptation matters a lot even more in a
sense matters there's a new idea called
loss and damage loss and damage is
separate from adaptation in the sense
that they want and deserve new money to
recognize the fact that already their
economies have been absolutely Shattered
by climate events I'm thinking for
example of the hurricane that hit
Dominica in 2017 that caused about a
loss equivalent to 224 percent of their
GDP and these happen year after year
they cannot adapt to that so we need a
separate budget stream for loss and
damage and that hasn't been forthcoming
either and do you have faith that the
money will come we've heard a lot about
it obviously the calls from developing
nations asking for it saying it should
have been here last year we're being
told that it will probably be
forthcoming in 2023 possibly earlier and
there's new money announced last week
from Japan as well do you feel that
progress has been made and that people
are pushing hard enough no I don't I
think it's outrageous that right now in
cop26 we are not coming forward with the
finance that the developing countries
have been asking for that we have
promised them actually since 2009 it was
supposed to be fulfilled in full by last
year as you say but we've been promising
this for years there will be no
sustainable outcome from this cop Summit
unless the finance is forthcoming the UK
has a bigger role to player than it is
it cannot have leverage with other
countries when it has cut its own Aid
budget by four billion pounds so it
needs to be doing an awful lot more
itself it needs to be stepping up to the
plate it needs to be making sure that
the voices of developing countries are
heard as well there's been so much anger
here that first of all some of the
non-government organizations from those
countries haven't been given Visa so
they can't be here I've just been in a
meeting a plenary meeting when some of
the representatives of the small island
states were saying that negotiations are
happening that they can't attend because
there are four or five meetings
happening simultaneously and they simply
don't have the negotiators to be able to
staff all of those meetings at the same
time so there needs to be far greater
consideration about how we hear those
voices of the people who are on the
front line of the climate emergency they
have done least to cause it and theirs
are the lives that are being wrecked
first by it the organizers would no
doubt say they've made every effort to
try to be as inclusive as possible and
today is a day that's focusing on their
needs right now plus every day every day
needs to be focusing on their needs and
I simply say that it cannot be the case
that they have have done everything they
could in order to be able to hear the
voices of some of those small island
States because clearly we had the
representative of those States very very
angry rightly so this morning so more
needs to be done and frankly the needs
and demands of the developing countries
have to be front and center of this
conference not just on one day of the
two weeks but of every single day well
let's look at what has been achieved so
far there have been pledges that we've
heard sprinkled through the last week
we've had an agreement on cutting
methane Emissions on coal production and
also for protecting forests and trying
to prevent a deforestation
do you accept that some progress has
been made of course there's some
incremental steps in the right direction
but even on those agreements that you're
describing the real worry is that
there's no detail on the accountability
and the transparency how we really do
hold government and institutions to
account on the promises that they're
making there's no legal requirement for
them to deliver on these things when it
comes to some of the financial
um uh the things that have been
committed again we're seeing that
there's no way of holding them to
account they can still go ahead and fund
new coal even though they are making
pledges themselves about trying to move
away towards more green and sustainable
ways forward so if at the same time
they're doing the good stuff they're
also still doing the bad stuff if they
are still funding fossil fuels then that
isn't good enough and that needs to be
far more transparent and yet we did have
analysis didn't we from the iea last
week suggesting that if the pledges were
met and there that is a big caveat
because people can make promises and
obviously they've got to deliver on them
but if they did meet their commitments
that have been made during the course of
this conference as well as previous
commitments the hope of 1.5 is is closer
in touch they suggest that it would take
us to a global warming ceiling of 1.8
degrees what do you make of that are you
encouraged by that or are you skeptical
a bit I'm skeptical about is the big if
in your in your comment really is is if
those countries and those institutions
do deliver on these pledges when you've
got pledges that are you know decades
away in some cases when you've got
pledges that are being made that have
absolutely no accountability mechanisms
whatsoever I think it will be an
extraordinary leap of faith to believe
that those are going to deliver we knew
that the previous forestry agreement
that was made in 2014 didn't deliver
this time around there is some more
money which is good there is more of a
focus on indigenous communities which is
good but there's still no transparency
as to whether or not there will be
mechanisms and levers for people to hold
to account those organizations who are
making those pledges and until we get
those I don't think any of us can be can
be relaxed about the future and to
return to the theme of the day
adaptation and resilience clearly the
urgent need now is for those people
whose communities are being destroyed by
climate change but however let's also
look at the UK's position as well to
what extent do you think that we're
ready for summer the effects of climate
change in this country
well I think the fact that we continue
to build on floodplains the the fact
that the government ruled out a new
legislation on zero carbon homes they
actually ditched that earlier so we are
still building homes that were going to
have to retrofit quite soon because
we're not building them to be resilient
to a climate dangerous future so we're
not doing enough here in the UK and in a
sense we're letting down new homeowners
who are buying houses in good faith
assuming that they're going to be able
to withstand climate effects and we know
that they're not because they're being
built in the wrong places and they're
not being built to the highest standards
and yet the government did release its
Net Zero strategy in the run-up to cop26
do you feel that that is a good plan for
trying to keep our emissions down but
also adapt to a changing climate I think
it's just not joined up you know part of
the Net Zero strategy was also the Heat
and building strategy that came out at
around the same time which had a big
Fanfare about for example heat pumps
that there was going to be money for
people to put heat pumps in their homes
but hardly any money for insulation
there's no point in putting a heat pump
in your home if you haven't already got
good insulation it's like buying a leaky
teapot it's useless the the thing just
leaks out of your of your home so that's
just one little example of how still
this Net Zero strategy is not joined up
neither is the Heat and building
strategy so we need the government to
step up here and yet they would argue
that we're one of the few countries in
the world that have really set out
detailed plans we don't just set
ambitious targets but we've set out
detailed plans of meeting them that they
should be credited with that shouldn't
they well there is a step forward in the
sense that until very very recently all
we had was targets and obviously targets
don't cut emissions you need the
delivery plans and that's why the
committee on climate change the
independent Watchdog if you like has
said again and again delivery delivery
delivery you're right now we do have
some plans let's wait to see if they
actually do get delivered on and let's
just try and get the government to stop
doing the bad stuff it's so easy to say
they're doing some good stuff but if at
the same time they're promoting a new
oil field in Cambo if at the same time
they are still giving a green light to a
mine a coal mine in Cumbria if at the
same time they're building 27 billion
pounds worth of Roads it doesn't matter
how much of the good stuff they're doing
if they don't stop doing the bad stuff
and both those fossil fuel projects are
under investigation at the moment Cambo
is not eventually when it came to the
cumbrian coal mine yes the government
finally was persuaded to call it in we
don't know what the outcome that will be
but they should have called it in much
sooner on Cambo it's been pushed till
after the cop so it doesn't embarrass
the government but we've heard no
indication yet that the government isn't
going to Green like that and I've been
asking that question again and again in
the House of Commons and Boris Johnson
certainly has not ruled that out yes and
they talk about the fact that the
license was was awarded a long time ago
I look at the climate matter cares when
the license was issued what it cares
about is when the admissions are emitted
and they're going to be emitted now and
that's what's so dangerous okay and
we'll find out about that in future but
but let's look ahead to the end of the
week what is your uh hope and
expectation for the end of cop26 one of
the big kind of missions is to keep
global warming caps at 1.5 degrees to
keep 1.5 alive do you think it can be
I certainly think it can be if we have a
if that's a different question
um I hope so but I think first of all
that the developing country is very real
and legitimate concerns need to be met
so that 100 billion is no good having
that in 2023 that needs to come forward
there needs to be a separate pot of
money for loss and damage and then again
we also need much more robust mechanisms
for analyzing uh whether or not the
emission reduction targets are going to
add up to keeping below 1.5 and we also
need not to have this massive loophole
which is around carbon markets
essentially what we're having now is
countries saying that they're going to
meet Net Zero by offsetting their
emissions that means that they will for
example build um the plants lots of
trees in other countries to try to
absorb their emissions and that's how
they get to be Net Zero I've just been
in a meeting where it was said that just
for Shell one company that has a net
zero Target for 2030. uh if it were to
deliver on that and the number of trees
that would have to plant would be three
times the size of the Netherlands there
are some really big questions here about
the kinds of statements that are being
made and whether or not they really do
add up okay and I know nothing about
what shell has to do so I can't answer
on that one anyway Karen look is a good
to talk to you thanks very much indeed
for your time
now the UN estimates that methane gas
has accounted for 30 of global warming
since the Industrial Revolution the oil
and gas industry are well known to be
big and unregulated emitters of methane
with the cattle industry too often
criticized but another key emitter of
the potent gas is our own rubbish well
Mark Stone reports now from Texas where
they're trying new ways to capture the
methane from the mountains of refuse
that we produce
we all contribute to landfill but up
close there is something overwhelming
about a place like this and in
consumer-obsessed America the scale is
quite something
so too the lack of effective recycling
just look at the plastic and the
cardboard here
this is cleared for more and more
because the average American produces
nearly a ton of rubbish every year
that's three times as much as the
average Britain
we are seemingly Unstoppable generators
of waste which is why management is so
vital so this is the most interesting
work I've ever done
Zachary Peterson manages this vast
landfill outside Houston America's
fourth largest city and he's proud of a
process that despite flaws caused by
consumer culture and poor regulation is
he says sustainable my passion for
landfills is I can affect change and it
affects you know our community it
affects you know being a good neighbor
it affects the environment you know I'm
directly affecting the
the world my daughter's going to grow up
in by doing proper landfilling
under this pasture is tons of waste
among the huge challenges of landfill is
methane without effective management
methane seeps out of the earth as the
waste decomposes and it is a greenhouse
gas that short-term warms our planet
faster than any other in America alone
landfill accounts for nearly 20 percent
of human-caused methane emissions but
here a solution we've watched the trucks
coming in through the morning tons and
tons of waste flattened and compacted on
top of a plastic shell that already
lines the landfill site eventually that
shell will be sealed the waste within it
will decompose and from that the methane
can then be extracted
these stumps are the methane Wells
dotted across the landscape they are the
heart of the operation and they are the
success story the example I like to use
being if you imagine a milkshake you
have a straw in the milkshake the
milkshakes your landfill the straw is
the extraction well you exert the vacuum
using your mouth or in our case a blower
system and you know the content is
removed at some point
on the edge of the site the gas which
would otherwise seep out of the earth is
piped into a Refinery cleaned and then
sold on to power cars and heat homes
this methane capture is a technology
used increasingly around the developed
world yet Beyond it is literally an
ever-growing Challenge and while this
may be a success of sorts the troubling
fact is that even here so much of this
will never decompose Mark Stone Sky News
in Texas
cop president alak Sharma in his daily
news conference please stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so much so this is cop president Alex
Sharma holding his daily news conference
let's listen in
nowhere is immune to climate change and
this is precisely why we must come
together to forge Global agreement here
in Glasgow responding to adaptation
needs which is vital
today ministers are starting their work
on the negotiations together we Face the
arduous task of building political
consensus between almost 200 countries
finding consensus is not going to be
straightforward
but the progress made last week
demonstrates that a constructive Spirit
amongst negotiators exists and here in
Glasgow we have a unique opportunity to
reach a historic outcome and I'm
committed to Bringing countries together
uh we want to forge agreement uh that
means we see more action this decade to
help keep the limit of 1.5 degrees
Global temperature rise in reach
now during the informal stock taking
plenary which was held this morning I
outlined I outlined how we will work
during this week
I also announced ministerial pairings on
key topics these include adaptation loss
and damage Finance keeping 1.5 alive and
of course the key rulebook issues of
common time frames article 6 on carbon
markets and transparency
my priority now is peace there needs to
be a sense of urgency in all our
negotiations the science is clear we
have no time to lose and I will ensure
that negotiations proceed in a timely
manner whilst of course ensuring
transparency and inclusivity
last week countries made commitments
which will all help to protect our
planet but they must be delivered on and
accounted for
today on adaptation and loss and damage
day the spotlight will be on those
Nations and communities which are most
vulnerable to climate change those whose
voices are too often left unheard
and we know that even if we stopped
polluting our world tomorrow there will
be negative consequences for many
millions and that is why issues such as
adaptation are so important now I'm
pleased to see progress on these topics
today and particularly welcome the
commitments to the adaptation fund which
we made in the next few hours including
from the UK to support vulnerable
communities to respond to climate change
developed countries and development
Banks recognize they need to increase
levels of Finance for adaptation and I
hope we will be able to capture this
renewed commitment in the cop 26
negotiated outcome
those of you who have followed this
process will know that loss and damage
has historically been seen as a
polarizing issue
but I'm encouraged that the mood music
has changed somewhat and there is now a
practical recognition that action is
needed on this topic in the face of
growing impacts
discussions within the subsidiary bodies
on the Santiago network is a testament
to that and paves the way for greater
resources to avert minimize and address
loss and damage
climate vulnerable communities are
particularly at the Forefront of my mind
and will be so throughout these
negotiations they and the generations to
come will not forgive us if we fail to
deliver in Glasgow uh I now like to pass
to the UNF Triple C triple F UNF Triple
C uh executive secretary Patricia
Espinoza for hermaph
thank you Mr President thank you and
thanks to all of you for for being here
joining this um a
presidences uh press conference
um I want to
um just maybe
building on the on the very
comprehensive summary that the president
has just presented uh underline that the
arrangements that he has put in place
for this week and the involvement of of
ministers in my view are in a very very
positive development they have many of
them have already arrived I would say
most of them have already arrived and
they are all
um eager and and willing to get involved
in the in their negotiations and
actually the decisions that need to be
taken now are more of a political level
decisions so that is uh really a very
very welcomed development and the way
that the president has arranged the
organization of work for week two I
think should allow us to be a successful
to be able to adopt a meaningful group
of decisions at the end of this week
um
I am cautiously optimistic I would say
about it uh yes because the issues under
discussion are not easy but what I can
see now is that the will and the
political level participation is there
thank you
thank you Patricia
um yes the acronym is always a challenge
unfccc stands for United Nations
framework conventional climate change
for the reporting it may be easier to
use un climate change
thank you
um
is there any statement to come or shall
we proceed for Q A's I think we're happy
to take questions okay please
let's start in the first row
hi Leslie Hook from the financial times
a question for Alec what would you like
to see in the cover text uh what's the
sort of Ideal uh contents of that
document thank you
so Lizzy thank you for that
um we have put out a non-paper as you
are aware uh detailing uh the issues
that have been raised by uh parties over
the last week obviously we're going to
have to have a a discussion around that
uh Archie young my chief negotiator has
been leading on that work and there will
be a heads of Delegation meeting later
on this afternoon to discuss those
issues so maybe ask you if you wanted a
comment
thank you very much as the club
President says we've been engaging
widely with parties and with groups both
bilaterally and also we have held
multilateral consultations in order to
hear from all what their expectations
are what they would like to see as a
result we put out the non-paper over the
weekend we have already heard some
feedback and we continue to welcome that
we will be having a meeting this
afternoon with all heads of Delegation
in order to continue to hear the
feedback and on the basis of that we
will then set out next steps two points
I would raise on it one is that we have
been cleared through the various
Reflections notes from the cop president
from the ministerial meetings that we
have held our expectations that this
conference will deliver in terms of the
science and in terms of the expectations
of all of our citizens and the second is
to highlight the inclusive approach that
we're taking by by really co-creating
this with all parties and with groups so
that this is not simply a text which is
kind of arrives from the presidency but
one which is really developed uh
constructively and collaboratively with
all parties and groups thank you
uh we continue in the first row please
thank you my name is Justin cat in her
song with manga Bay this issue is to
transparency and accountability in the
United Kingdom and the European Union
the biggest source of renewable energy
is burning Forest biomass instead of
coal
so I'll set aside for a moment the
question of whether this is driving
deforestation in places like the United
States and Canada which are producing
these wood pellets my question is are
you concerned that the emissions from
millions of tons of burning wood
are not counted at the smokestack in the
European Union in the UK and that this
is in effect affecting the accuracy of
the carbon Accounting in those countries
and the transparency as well and this
comes in light of today's investigative
story in the Washington post about many
many countries Under reporting their
emissions
and a lack of transparency and accuracy
this gets to the heart of what you're
trying to accomplish here thank you
well I mean you know obviously as I've
said one of the things that we are very
keen to close off are all the
outstanding elements of the rule book
and transparency is a key outstanding
element and that is something that we
have been discussing for some years now
uh transparency absolutely underpins the
Paris agreement uh and obviously we need
to be able to see that the commitments
that are being made are actually being
delivered on and there's an enormous
amount of work that has been done so far
by uh our officials and negotiators on
this issue uh but of course what we need
to see is that we close off transparency
at this cop
five two minutes
do you want would you like to come in
no um sorry uh the the the use of well
look I mean I think what what we're
going to uh as I said I think the key
issue here is to ensure that we get
agreement on the transparency tables uh
that are going to form the basis of what
is reported uh there are a um a range of
of uh emissions that will be part of
those transparency tables and as I said
what we want to do is to reach consensus
on that
the gentleman in a row three
sorry four
hello Felix van Gaia with new orator.com
um now I think anyone who's been on the
cops before would realize that as you
were saying
um they've been very politically
polarized for example in Madrid and
while some of the politics haven't quite
gone away I think many of the issues are
probably now more technical in things
like corresponding adjustments
carryovers and lots and damage is there
anything you would like to say about
um these technical issues
um particularly on say corresponding
adjustments and loss and damage which
would be instructive to journalists
understanding where we are with current
negotiations thank you
yes thank you so I think as uh you'll
have heard from the SB chairs uh this
morning uh there are a range of issues
that uh were closed off by them and I
really welcome the work that they and
their teams have put in
um clearly some of those elements that
are coming forward are technical but
there are also Elements which are are
political as well and I think uh you
know closing off on article 6 on
transparency and common time frames uh
will require a political consensus to be
built amongst ministers and it's why I
outlined for you um the seven areas as
well uh and in the in the plenary I set
out which pairings of ministers will
lead work on this I'll invite Archie
young if he wants to say anything from a
technical perspective on what's gone on
in the last book
you're watching Sky News climate live
just to let you know at two o'clock as
it is now we are watching the top
president Alex sharma's daily news
conference but just to let you know that
we are expecting to hear very shortly
from President Obama with his second
session of the day and we'll be Crossing
to that just as soon as he stands up to
speak
you mentioned corresponding adjustments
for those who aren't familiar that's one
of the the main issues outstanding with
regard to article six but the issue of
how you make sure that there is
consistent and clear accounting on the
new 6.4 mechanism and that is a
technical issue but actually it is
political in terms of both the strong
interests the national interests that
are driving different positions and also
political in terms of the way that it
can uphold environmental Integrity in
article 6 and the Paris agreement as a
whole on loss and damage as the cop
president said we're pleased that the
the progress that was made on the
technical work uh through the subsidiary
bodies over the last week in clarifying
the functions of the new Santiago
Network on lost and damage but equally
we've heard clearly a political desire
for more work on loss and damage for
more work on the functions and also for
more work on how we can scale up the
finance that can avert minimize and loss
avert minimize and address loss and
damage so I think on all of these there
is a technical work but um it is never
far from the political considerations
that are driving the work here thank you
so if I may just to to add on on this
point
um I hope it's it's useful I think it's
also important to take into account that
here we're talking about issues that are
interrelated and that the climate change
um
architecture
has a balance between the different uh
the different components we have
mitigation adaptation and loss and
damage means of implementation including
Finance uh technology and capacity
building so that is also that also plays
a part in the way that the negotiations
um are addressed and and and also
explains why there needs to be
this political level interventions in in
the case of article 6 for example it is
very directly linked to adaptation Asian
specially adaptation Finance it is
linked to transparency as well and on
the other hand transparency is linked to
different other parts of of the package
so this is why uh what um the the
co-president has put together this group
of ministers under his leadership is so
important because it's really the best
way to put together the whole package
and find that very delicate balance
thank you the lady in green Row three
three
go ahead sorry
uh Katie Collins with CNET I'm here
today with two questions firstly Global
witness released a report this morning
saying that there were more than 500
fossil fuel lobbyists here at cop more
than in any national delegation how and
why has this been allowed to happen What
role are they playing here and how can
this be justified given their complicity
in propagating climate change denial
narratives and the harm they have done
and continue to do that has brought us
here in the first place
secondly former U.S president Barack
Obama is currently speaking here at cop
today with a message to the youth but
the youth here at cop including black
indigenous and people of color have not
been able to get tickets in fact they
complained of being shut up many key
events this week
even though outside they are showing
themselves to be leaders in this fight
Mr Obama's message will not be heard by
them today why has more space not been
made for them
um thank you let me let me uh take this
first and I think Patricia may want to
come in as well on a logistics issue so
firstly in terms of attendance by um I
think you referred to folks related to
to oil and gas I mean at the end of the
day it is up to parties and observers
who gets accredited as part of their
delegation
um and ultimately accreditation is a
matter for the UNF uh Triple C and
Princess you might want to comment on
that
um your second issue was about uh Youth
and and access again I think the UNF
Triple C may want to set out the
statistics on the number of registered
delegates here particularly those from
civil society and observer groups and
there has certainly been an issue in
terms of access to rooms but that's been
an issue for parties as well as
observers because of course we are
holding this is in quite unprecedented
times there is a reason that we're
restricting the numbers in rooms because
of covert safety there's a reason why of
course you're all wearing face coverings
we're having our daily testing regime
and I think we have tried and we will
continue to try to ensure that the
process is as inclusive as possible
there is of course also a online
platform which is available as I
understand about 12 000 people have now
made use of that as well uh particularly
I know whether you want to add anything
on these two issues
well regarding the the first point about
the the fossil fuel
um lobbyists well
first of all I I think that um what I
would like to say is
um we don't have any constituency that
uh has that is a representatives of
fossil fuel companies I mean this is not
something we don't have a partnership
the UNF Triple C doesn't have any
partnership with the
um a fossil fuel companies
um
but in our in our process some of the
constituencies May accredit
some people that are linked
um may be linked to some of these uh
fossil fuels the same uh in the case of
some party delegations you know
um it is really the Sovereign right for
every government to accredit as a as a
representative as part of of its
delegation
um the persons that it seems appropriate
the Secretariat there's no legal basis
for us in the Secretariat to say okay we
will exclude this or that person having
said that what I would like to say is
also that we uh always say this is an
inclusive process and what is a fact is
that the transformation that the process
of transformation that we need to to to
see
requires also a transformation in this
sector and requires a just transition
adjust energy transition everywhere
around the world so I think that these
are the two elements that um
we we take into account when we uh we do
engage in dialogue of course with those
companies in telling them making the
point very clearly look this is
something that needs to change it is not
something that we you will be able to go
go on forever I mean you know that some
of our parties are all producing
countries some of the them have also
even state-owned oil companies uh we
need we need all of that industry also
to change we need them on board but we
do not allow
um and an open
lobbying or open
promotion of oil and gas of course that
would be against the objectives of the
Pirates agreement and the convention
so our producer just in terms of the the
number of registered Society youth
delegate issue
I I I would need to do you have the
number of the youth well not of the
youth we have I can give you the number
of The Observers
fourteen thousand one hundred twenty
four registered participants
then maybe to put it into perspective 22
274 party delegates and three thousand
eight hundred eighty six media
if I may on on that also it is it is
really a very big number and we have
made also uh for The Observers in an
effort to allow more more people to
participate so you see uh those High
numbers it doesn't mean that they are
here at the same time all the time
some of them have a are a registered to
participate on on some dates not the
whole two weeks that was something that
took us a long time to figure out so
that we could even issue daily budgets
so that you know instead of only being I
don't know five people throughout two
weeks they could they could bring in
maybe 20 people uh and and that would
make it also for the constituency
inside more inclusive so yes these are
very very high numbers and our objective
has been that will remain as inclusive
as possible and in accessing the rooms
the limitations that they are
experiencing are exactly the same
limitations that parties are
experiencing it it's it's the same it's
just um the physical space that is is
available and what we are doing so we're
going to leave the cop presidency news
conference right there and as you can
see the event in the other Hall is
getting underway we're expecting to hear
from President Obama as part of this
session so let's listen
the deepest point of the world's ocean
several years ago I asked President
Obama a question about the military
presence in the Pacific Islands
he answered with raise awareness gather
allies and unify voices
I took those powerful words with me and
kept them close
they've guided me here
I am at cop 26. to raise Global
awareness and Consciousness around ways
to protect and heal Mother Earth
I am here to gather allies
from and for indigenous communities
around the world
as the first stewards of the land and
ocean
our traditional knowledge can guide the
way
all together we hold the keys to solving
the issues of militarization
climate change and climate colonialism
we are not passive victims
and I am here to amplify the voices of
those who live on the front lines
on my Island storms are now
unpredictable
and frequently turn into Super typhoons
strong enough to impact our economy
destroy homes
and create fear at the very sound of
wind gusts and heavy rain
all while our Shoreline continues to
disappear
as a son of the Asia Pacific President
Obama understands how indigenous people
are the keepers of the land
and that we are deeply connected to it
he recognizes impacted communities must
have a seat at the table as we ensure
accountability and action
for all parties who create large
emissions
young people must do and are doing our
part as well
as the youngest elected official In My
House of Representatives
I feel this drive to action every day
and I am not the only one
as President Obama told us at our
gathering of Obama leaders we are the
ones we've been waiting for
we have the wisdom of our elders
the enthusiasm of our youth
who have taken their place as leaders in
this movement
we must recognize and respect this
leadership
and see it for the renewable resource
that it is
we know it's up to us
and so does he
please join me in welcoming President
Barack Obama
thank you
thank you so much thank you
hello Glasgow
thank you very much thank you please
well it is wonderful to be back in the
UK it is
let's face it wonderful to be traveling
anywhere these days
and thank you Sheila for that
outstanding introduction and for all the
work that you are doing
in a part of the world that is feeling
the effects of climate change right now
thank you
for making what sometimes can seem a
bunch of abstract numbers painfully
immediately real so we're very grateful
for her
um
I am a private citizen now
so trips like this feel a little bit
different than they used to
I don't get invited to the big group
photo
traffic is a thing again
music doesn't play when I walk into the
room
on the positive side I can give a speech
like this without wearing a tie and not
create a scandal back home
I hope
but even though I'm not required to
attend Summits like this anymore old
habits die hard
and when the issue at hand is the health
of our planet
and the world our children and our
grandchildren will inherit then you will
have a hard time keeping me awake
and that's why I'm here today
to talk about what's happened in the six
years since I spoke to the United States
nation's climate change conference in
Paris
and to talk about the steps we need to
take if we want to keep doing big things
because when it comes to climate
time really is running out
you're the same message from world
leaders last week
and now that they've left here's what we
can report
meaningful progress has been made since
Paris
and the agreements made here in Glasgow
thanks to so many of you including
my friend John Kerry here
foreign
[Applause]
thanks to your efforts
here in Glasgow
we see the promise of further progress
what is also true
is that collectively and individually
we are still falling short
we have not done nearly enough to
address this crisis
we are going to have to do more
and whether that happens or not to a
large degree
is going to depend on you
not just those of you in this room
but anybody who's watching
or reading a transcript of what I say
here today
that was true six years ago as well
and on Paris our goal was to turn
progress
into an enduring framework that would
give the world confidence in a
low-carbon future
an agreement where countries would
update their emissions Targets on a
regular basis
an agreement that would help developing
nations get the resources they need to
skip the dirty phase of development
and help those Nations that are most
vulnerable to climate change get the
resources they need to adapt
an agreement that would give businesses
and investors the certainty that the
global economy is on a firm path towards
a clean and sustainable future
in other words
Our Hope was to create an agreement that
gave our planet a fighting chance that
was our ambition
and by some measures
the agreement has been a success
for the first time leaders of nearly 200
Nations large and small developed and
developing made a commitment to work
together to confront a threat
to the people of all Nations
and that seemed proof that for all the
divisions in our world when a crisis
threatens all of us we can come together
to address it
at the time we also believe that if
enough National governments showed they
were serious about climate
than other institutions particularly in
the private sector would start raising
their sites as well
and over the last six years
that is what's happened today more than
one-fifth of the world's largest
companies have set net zero emissions
targets
not just because it's the right thing to
do for the environment
but in many cases because it makes sense
for their bottom line
more than 700 cities in more than 50
countries
have pledged to cut their emissions in
half by the end of the decade
and reaching at zero by 2050.
about a third of the global banking
sector has agreed to align their work
with the Paris agreement
so that's meaningful now back in the
United States of course some of our
progress stalled when
my successor decided to unilaterally
pull out of the Paris agreement in his
first year in office
I wasn't real happy about that
and yet
the determination of our state and local
governments
along with the regulations and
investment that my administration had
already put in place allowed our country
to keep moving forward
despite hostility from
the White House
the 90 billion dollar investment that we
made in 2009 helped to jump start the
clean energy industry in the United
States and markets adapted and so did
consumers
and even when
the Trump Administration rolled back
emissions requirements for automakers
along with regulatory changes and
efficiency standards many businesses
chose to stay the course
they kept reducing emissions they
continued the transition to electric
vehicles and energy saving appliances
the ball had been rolling
and it didn't stop
and meanwhile Science and Technology
continued to advance
so today the price of Solar and wind
energy has dropped to the point where in
some places clean energy is cheaper than
fossil fuels
around the world scientists and
entrepreneurs are integrating abundant
renewable energy more powerful batteries
breakthroughs and feels like synthetic
biology to invent a better future that
is healthier and more affordable
that's all good news for the planet
and it is also good news for people
looking for a job
in the U.S alone more than 3 million
people now work in clean energy related
jobs that is more than the number of
people currently employed by the entire
fossil fuel industry
so despite four years of active
hostility toward climate science
coming from the very top of our federal
government
the American people managed to still
meet our original commitment under the
Paris agreement
and not only that but the rest of the
world stayed in the deal
and now with President Biden and his
administration rejoining the agreement
the U.S government is once again engaged
and prepared to take a leadership role
and everybody who's been watching John
Kerry run around here knows
that we take that role seriously
as the world's second largest emitter of
greenhouse gases
the U.S has to lead
we have
enormous responsibilities
and obviously we still have a lot of
work to do
but last week Congress passed President
Biden's bipartisan infrastructure bill
that will among other things create
manufacturing create jobs manufacturing
solar panels and wind turbines and
batteries and electric bill vehicles and
build out the first ever national
network of charging stations so families
can travel across the U.S in electric
vehicles
and I'm confident that a version of
President Biden's build back better bill
will pass through Congress in the coming
next few weeks
and here's what
it will mean when that bill does pass
that legislation will devote over half a
trillion dollars
to reduce greenhouse gas emissions
by over a billion metric tons by the end
of the decade at least 10 times more
than any legislation previously passed
by Congress
along the way it will reduce Consumer
Energy costs it will invest in a clean
energy economy it will create hundreds
of thousands of jobs and it will set the
United States on course to meet its new
climate targets
achieving a 50 to 52 percent reduction
in greenhouse gas emissions below
2005 levels
by 2030.
so the U.S is back
and in moving more boldly the U.S is not
alone
earlier this year
the UK government our hosts
announced a plan to cut emissions by
almost 80 percent by 2035.
this summer The European Union put
themselves on a path to carbon
neutrality by 2050.
Korea passed a carbon Neutrality Act in
September that requires the government
to cut greenhouse gas emissions 35
percent or more by 2030.
the Canadian government has laid out a
path to carbon neutrality by 2050 with
Milestones to hit along the way
so Paris showed the world that progress
is possible created a framework
important work was done there and
important work
has been done here
that is the good news
now for the bad news
we are nowhere near where we need to be
yet
for starters despite the progress that
Paris represented most countries have
failed to meet the action plans that
they set six years ago
and the consequences of not moving fast
enough are becoming more apparent all
the time
last month a study found that 85 percent
of the global population has experienced
weather events that were more severe
because of climate change
stronger storms longer heat waves more
intense flooding crippling droughts
parts of the world are becoming more
dangerous to live in
triggering new migration patterns and
worsening conflict around the globe it's
one of the reasons why the U.S pentagon
and other U.S agencies have said that
climate change poses a national security
threat for the U.S and for everyone else
but not only did we not hit all of the
targets that were pledged in Paris
but remember Paris was always supposed
to be a beginning
not an end point
of our joint effort to control climate
change
back in 2015 we knew that even if the
commitments made as a part of the Paris
agreement were fully met we would still
fall short of our goal of keeping Global
temperature increases below 1.5 degrees
Celsius
and that's why Paris was designed to be
a framework for countries to constantly
ratchet up their Ambitions as they got
more resources and as technology reduced
the cost of transitioning to a clean
energy economy
so we come now here to Glasgow and just
was as true with the Paris agreement
there is good news and bad news about
what has happened here this past week
the good news
in large part because of the efforts of
the people in this room
the hours of work that you spent
with
you know wheat coffee and bad food and
feeling sleepy
because of you
countries around the world
are recognizing this is a decisive
decade
to avoid a climate disaster and are
setting some really important goals for
2030.
more than 100 countries this past week
have committed to reduce methane
emissions by 30 percent by 2030. as all
of you know curbing methane emissions is
currently the single fastest and most
effective way to limit warming
more than 100 countries have also
promised to stop and reverse
deforestation by the end of 2030.
businesses from around the world name
brands some of the biggest businesses
on this planet have agreed to help
create a market for the Technologies we
need to transition to clean energy
here in Glasgow Nations have also
committed to help poorer countries move
away from fossil fuels and deal with the
effects of climate change
President Biden announced that the U.S
will be quadrupling its annual climate
Finance pledge over the next few years
to 11 billion dollars including three
billion dollars
dedicated to helping vulnerable
countries adapt to the impacts of
climate change
and the U.S along with 20 other
countries agreed to stop publicly
financing International fossil fuel
development with limited exceptions
so these are significant accomplishments
they are hard-won commitments
you should be proud of yourselves and we
need to celebrate
those commitments even as we demand that
the signatories to these commitments
actually follow through
we have to track it
they're not self-executing
they're going to require effort but
let's assume that we actually delivered
that's significant
but once again we also have to
acknowledge that this progress is
partial
most Nations have failed to be as
ambitious as they need to be
the escalation the ratcheting up of
ambition that we anticipated in Paris
six years ago
has not been uniformly realized
I have to confess it was particularly
discouraging to see the leaders of two
of the world's largest emitters
China and Russia declined to even attend
the proceedings
and their National plans so far reflect
what appears to be
a dangerous lack of urgency a
willingness to maintain the status quo
on the part of those governments and
that's a shame
we need advanced economies like the U.S
and Europe leading on this issue
but you know the facts we also need
China and India leading on this issue
we need Russia leading on this issue
just as we need Indonesia and South
Africa and Brazil leading on this issue
we can't afford anybody on the sidelines
I recognize we're living in a moment
when International cooperation has waned
a moment of Greater geopolitical tension
and stress in part because of the
pandemic
in part because of the rise of
nationalism and
tribal impulses around the world
and yes in part because of a lack of
leadership on America's part for four
years on a host of multilateral issues
I understand that it's harder to get
International cooperation there are more
Global tensions
but there is one thing that should
transcend our day-to-day politics and
normal geopolitics and that is climate
change
it's not just that we can't afford to go
backward we can't afford to stay where
we are
the world has to step up and it has to
step up now
so how's that going to happen
how do we close the gap between what's
necessary
for our survival and what seems
politically possible right now
I confess
I don't have all the answers
as I'm sure
is true for all of you out there those
of you who are steeped in this work who
are far more expert than me
there are times where I feel discouraged
there are times where the future seems
somewhat bleak
there are times where I am doubtful that
Humanity can get its act together before
it's too late
and and then images of dystopia start
creeping into my dreams
and yet whenever I feel such despondency
I remind myself that cynicism
is the recourse of cowards
we can't afford hopelessness
instead we are going to have to muster
the will and the passion
and the activism of citizens pushing
governments companies and everyone else
to meet this challenge
that's what allowed the U.S to do its
part over the last few years to meet our
climate goals even when we didn't have
much leadership on it
it wasn't just elected officials or CEOs
doing the right thing it was ordinary
Americans
making their voices heard making it
clear we need to solve this problem
regardless of the obstacles people who
organize and educated others in their
communities people who put pressure on
businesses and governments to do better
people who turn their passion into votes
that's the kind of commitment we're
going to need going forward
because let's face it this is not just
about
raw numbers this is not just about
science
this is about politics it's about
culture
it's about morality
it's about the human dynamic
how do we work together to get a big
thing done
and it's about participation
and Power
thinking back on my own experience as
president
I would have had the power to do even
more to fight climate change during my
time in office if I'd had a stable
Congressional majority that was willing
and eager to take action
and for the bulk of my presidency I
didn't have that majority
gaining such majorities require an
Engaged citizenry willing to do what it
takes to reward politicians who take
this problem seriously and send out of
office those who don't
I am convinced that President Biden's
built back better bill will be historic
and a huge
Plus for U.S action on climate change
but keep in mind Joe Biden wanted to do
even more
he's constrained by
the absence of a robust majority that's
needed to make that happen
both both of us have been constrained in
large part by the fact that one of our
two major parties
has decided not only to sit on the
sidelines but Express active hostility
toward climate of science
and make climate change a partisan issue
perhaps some of you have a similar
dynamic in your own countries although
generally speaking
the United States seems to have a
John a uh
a more vigorous opposition to climate
than in many other places
but my broader point is that's got to
stop saving the planet isn't a partisan
issue
I welcome any faction within the
Republican Party in the United States
that takes climate change seriously
and that may be a rare breed right now
but keep in mind
sexual Republican elected officials used
to be commonplace used to exist
President George H.W bush a Republican
was one of the first U.S presidents to
officially recognize the threat of
climate change was a signatory to the
Rio Accord
if we are going to act on the scale
that's required
climate change can't be seen
anywhere in the world as just an
opportunity to score political points
and for those listening back home in the
U.S let me say this it doesn't matter if
you're a Republican or a Democrat
if your Florida house is flooded by
Rising Seas
or your crops fail in The Dakotas
or your California house is burning down
nature physics
science do not care about party
affiliation
and what is true in the United States is
true in every nation
we don't just need the Democrats or
the green party or progressives to be
working together on this existential
problem we need everybody
even if we disagree on other things
and what's also true around the world
through in the U.S true in all the
countries represented here
is that the most important energy in
this movement
is coming from young people
and the reason is simple
they have more stake in this fight than
anybody else
and that's why I want to spend the rest
of my time today talking directly to
young people who may be watching and
wondering what they can do to help
I am the father of two daughters in the
early 20s
so I have some sense of
all the stuff that gets thrown at young
people these days
it's not always easy being young today
and for more most of your lives if
you're in that generation you've been
bombarded
with warnings about what the future will
look like if you don't address climate
change
and meanwhile you've grown up watching
many of the adults who are in positions
to do nothing about it
the problem doesn't exist
fuse to make the hard decisions
necessary to address it
and that's a source of real anxiety
and real anger at
older people
and some of you no doubt wonder if
you'll
be able to be safe in the community
where you've grown up
whether you'll have to raise your own
kids in a world ravaged by extreme
weather and climate migration and
conflict
as one 16 year old said
for us the destruction of the planet is
personal
and that's why my message to young
people begins with acknowledging you are
right to be frustrated
folks in my generation have not done
enough to deal with a potentially
cataclysmic problem that you now stand
in here
but I also want to share some advice for
my mother used to give me
you know if I was feeling anxious or
angry or depressed or scared
she'd look at me and she'd say don't
salt
get busy
get to work
and change what needs to be changed
and luckily that's exactly what
young people around the world are doing
right now
two years ago a Swedish teenager named
Greta thurnberg inspired millions of
people to join the largest climate
demonstrations in decades
a lot of people now know about Greta but
the world is full of gretas
one of the things I love most about our
work at the Obama Foundation is getting
to meet young activists from all over
the world taking up the Baton on climate
change
you just heard from Sheila babata
from the Northern Mariana Islands as an
elected representative Sheila is
fighting to preserve natural resources
on the island
and helping young people take the lead
in the fight for human rights and
climate action
I've met people like Juan Carlos
Monterey Gomez from Panama
after representing his country at the
Paris negotiations I think he was like
22.
one then LED an effort to amend the
Constitution of Panama today he's here
in Glasgow as a climate negotiator
[Applause]
you've got uh Colette Pinscher
battle who is the founder and executive
director of the Gulf Coast Center for
Law and policy in Louisiana back in the
States they're a non-profit helping
communities of color across the South
that are already feeling the effects of
climate change rebuild after disasters
and build more sustainable communities
and more sustainable economies
and then there is Louisiana
an activist who leads Fridays for future
strikes in Germany
during the global climate strikes in
2019 Louisa helped organize 270 000
Marchers in Berlin put pressure on
German political parties to take climate
change seriously
climate change is frightening she said
so the question is how can we turn this
anxiety into something constructive
that's what these young leaders are
already doing
I'm I'm really looking forward to
sitting down and talking with some of
them in a separate form later today
because they're not just working for
their own countries they are forming a
movement across borders
to make the older generation that got us
into this mess see that we all have an
obligation to dig ourselves out of it
and if those older folks won't listen
they need to get out of the way
now at this point some of the young
people watching or listening they may be
thinking I don't have time to organize
200 000 people
or propose a constitutional amendment
I've got a math exam next week
I get that I promise you unlike Greta I
was not on the cover of Time Magazine
when I was 16 years old and if I was
skipping school it had nothing to do
with climate change
foreign
but there are plenty of things that each
and every one of you
young people can do that won't require
devoting your entire life to the cause
but will make a real difference
the first and most important is
if you are age eligible
to vote the issue
vote like your life depends on it
because it does
I recognize that a lot of young people
may be cynical about politics
but the cold hard fact is
we will not have more ambitious climate
plans coming out of governments
unless governments feel some
pressure from voters
in one survey of young people in 22
countries
more people cited climate change as one
of the most important issues facing the
world than anything else
young people understand this issue but
they don't always vote at the same
levels as older folks
many young people are now starting to
realize I've gotta make my interests
heard
if I had the opportunity to vote
so in the 2020 U.S presidential election
young people were more likely than older
voters to say that climate change was
their top concern
and they also voted at a rate 11 points
higher
than in 2016.
that's the kind of thing that makes
politicians sit up and take notice
as one 20 year old organizer said young
people understand that if we want to
save our lives and our future then we
have to do it ourselves
and this is part of your power that you
have to use
don't think that you can ignore politics
you don't have to be happy about it but
you can't ignore it
you can't be too pure for it
it's part of the process that is going
to deliver all of us
the second way you can have an impact on
climate change is by pressuring
companies to do the right thing
members of your generation have already
shown you're willing to pay for products
that you believe are responsible and
responsive to The Climate Challenge and
that you're also willing to avoid those
companies that are actually making
climate change worse as I see this in my
my own daughters and their friends their
peer group in terms of which companies
they support and which products they buy
and not only are they sophisticated
consumers they're active and engaged
citizens and and that's a message that
CEOs will learn to understand companies
are starting to figure out that becoming
more energy efficient is good for their
bottom line because they'll spend less
on energy but you also have the
opportunity to teach them but that by
getting serious about climate change
they have a chance to win loyal
customers
and employees
and they conversely will lose customers
and Top Flight employees
if they're not on the right side of the
issue that's part of your power you need
to use it
while you're at it
you need to help educate your parents
and grandparents your uncles and aunts
your teachers your employers
because while a dangerously warming
planet is a reality that a lot of
you have grown up with as as young
people you've studied in school you've
read about it
it's been part of the backdrop of of
your childhood
members of the older generation don't
have that same frame of reference
they do love you though they do care
about you
they listen to you more than you think
and if you explain how important the
issue is to you
you may lead them to rethink their
position or at least be more open-minded
in fact I'm pretty sure they'll listen
to you in a way they might never listen
to
a politician or some expert on TV or a
former president
that's power you have you have to use it
and finally let me say
it will not be enough to Simply
mobilize
the converted
it will not be enough to preach to the
choir
it will not be enough to just ramp up
intensity among people who already know
about climate change and already agree
with us and care deeply about it
protests are necessary
to raise awareness
#campaigns can spread awareness
but to build the broad-based coalitions
necessary for bold action
we have to persuade people who either
currently don't agree with us
or are indifferent to the issue
and to change the minds of those fellow
citizens in our respective countries
we have to do a little more listening
we can't just yell at them
for say they're ignorant
we can't just tweet at them
it's not enough to inconvenience them
through blocking traffic
in a protest
we actually have to listen to their
objections
and understand the reluctance of some
ordinary people
to see their countries move too fast on
climate change we have to understand
their realities
and work with them
so that serious action on climate change
doesn't
adversely impact them
so listen it is true a lot of climate
opposition comes from fossil fuel
companies trying to make a buck
despite the green ads that they run on
TV
it's true that there are climate deniers
out there who for ideological reasons
you will never convince
but I'm not talking about them I'm
talking about the fact
that we've got to persuade the guy who
has to drive to his Factory job every
single day
can't afford a Tesla
and might not be able to pay the rent or
feed his family if gas prices go up
we have to think about
the mother in India who yes will suffer
droughts and floods made worse by
climate change but whose more immediate
concern
is getting electricity so her children
don't have to sit in the dark every
night and can't do their homework
that's not a
that you can't dismiss that concern
there are workers and communities that
still depend on coal for power and jobs
and they yes they are concerned about
maintaining
their wages
that's not a reasonable for them to be
concerned about them
and the fact is the truth is that
transitioning from Dirty energy to clean
energy does have a cost
and it is not unreasonable for people
who often are already economically
vulnerable
and maybe don't feel particularly
politically powerful it's not
unreasonable for them to think that
for all the highfalutin talk some of
those costs of transition will be borne
by them not by the more powerful and the
privilege that's not an unreasonable
perspective for them to have
and that's why when it comes to climate
change a country like the US with a
higher per capita carbon footprint does
have to do more than
a country like Mali or Bangladesh
it's also why we need to make sure the
people most affected by the transition
to clean energy
aren't the ones bearing most of the cost
they don't have any margin for error
I can afford to give up a lot
of my current lifestyle to benefit the
planet because I'll still have a lot
left over a lot of folks don't have that
cushion
so that means that any climate plan
worth it salt has to take these
inequities into account whether it's
through subsidies
to poor people to ease the transition to
clean energy whether it's technology
transfers that help poor countries meet
their development goals by leap frogging
dirty fuels we have to pay attention
to those embedded inequities
and the politics that surrounds them
and that's not easy
so let me close by being born
keeping the rise in global temperatures
to 1.5 degrees Celsius
will not be easy
it is going to be hard
existing political institutions move
slowly
even When leaders are well-intentioned
International cooperation has always
been difficult
it's made more difficult by all the
misinformation and propaganda that can
flood out through social media these
days
Business Leaders let's face it are
typically rewarded for boosting
short-term profits
not addressing major social issues
getting people to work together on a
global scale
takes time
and right now that's time we don't have
so if we're honest with ourselves yes
this is going to be really hard
the thing we had going for us
is that Humanity has done hard things
before
I believe we can do hard things again
yes the process will be messy
I guarantee you every Victory will be
incomplete
we will face
more setbacks
sometimes we will be forced to settle
for imperfect compromises because even
if they don't achieve everything we want
at least
they Advance the cause at least they
move the ball down the field
but if we work hard enough for long
enough
those partial victories
add up
if we push hard enough
stay focused enough and are smart about
it
those victories accelerate and they
build momentum
if we listen to those who
are resistant
and we take their concerns seriously and
we work with them and reorganize and we
mobilize
and we get our hands dirty in the
difficulties
of changing
political Dynamics in our countries
those victories
start happening a little bit more
frequently
if we stay with it we will get this done
so to all the young people out there
as well as those of you who consider
yourselves young at heart
I want you to stay angry
I want you to stay frustrated
but channel that anger
harness that frustration
keep pushing harder and harder for more
and more
because that's what's required to meet
this challenge
gird yourself
for a marathon
not a Sprint
for solving a problem this big this
complex and this important has never
happened all at once
since we're
in the emerald Isles here let me quote
the BART William Shakespeare
what wound he writes
did ever heal but by the grease
our planet has been wounded
by our actions
those wounds
won't be healed
today or tomorrow or the next
but they can be healed
by degrees
and if we start with that spirit
if each of us can fight through the
occasional frustration and Dread
if we pledge to do our part and then
follow through on those commitments
I believe we can secure a better future
we have to
and what a profound and Noble task
to set for ourselves
I'm ready for the Long Haul if you are
so let's get to work
thank you very much everybody
foreign
ER U.S president Barack Obama there
receiving a standing ovation after his
speech at the cop 26 Summit here in
Glasgow we heard a rallying call for
Action from the former president he said
that meaningful progress had been made
since Paris he was in Paris of course
when the Paris agreement was signed on
climate change and he said along with
the announcements made in Glasgow he
said he saw the promise of further
progress but he said what was also true
collectively and individually we are
falling short he said we are going to
have to do more and this is going to
depend on you he was critical of
President XI and Putin for what he
described as a dangerous absence of
urgency but he also said the U.S was
back he made a few Digs at president
Trump but he said that now that Joe
Biden was back he felt that could be
transformative he said the U.S has to
lead as the world's second biggest
emitter we have enormous
responsibilities
but he pointed to the fact that the
infrastructure Bill had gone through
Congress last week and he said that a
version of Biden's buildback better bill
would pass he thought in the next few
weeks releasing trillions of dollars to
tackle this issue he also talked about
the hope that he got from young people
he did say there were times when he felt
discouraged and the future feels Bleak
but he said we can't afford hopelessness
and he said the most important energy in
this movement at the moment was coming
from young people and he said that's why
he wanted to spend the rest of his day
here in Glasgow with those Youngs people
so wide-ranging speech he's been
speaking for some time now received very
warmly there in the hall here in Glasgow
so lots of issues he touched on there
joining me now and throughout the
afternoon is navra singhali who's
program director of the global
environment and climate change law at
Edinburgh law school so so welcome to
you
um first of all just a general question
when you have someone like President
Obama with his kind of status and his
history do you think that people do sit
up and listen do you think he can make a
difference in in galvanizing some kind
of change yeah I mean it's you know
American Presidents often talk a really
good game and he's talked a better one
than most and now that he's out of
office he can you know make all sorts of
promises but I think he does a couple of
things when he gives a speech like that
one is that he really galvanizes the
faithful you know he really speaks to a
large community of the global audience
who really want this process to succeed
and that's obviously enormously
important and you saw the response that
he received
um and I think there's also you know a
fair element of domestic signaling in
what he's doing that America is really
participating in the big game the big
Global game anymore it's not an
isolationist position which is very
different and there's obviously a
constituency back home that really wants
to hear that so I think he's playing you
know a multi-level game there that's
right he kept saying the US is back
exactly yeah I mean so you know very but
words like that mean a lot to the Core
Democratic base
that's right so and he also did talk
about the progress since Paris because
he was in Paris at the time and he felt
that meaningful progress had been made
but it didn't go far enough I mean how
are we able to measure how much progress
has been made since then we've measure
progress in a number of different ways I
mean the the most simple possibly
simplistic way to measure progress is to
look at what's happened to Global
emissions since 2015 since Paris was
concluded and they've gone up another is
to look at things like climate Finance
you know how much money that was
committed in in fact even going back to
2011 in Copenhagen when President Obama
led the uh LED those negotiations
um you know there was a promise of 100
billion per annum or for Global Finance
principally from the developed to the
less developed World
um that money still hasn't been hit so
those are supposed to be all in place
now by 2020 and we're not there yet I
suspect we may get pretty close by the
end of this week but we're not there yet
um and there's also a question as to the
adequacy of those sorts of sums I mean
it sounds like a lot of money but you
know you just heard that the domestic
package was running to the trillions and
in that scheme 100 billion globally you
know it depends how much it unlocks it's
also an issue of How It's spent as well
how it's spent uh the processes by which
it spends you know the I think the
central question is how much private
money it leverages
you know so if it's you know one to one
two hundred billion doesn't really go
very far if it's 20 to 1 then it looks
starting to look like serious money
and what about
um what's been agreed so far at this cop
ped well because he referenced the fact
that pledges had been made by countries
and that new pledges have been made here
so what has been achieved so far we're
one week down so I think there are three
seriously big
um commitments which are all processes
which have come together last week the
one was on forestry the international
agreement on forestry and that's really
very very significant the second goes to
methane I think that's more of a
technical fix but still very substantial
in the terms that were just outlined and
I think the third one which was by far
the biggest which hasn't really got a
lot of play is the way in which
um many of the most advanced economies
in the world have agreed not to finance
foreign fossil fuel
infrastructure and
production and that is enormous I mean
the idea that we're not not only are we
taking action domestically but we're
going to stop taking negative action
abroad it's massive absolutely enormous
but some people sorry to interact some
people will be skeptical though won't
they they'll they'll say we've had
agreements before I think there was a
forestry agreement in 2014 and those
pledges haven't been met so do they
count for anything
what so this is really the handout this
this is that depends on two things one
very short term issue and one a longer
term issue the short-term issue is
what's in the the Glasgow declaration as
it's probably going to be called
um at the end of this week you know so
what teeth does that have what level of
commitment does that statement have so
that's the very short term thing the
longer term thing sorry what could that
include could that include a kind of
commitment to to monitoring or to to
checking in every year or what might
that include it could include
um well it will certainly include things
like monitoring but the checking
endpoint is very important engagement
with other regimes so for example on the
export Finance piece that I just
mentioned if that was to be keyed in to
established processes such as the oecds
export Finance regime that would really
give it teeth that's a well-established
regime so that would be a commitment
which was made here but delivered
elsewhere so you know that sort of
joined up system if it Global governance
is what you'd be looking for so what
will we expect at the end of this week I
mean
a million dollar question but
negotiations continuing but but what
actually would you think they're talking
about behind the scenes now so there are
two tracks of negotiations essentially I
mean the one is the the official agenda
and the official agenda is really quite
narrow I mean this is a bit of an odd
cop I'm sure you've had this
conversation with your other guests but
it's a bit of a strange copy in that the
official agenda is not dominating the
conversation uh the official agenda is
essentially about a tech really
technical issue about carbon markets the
article 6 debate
um it's important it's very important
but it's relatively discreet the
political agenda is a really big one and
what's odd about that is that it's
really between the UK presidency and
clubs so different groupings of Nations
it's not between the UK and
um 196 State parties
um so the you know the forestry one was
with forestry Nations the uh fossil fuel
Finance one was you know the countries
who do that so there are these different
clubs who are engaging in these
negotiations of the challenge is to
bring all of that together by Saturday
into something which every state party
can sign up to not just the little clubs
the little clusters of groupings but
everybody can sign up to and that's
really difficult because
you know there are a lot of conflicting
views and preferences on these issues so
that's going to be you know if if the
presidency can deliver that I think that
will be a very significant diplomatic
achievement so is it likely that there's
a text at this stage which is being
shuttled around different groups and
different nations and people are
tweaking sentences then you go back to
another country and detect they're happy
I mean how does it work well that would
be the process but I don't think that
started to the best of my knowledge that
hasn't started or at least if it has
started it started within a very small
circle that the of uh allies and friends
that the UK presidency is engaging with
it hasn't gone broader than that quite
yet I think it's too early but yeah
there would be that process of diplomacy
arguing about language and how crucial
is the money in all of that today the
the theme of the sessions and of the day
is all about resilience and adaptation
and and loss and damage isn't it so so
what extent is the money it's obviously
crucial for adaptation but how much is
it crucial for trust and Good Will and
progress as far as the general tools are
concerned you're absolutely right it is
about trust and Goodwill as well the
money is what unlocks the
um participation and approval of
broadly speaking the less developed
world the non-industrialized world the
sorts of States who haven't contributed
to the problem but as we well know are
most vulnerable to its impacts and what
they really want to see is Hard Cash to
protect them to uh to solve the problem
to the extent that it impacts them
um and that's what's been missing I mean
Finance day was I think Wednesday of
last week and we saw some enormous
numbers being bandied about
um but those need to be I think they
need to be bottomed out somewhat and
made a little bit more concrete
so what do you think is the key to
unlocking all of this is there one
announcement or one breakthrough that
could determine whether or not this is a
success no I don't think there is I
think this is going to be
um I think it's a bit of a jigsaw puzzle
um in which there are going to be lots
of different elements so we've and this
seems to be the approach that the UK
government's taking that there are a
number of different elements which have
to come together in some sort of
configuration rather than one single
thing which unlocks everything I don't
think these are such complicated
negotiations they've been going on for
more than quarter of the century
um you know if there was if there was a
silver bullet we would have identified
it by now but there isn't and obviously
the the aim that's been set out by many
of the organizers is to keep 1.5 alive
this idea of making sure that capping
global warming at 1.5 degrees remains
Within Reach have we reached that stage
yet or is it how difficult is it going
to be to calculate or determine whether
or not it's been reached by the end
we've certainly it's in progress this
week I mean it's really interesting that
um there have been updated ndc's these
National commitments uh or contributions
rather from
you know some some really large emitters
India Vietnam Indonesia and uh and
others
um all of which actually bring us much
closer to one and a half so you know
last week before cop even it was looking
like 2.7 degrees now according to some
calculations that I've seen that's about
1.8 1.9 degrees that's a very
significant change so I think the the
trajectory is moving in the right
direction but that's everyone meets
their pledges that's if everybody
man if everything that people want to do
they're able to do that the technology
works that the money's in place
um you know all of these sorts of things
that we don't have backsliding you know
we've witnessed backsliding in all sorts
of
Arenas
um uh through populist movements in the
last 10 years or so so yeah I mean there
are a huge number of moving Parts but
yeah everything has to go right so this
is it's a it's a very complex game and
what about the power of of young people
as well we heard of President Obama
there saying that some of the most
exciting conversations that are going on
at the moment and some of the most
exciting drive is amongst young people I
mean to what extent does the power of
the voice on the street and the power of
the Next Generation to what extent can
that move the dial and help change
political minds and make them act well I
mean as I'm sure President Obama's just
found out it's very difficult to speak
on this topic without sounding
incredibly patronizing for young people
um but one thing that we've certainly
seen is that
um young people in the Friday Futures
movement and others have really managed
to
um
crystallize public opinion or a large
segment of public opinion around this
issue
and but you know I think telling them to
vote or to be responsible consumers is
I'm not quite the way to do it
now for us sing golly really good to
talk to you thanks very much indeed
so former U.S president Barack Obama has
just delivered his remarks to cop26 so
let's take a listen to some of that
right now
most Nations have failed to be as
ambitious as they need to be
the escalation the rapturing up of
ambition that we anticipated in Paris
six years ago
has not been uniformly realized
I have to confess it was particularly
discouraging to see the leaders of two
of the world's largest emitters
China and Russia declined to even attend
the proceedings
and their National plans so far reflect
what appears to be
a dangerous lack of urgency a
willingness to maintain the status quo
on the part of those governments and
that's a shame
we need advanced economies like the U.S
and Europe leading on this issue
but you know the facts we also need
China and India leading on this issue
we need Russia leading on this issue
just as we need Indonesia and South
Africa and Brazil leading on this issue
we can't afford anybody on the sidelines
former president Barack Obama speaking
in the last hour or so now the second
week of [ __ ] 26 has begun and countries
are being urged to put loss and damage
at the center of negotiations ministers
and leaders are looking into solutions
to help the most vulnerable countries to
adapt to global warming it comes as you
saw there as former U.S president Barack
Obama has told the summit that small
island nations are the canaries in the
coal mine of climate change and are
sending a message on the need for Urgent
action well joining me now is climate
Justice activist Vanessa nacarte and
Scotland's first Minister Nicholas
surgeon so welcome to both of you thanks
so much for talking to us first of all
Vanessa nicate you've been campaigning
for climate Justice for several years
now and you founded your own protest
movement in Uganda pushing for Action so
what's the main thing that you want from
cop26 I want leaders to acknowledge that
loss and damage is here with us now
community is from countries like mine in
the global South they're already on the
front lines of the climate crisis there
are things that we can no longer adapt
to we cannot adapt to Extinction we
cannot adapt to starvation we cannot
adapt to our lost cultures or our lost
Traditions or our lost identities so
right now I want the leaders to show us
the money to put a separate fund for
loss and damage because we are facing
the worst of the climate crisis right
now how confident are you that that
money will come a hundred billion
dollars was promised years ago it was
due to be delivered in 2020 last year
and it's still not there are you
confident there will be the commitments
that you want I'm not confident because
like I can say that a hundred billion
dollars that was promised by the leaders
including President Obama has not yet
been delivered it has been delayed to
2023 which is unfair to communities that
are on the front lines of the climate
crisis and the most ironic and tragic
thing is that these communities didn't
cause the climate crisis they are not
responsible for the rising greenhouse
gas emissions so it's really
disappointing to see that the
Deliverance the implementation of the
100 billion dollars has not yet been
delivered more and more broken promises
more and more delays and what does this
lead to loss and damage for our
communities and you've spoke
passionately on this spoken passionately
on this subject both inside the
conference and out on the streets as
well so do you feel that you're being
listened to I don't know but I hope that
I'm being listened to and I know that
President Obama is at the cup and we as
young activists especially from the
global South we have been asking him
where is the money that was promised in
2009 I think I was just 13 years old but
now I am 24 and we haven't seen the
Deliverance of that money while our
communities continue to perish and
suffer because of the climate crisis so
we want the presidents we want the
leaders from the global North to show us
the money for loss and damage so do you
think Barack Obama could make a
difference on that
well it depends if he is to give us a
response we held uh we held an action in
the cop this morning we've put out
tweets so if he gives us a response on
the already promised climate Finance
then we will tell whether he can make a
difference Nicola sturgeon um welcome to
you how
do you feel about this 100 billion
dollars I promised so many years ago
still not delivered how crucial is that
money if this Summit is going to be
success it's shameful that 12 years old
it hasn't been delivered in full and the
money is really important but it's also
become a fundamental issue of trust
between the global South and the global
North and it's a key test of success of
this cup Summit to get to that 100
billion dollars a year not by 2023 but
now because it was meant to be delivered
last year in 2020 but even if that total
is delivered there's no commitment at
all to dedicate any of that money to
loss and damage yes it's important to
mitigate the climate change it's
important to adapt to climate change but
countries like Vanessa's are feeling the
impact right now they're suffering the
loss and damage right now and in many
cases that's loss of life it's loss of
livelihood it's not abstract it's real
Scotland has this week become the first
developed country in the world to commit
resources to loss and damage now
Scotland's a small country so it's a
relatively small sum of money in global
terms one million pounds but it's
intended also to send a message to other
developed countries that we caused
climate change we are responsible for
the impact that countries like Vanessa's
are experiencing right now so this is
not an act of Charity it's an obligation
and a responsibility of reparation that
we owe and I hope other Rich developed
countries step up and recognize that
obligation and I'm sure all money that's
contributed is very welcome but what
about trust in leaders meeting promises
I know that Scotland isn't officially
party to the UN climate convention but
the Scottish government did voluntarily
submit some ndcs that some nationally
determined contribution targets as all
the parties are required to do under
under the Paris agreement which is
laudable but Scotland hasn't met those
targets has it we set ourselves legally
binding annual targets so that we can
measure progress along the way to our 75
reduction Target by 2030 Net Zero by
2045 because they are annual targets
which most countries don't do yes
there'll be some years where we fall
short but let's put it in context we
were hopefully by now we would have
reduced our emissions by 55 we've Fallen
a bit short of that but we've reduced
our emissions by 51.5 so we've
decarbonized faster than any G20 country
and in Scotland we're already halfway to
Net Zero we've got much much more to do
and the bad of what would leadership is
too low it's too easy to be a world
leader but Scotland is leading by
example but do you understand the
frustration then of activists like
Vanessa who come here and they hear
politicians making promises and they
don't meet them well I would argue
Scotland is delivering on its
commitments but we've got to go much
further and much faster it's not an
accident that I'm standing here next to
Vanessa I've made a commitment and
actually it's a bigger commitment on
Vanessa's part for us to catch up during
pop so that I can listen to the voice of
Vanessa and the the many people across
the global South that she represents
because it's right that she challenges
people like me to go further and that
people like me listen and recognize the
massive responsibility that we have I'm
not standing here saying Scotland is
doing everything we should be doing or
as much as we need to do but I think we
are doing more than most we've got to
challenge ourselves to go further and
we've got to do as much as we can to
challenge others to go further too
Vanessa what do you make of the progress
that's been made at cops so far we're
one week in do you feel that things are
going in the right direction
we are getting commitments we are
getting targets but I just want to make
one thing clear commitments do not
reduce emissions targets do not stop
suffering Net Zero promises do not of
Erasure of our histories or our
Traditions what will stop the suffering
of the people on the front lines what
will reduce emissions from rising will
be real action so until I see real
action until we activate still real
action come out of these commitments
that is when we will believe that we are
moving forward because we have seen in
the past hopes there have been
commitments there have been targets but
the emissions have continued to rise so
commitments won't reduce emissions real
action will reduce emissions so when you
hear about the agreements on reducing
methane Emissions on reducing coal
production and protecting forests are
you encouraged or do you think they're
meaningless until you see action what
what's your take do you think that we're
that that it shows willingness and
commitment I will be encouraged by real
action because for so long leaders have
been promising leaders have been
speaking governments have been putting
net zeros for their countries for their
communities but what will convince me is
real action what will convince me is
saying that reducing emissions not empty
promises but then empty actions
so so what do you want to see by the end
of this week then we've had these
commitments and I should say the
International Energy agency has taken
into account all the commitments ahead
of cop and since cop in terms of
countries pledges and targets but also
these groups that have come together on
issues like methane and forests and they
say now that if all those were commit
not just committed to but acted on the
temperature could be capped at 1.8
degrees does that give you encouragement
it's better than what might have been
the case coming into court where it
still looked as if all of the
commitments and remember they've got to
be delivered would only count
temperature rises it may be 2.7 or at
best 2.4 so that is progress if those
commitments are met but it doesn't go
far enough we need to see further
progress and coming out of this a clear
process of how that remaining Gap is
going to be closed and Vanessa's right
that we need to see global emissions
come down and come down fast they're
coming down in Scotland but they're not
coming down globally they're still
Rising globally and we know that in
order to keep that
necessity to limit global warming to 1.5
alive we need to see global emissions
half by the end of this decade so it's
the near-term commitments that countries
are making that matter and also the
detail of how they'll be delivered
according to the international agent NG
agency a moment ago another thing
they've said is that all fossil fuels
need to stay in the ground from now on
so does that mean that you think that
the Cambo oil field should not go ahead
I've already said it should not go ahead
unless there can be an absolutely clear
case made that it is consistent with the
Paris agreements and our climate change
obligations I lead a country I don't
have the power over no C licensing but I
lead a country that right now has maybe
a hundred thousand jobs dependent on oil
and gas much of our energy is still
dependent on oil and gas so I think we
need to move away from fossil fuels much
faster than previously indicated new
projects go completely against that
don't they I think there's a real
question that yes they do which is why
I've said what I said on Campbell the
point I was going to make though as a
leader it's not in enough for me to say
stop something or don't do something
I've also got to look in the eye people
who work in that industry and see how
are we going to justly transition you to
the Alternatives and how are we going to
build up the alternative sources of
energy to reduce our dependence on oil
and gas I'm determined to do that it's
it's one of the tough issues for a
country like Scotland but every country
has to face up to its difficult issues
as well as the relatively easier ones
and Vanessa when you're pushing for
change for a continent that's already
experiencing climate change do you take
on board those arguments from
politicians who say that there are it's
a complicated picture that there are
jobs involved in fossil fuel Industries
for example and it and it's a tricky
process to reduce emissions it's not
always straightforward what's your
reaction to that yeah I should I can say
that when we are taking climate Justice
I think that climate Justice should have
the hearts of the people on the front
lines it should have the working people
on the front line times of at the heart
of the decisions for climate justice so
climate Justice should not leave anyone
behind climate Justice should not mean
that indigenous communities are going to
lose their lands to tree planting
campaigns climate Justice should not
mean that we are going to have electric
vehicles while more children more women
more girls are being exploited in
different parts of the world climate
Justice should not mean that people are
going to lose their jobs that's why we
say we need to stop development of all
new fossil fuel projects because this
will allow for an easier transition for
you know for people for communities to a
more sustainable world and when it comes
to countries like mine countries like
mine are also facing the pressure of
transitioning you know the pressure of
developing without coal or without oil
or without gas but how is this going to
be possible without climate Finance from
the countries that cause the climate
crisis can you envisage getting to the
end of this week and feeling satisfied
with the outcome do you think it's
possible that you will walk away at the
end of this week and feel
feel good about cop26
and I'm going to walk away knowing
different kinds of commitments and
targets that have been set by leaders
but I think the satisfaction will really
come from the real action what follows
at the end of the second week are we
going to just forget that the conference
ended now we can rest and then prepare
for more Targets in at cop27 no what
will follow after this second week will
determine whether we are moving towards
real action or it was just another show
of empty promises and empty ones okay
well Vanessa McCarthy Nicholas sturgeon
thank you both very much indeed for your
time here on scania's climate life we
appreciate it
do stay with us we've got lots coming up
for you in just a moment on Sky News
climate live don't go away
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
of the conference now the United States
Governors are speaking about climate
action and a net zero future so let's
have a little listening
20 40. and last year I signed an
executive order directing State agencies
to set caps on climate pollution for
sectors like Manufacturing increase
Energy Efficiency standards for
buildings and appliances and create a
Statewide plan for electric charging
infrastructure to accelerate the
transition to zero emission vehicles
but the work I'm most proud of that
we're doing in Oregon is the how we are
approaching this work and that is
through an equity lens we all know that
our communities of color our low-income
communities and our rural communities
are disproportionately impacted by these
climate change events
so we are working hard to uh disrupt uh
that uh proportion and let me share a
couple quick examples uh number one we
are working very hard to ensure that we
are centering the voices of our black
our Brown and our indigenous communities
at the Forefront of our work what does
that look like we are working to make
sure that the costs of the clean energy
transition are that they these
communities are most vulnerable
communities are held harmless
secondly as we transition to EV Vehicles
we have created EV rebates on the hood 7
500 not only for new vehicles but for
used vehicles as well we want to make
sure that our vulnerable oregonians have
access to these Technologies
but the best thing we can do is to make
sure that these communities have access
to a good paying job and so we're also
focused on job training and offering the
types of training in these new clean
green technologies that are good paying
jobs and sustainable one quick example I
will share is the work happening in the
Columbia River Gorge the wind Windy
River area Hood River surfing capital of
the USA there at Columbia Gorge
Community College we're working to
ensure that community members have
access to Electric turbine technology
both building and repairing where the
wind technology is so great with the
opportunity for wind turbines are so
great that all of our community members
will have access to these very good
paying jobs
we absolutely have to Center these
voices at the Forefront of our work and
make sure that we are developing job
training systems connecting community
colleges Career and Technical education
and of course Technical Training uh
we're co-creating we're re-envisioning
reimagining this work together and that
is where we are focused
we have not only a economic imperative
to tackle climate change we have a moral
one and future Generations will judge us
not on the fact of climate change but
what we have done to tackle it the time
is now we must take action and Oregon is
leading the way thank you
thank you very much Governor Brown
Governor ige
thank you uh first I'd like to thank the
climate registry and the climate action
reserve for their incredible work in
helping to make sure that state voices
like all of us here as Governors are
present and heard here at cop26 and the
international venues we really
appreciate the opportunity to state for
States once again to lead in climate
action here at Glasgow
um you know Island communities are on
the front line of climate change we see
the most intense activity uh ever and we
see increasing activity in 2015 I we saw
for the first time in recorded history
three category five hurricanes
surrounding the Hawaiian Islands are
threatening our existence we've had
intense rain bombs in 2018 the most
intense rain bomb ever recorded in the
history of the United States 52 inches
of rain fell in a 24-hour period
devastating Hanalei Valley uh
traditional tarot farms and many of the
livelihoods in that Community we see we
have seen the most severe drought
recorded on our Hawaii County and Maui
County and we see herds of reindeer that
have been coming to forage because they
lack the food in the Forest Reserve
service we see continuing action of what
climate change means in a real way as
President Obama said earlier this
morning Island communities are the
canaries in the coal mines we see the
impacts of climate change in a dramatic
way and we know that we must take action
now
it has been an exciting opportunity for
us in the climate Alliance because we
all share and recognize the climate
emergency that we are seeing we know
that two degrees is not sufficient we
are driving for 1.5 degrees Celsius
uh Hawaii was the first state in the
country to commit to 100 clean renewable
energy in toy electricity in 2015. you
know we didn't know exactly how the
Technologies would play in and
specifically how they would be utilized
but we were clear about where we needed
to go and that was the transition from
fossil fuels to clean renewable energy
we know it's the same as we race to
eliminate emissions we are now committed
we know that Net Zero is not good enough
in 2018 the state of Hawaii committed to
a net negative goal by 2045 or as soon
as practical because we know that zero
is not good enough
as Islands we are directly threatened by
sea level rise rain bombs and coral
bleaching all of those things get even
more intense if we are unable to
maintain a global warming to less than
1.5 degrees
and we are definitely committed to high
impact action to ensure that we never
get there
um we set the goal of
committing our
um we are committed to lead by example
we have set a goal of zeroing out our
emissions from our Auto Fleet we have
Set uh the the criteria of 100 clean
energy sources by 2035
we have committed our state employees to
rent electric vehicles whenever they are
available
uh we have created a rebate to build the
infrastructure for the transition of our
transportation all across the state
we are tackling the hardest part of
Transportation which is uh conversion of
Aviation and Marine transportation we
are preparing for electric planes for
inter-island flights and sustainable
Aviation fuels for longer flights we are
looking at switching our inter-island
shipping to locally sustainable biofuels
hydrogen to power our medium and heavy
duty vehicles and equipment for longer
distance transportation
and while pursuing negative emissions
through our natural and working lands we
do know that investments in our natural
resources give us the best opportunity
to capture more carbon than we admit
when more carbon than we emit we did see
one of the Silver Linings in this
pandemic as all businesses and
organizations went to working from home
we saw how rapidly our air cleared and
our oceans restored a vibrant Coral
communities and we do know that if we
give our nature an opportunity they will
help us more than we ever realized I
committed Hawaii to 100 million trees as
part of the 1 trillion tree initiative
looking to enhance carbon sequestration
all of these actions make Hawaii more
resilient
as an island we have to take a holistic
approach and our community understands
that in order for us to be successful we
have to come together and work together
because in our history we know when we
work together we can do great things
thank you
thank you very much governor ige
governor Inslee
uh thank you first I want is this a joy
to be here for this discussion to be
with my colleagues and I do want to
congratulate them uh Illinois and Hawaii
and Oregon they have tied for second
place in the best climate change program
in the United States I want to
congratulate them for that but on a
serious note this my colleagues here
have done such great work Kate Brown's
work on this Redemption program for cars
fantastic idea David's pre-planning
their business development so we're
going to leave that session there in
another part of the conference Hall in
Glasgow and a focus on the UK for a
moment now clearly a lot of the
conversation here when the focus of
today's conference is resilience and
adaptation a lot of it is focusing on
small island States who are dealing with
very real emergencies right now but um
we wanted to also look about at the UK
as well and see what the impact of
climate change could be here and our
west of England correspondent Dan
Whitehead is on the Isles of silly an
area of the UK which could become
uninhabitable if action isn't taken to
tackle climate change so Dan explain a
bit more about what's been found about
the Arts of silly
yeah well the authorities here on the
Isles of silly were on uh sir Mary's
here the main island on the Isles of
silly say that's the the network of
islands are one of the most at-risk
places to climate change in the UK and
that is primarily because they're very
low lying you've got a population of
around 2 000 spread across five
inhabited Islands but there are actually
a hundred and forty Islands making up
the Isles of silly around 30 miles off
the coast of Cornwall and a big Study
last year found that it used to be just
one land mass less than a thousand years
ago now of course that isn't man-made
climate change over the last thousand
years but what's happening is they're
seeing increasing storm patterns which
is increasing the risk of coastal
flooding in fact back in 2014 I think
we've got some pictures of some of the
floods that took place during a really
bad storm here on the Isles of silly in
fact you can see the waves crashing over
uh the uh town of the Hue town which is
behind me where I am now completely
engulfing it at some points the height
of those waves really something pretty
spectacular but what that is causing is
twofold it's causing land erosion and
we've been here over the last week
speaking to Farmers who've been impacted
they're seeing their land eroded but
also big concerns about infrastructure
here on the island so in Port helich
which is a couple of Bays further up
here on Saint Mary's the lake the
freshwater lake which is the main supply
of the water for Saint Mary's here it's
just meters away from the beach at Port
helic and that is causing concern that
if over tops then it could contaminate
their water supply here on the island so
they are spending millions of pounds on
bolstering defenses sea defenses right
across the islands here in fact this
week they've had people carrying out
surveys to increase those sea defenses
by around a meter not just there in
porthalic but elsewhere across the
islands Farmers as well being impacted
and it's not just through land erosion
but also they have the hottest Mayo
couple of years ago and that ruined
crops for some Farmers we were speaking
to a company that makes essential oils
in their own gin and then simply not
being able to harvest the essential oils
and herbs which they needed this year
and finally worth mentioning the impact
on marine life we've been speaking to
the Isles of silly Wildlife trust who
they who say they're seeing a real
impact on marine life so this is a real
Haven for the gray Atlantic seal and
what they're seeing is that storms are
getting earlier so rather in November
they're happening in September and
October which is during popping season
popping season so seal pups back in 2017
nearly a hundred percent of them were
washed off the beach and they died they
lost a lot of seal pups because they
weren't ready to be taken in by their
mothers into the sea and they've seen
huge declines as well in certain bird
life so there's a real concern what's
been happening here on the Isles of
silly today is that the authorities have
been holding a climate cop 26 climate
change virtual Summit discussing uh what
they can do to tackle the issue and
they've also published their climate
change action plan for public
consultation that's going to go on until
December they do have some pretty lofty
Ambitions in that plan they want to be
at zero carbon by 2030 increase the use
of things like solar power and electric
cars but as well as the mitigation it's
adaptation the big money is going into
sea defenses and they've put in new
barriers new granite barriers as well as
concrete ones sea defenses at strategic
points right across the aisles of silly
to protect the infrastructure to protect
the homes and to protect the businesses
Dan Whitehead thanks very much indeed so
a little bit of a snapshot of how parts
of the UK could be affected in future by
climate change but let's go back to that
session that we were bringing you a
short time ago it's the United States
governor speaking about climate action
and a net zero future
and it is really vaulting our state
ahead it includes becoming the first
midwest state to Target a hundred
percent carbon free energy by 2045 uh
phasing out private call by 2030 and all
call and natural gas by 2045. doubling
our investments in renewable energy and
providing long-term stable financing
making it clear that
um we're open for business in the state
of Illinois for climate friendliness
striving to become the best state in the
nation to drive an electric vehicle
offering uh rebates like the other
states um particularly Governor Brown
talking about her rebates we offer a
four thousand dollar electric vehicle
rebate and up to an 80 percent rebate
for the build out of charging stations
to ensure that we have widespread
availability
we've been incentivizing we created a
bill and passed it only 10 days ago but
it is one of the best incentivizing EV
producers battery manufacturers and
charging companies to build facilities
and to create jobs in the state of
Illinois we have companies like rivien
and Lyon Electric in our state and we
have lots of tier one and tier two
Automotive suppliers to the EV industry
and we invite more supporting uh
Illinois's valuable clean energy
producing nuclear Fleet I see somebody
in the audience promoting it and this is
important
your eyesight hasn't gone wrong that
that's obviously it's something problem
with the feed there to that session so
apologies for that so we're going to
take you to a different session where
hopefully the picture is a little bit
clearer and this is the alliance of
small island States holding a news
conference so let's listen in
um
so I do think that that's now as a as a
somebody outside of government just
thinking that countries should not be
afraid
of being transparent because we mean to
be credible our previous colleague was
talking about carbon club we can't have
any
healthy trade relation if we don't know
what is happening in countries and so in
a way my take is in particular because
that G20 countries in particular the
emerging countries that are very unhappy
because of the not taking enough I think
about of course the
big emitters in the in the G20 on the
developing Countryside that that doesn't
want or would not like to have the same
format of delivery on the on the
emission reduction but in reality their
interest and we just supported the
publication of the very good Italian
Institute on the G20 damage that will be
brought by climate change in the economy
so really frankly I think it's really
negotiating
Innovative it's exactly the office
politics that transmitted to negotiation
countries have an evident interest to be
transparent because that will draw
investment that will draw healthy trade
relation which will if not we will We
may enter into trying conflict and Wars
just because of the distrust of every
country but we need transparency on
finance as well I agree with that
thank you very much minister is there
anything you would like to add or should
we move on to the next question okay um
are there any other questions in the
audience I see two hands there maybe to
the lady first in the third row and then
the lady behind her
thank you very much my name is Amanda
Battersby from Upstream a question to
both or either of the ladies on the
panel please much has been made about
the ndcs that have been announced either
last week or in the run-up to cop but do
you realistically think they have a
chance of delivering what the ministers
have promised thank you
cool
minister
so the thing with the ndcs is that right
now what we're seeing is it's leading up
towards a 2.7 degrees Celsius and that's
something that it's not acceptable for
us my small island developing States
it's a matter of survival for us we
cannot live under 2.7 degrees Celsius
and it's not about only increasing
ambition it's about transparency it's
about accountability it's about making
things happen and I am hopeful and I
think that we can do it
however we need to see action
I will know example of South Africa the
NDC of South Africa which is pretty
ambitious is a result of a long process
of deliberation and discussion with many
many stakeholders and of course Chair by
the president so it is an engagement of
a country
so
what is missing is the one who have not
put updated and improve not updated
improve NDC that's a problem of
Australia and others that are telling
nice things about the Net Zero by 2050
which I happy with but don't don't say
what they will do in the next 10 years
that's why we need next year to close
that yeah of the one who have not
delivered
thank you very much there was a question
behind thank you
thank you Audrey Garrick with lemon the
newspaper it's a question for both are
you confident that we will have a
recognition of the need of a specific
Financial mechanism for loss and damage
in the cover decision and how do you
react of
EU being
reluctant to support such a mechanism
thank you Audrey oh
we must have a decision on lesson
damages we must we really must for us
it's necessary I am sure you've all seen
the news this past year and it's evident
that assistance is needed for us in the
Caribbean we have uh weather events
happening extreme weather events
happening every year they have been
stronger uh more
our hurricane season this year was
unprecedented and we don't have we're
the most indebted region in the country
right now in the second least financed
so we must have
this mechanism operative we must have it
functional and we must have uh rules and
a clear and precise mechanism for this
Finance to to reach the countries that
need it the most
be happy to do that with my colleagues
our previous colleagues that EU has
signed up in the G20 that we can have
new Financial mechanism in particular
with the mobilization of the
reallocation of special drawing rights
exactly for not only follows and damage
and the problem are affected countries
and communities of course as well for
health issues and and the transition but
now I think we of course I can
understand uh you know positioning about
negotiation but one we cannot just have
processes follows and damages that's
over that time is over and second we
have recognized your G20 that we need
financial mechanism for that and that
the countries that is affected it's not
because of the less developed countries
that cannot access to this mechanism so
let's do it let's having now the flow of
the SDR let's open that window for
countries that really are suffering and
Link that that's why I was saying we
have to open the win windows and the
doors of this cup and in the process
because the solution are not only in
there they are on the on the broad range
of financial institutions
thank you very much
um there is a question in the very back
if we could go to that and unfortunately
we have to wrap up in three minutes so
thank you my name is sibi I'm a
journalist from India uh either of you
could answer would you consider the cop
to be be a failure if this decision on
loss and damage doesn't come in the end
and if if you would consider it that way
what kind of so we're going to leave
that session there but do stay with us
here on Sky News climate live we've got
so much coming up for you after this
short break
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello it is week two of the cop 26
climate Summit as negotiations continue
in an attempt to Halt global warming you
are watching a dedicated Channel live
here in the very heart of the conference
this is Sky News climate live
foreign
[Music]
Sky News climate live at cop26 today's
top stories
[Music]
stop falling short President Obama says
there's a long way to go on tackling
climate change and world leaders must
put their own politics aside
we also need China and India leading on
this issue we need Russia leading on
this issue just as we need Indonesia and
South Africa and Brazil leading on this
issue we can't afford anybody on the
sidelines
the race is on the cup President says
pledges must be delivered on as the
summit goes into its second week
UK government pledges 290 million pounds
to support countries dealing with the
impact of planet
and we're in the Isles of silly where
the land could become uninhabitable
without urgent action
the majority of the population lives
here in Hue town but it's also one of
the most vulnerable parts of the Isles
[Music]
very good afternoon and now the pressure
is on here in Glasgow with less than a
week to go until these negotiations wrap
up and the cop president alok Sharma has
insisted that pledges are delivered to
meet the goal of halting global warming
at 1.5 degrees there is a real Buzz in
the room today that is with the arrival
of the former U.S president Barack Obama
who has been holding an event to
encourage protection of the small island
nations being affected by climate change
well it's all a day for looking into
adaptation loss and damage here at cop26
and we're going to be here bringing you
all of the latest news debate and
special guests and Analysis from not
only today but right the way through the
week well let's take a listen to the
former president who was speaking a
short time ago
most Nations have failed to be as
ambitious as they need to be
the escalation the ratcheting up of
ambition that we anticipated in Paris
six years ago
has not been uniformly realized
I have to confess it was particularly
discouraging to see the leaders of two
of the world's largest emitters
China and Russia declined to even attend
the proceedings
and their National plans so far reflect
what appears to be
a dangerous lack of urgency a
willingness to maintain the status quo
on the part of those governments and
that's a shame
we need advanced economies like the U.S
and Europe leading on this issue
but you know the facts we also need
China and India leading on this issue
we need Russia leading on this issue
just as we need Indonesia and South
Africa and Brazil leading on this issue
we can't afford anybody on the sidelines
I recognize we're living in a moment
when International cooperation has waned
a moment of Greater geopolitical tension
and stress in part because of the
pandemic
in part because of the rise of
nationalism and
tribal impulses around the world
and yes in part because of a lack of
leadership on America's part for four
years on a host of multilateral issues
I understand that it's harder to get
International cooperation there are more
Global tensions
but there is one thing that should
transcend our day-to-day politics and
normal geopolitics and that is climate
change
it's not just that we can't afford to go
backward we can't afford to stay where
we are
the world has to step up and it has to
step up now
so how's that going to happen
how do we close the gap between what's
necessary
for our survival and what seems
politically possible right now
I confess
I don't have all the answers
as I'm sure
is true for all of you out there those
of you who are steeped in this work who
are far more expert than me
there are times where I feel discouraged
there are times where the future seems
somewhat bleak
there are times where I am doubtful that
Humanity can get its act together before
it's too late
and and then images of dystopia start
creeping into my dreams
and yet whenever I feel such despondency
I remind myself that cynicism
is the recourse of cowards
we can't afford hopelessness
instead we are going to have to muster
the will and the passion
and the activism of citizens pushing
governments companies and everyone else
to meet this challenge
that's what allowed the U.S to do its
part over the last few years to meet our
climate goals even when we didn't have
much leadership on it
it wasn't just elected officials or CEOs
doing the right thing it was ordinary
Americans
making their voices heard making it
clear we need to solve this problem
regardless of the obstacles people who
organize and educated others in their
communities people who put pressure on
businesses and governments to do better
people who turn their passion into votes
that's the kind of commitment we're
going to need going forward
because let's face it this is not just
about
raw numbers this is not just about
science
this is about politics it's about
culture
it's about morality
it's about the human dynamic
how do we work together to get a big
thing done
and it's about participation
and Power
thinking back on my own experience as
president
I would have had the power to do even
more to fight climate change during my
time in office if I'd had a stable
Congressional majority that was willing
and eager to take action
and for the bulk of my presidency I
didn't have that majority
gaining such majorities require an
Engaged citizenry willing to do what it
takes to reward politicians who take
this problem seriously and send out of
office those who don't
I am convinced that President Biden's
build back better bill will be historic
and a huge
Plus for U.S action on climate change
but keep in mind Joe Biden wanted to do
even more
he's constrained by
the absence of a robust majority that's
needed to make that happen
both both of us have been constrained in
large part by the fact that one of our
two major parties
has decided not only to sit on the
sidelines but Express active hostility
toward climate science
and make climate change a partisan issue
well joining me now in the studio is
Patrick for Cohen chief executive at the
global Center on adaptation Patrick
thank you for joining us all about
adaptation today what have you made of
what you've heard and is it enough well
what I heard today is Samantha is that
we're all living inside the eye of the
storm of the climate emergency all
regions in the world are being impacted
while floods more droughts more storms
more fires but there's one continent in
particularly Africa which is
specifically impacted by the climate
crisis and in fact Africa didn't create
this crisis is suffering the brunt of
his impacts there's a profound moral
Injustice in the global system which has
to be addressed here in Glasgow what
Africa Minister said today for us it's
adapt or die
we hear from one of the youth climate
activists Vanessa McCarty from Uganda
and she talks about the fact that Africa
is a continent is responsible for three
percent of global emissions well so
Africa came here with a plan they have
the largest ever plan on adaptation
Africa adaptation acceleration program
Triple AP a 25 billion dollar program
for Africa is good for the planet is
good for profit it's good for the
economy that's exactly what they expect
here coming out of Glasgow because the
reason Samantha is this investing in
adaptation adjusting to climate shocks
is not only the right thing to do is the
economic smart thing to do why every
dollar pound Euro invested say in
climate smart agriculture has a much
higher return in terms of dividends so
it's simply smart economics African
nation does such we're willing to
prepare to put on the table six billion
a year but what we need is 32 billion so
there's a vast investment gap which
needs to be addressed here in Glasgow
and and just give us an idea of that
money vast sums of money what would it
be spent on what would be the first set
of priorities if what has to be invested
in early warning system drought tolerant
crops resilient infrastructure building
our cities differently it makes economic
sense to do so Africa has the solutions
but it needs the financing now to
deliver not just the scale of financing
but also the quality of financing it
cannot absorb more loans it needs Grand
financing because otherwise the depth
crisis will increase here in Africa and
that's no longer acceptable for these
African nations
we had Finance day in the middle of last
week and there was a big push about
bringing together public and private
money and sort of Blended Finance
Solutions is is that have we come far
enough in the financial sort of toolkit
to get the money to where it needs to
get to
money is Flowing to adaptation Finance
but is it flowing enough no it isn't at
the moment 6 billion a year annually for
example is Flowing to Africa but
compared to the needs of 32 billion is
absolutely inadequate so we need not
only more financing it's very important
what it is it should be grand financing
from the developed world to developed
Nations developing nations and these
developing nations suffer from
inadequate access to that Finance so
there is still a whole battle to fight
for in the coming days because realize
we have to adjust to this climate crisis
because the implications we see today is
in a world of 1.1 degrees warmer we're
going to 1.5 2.53 degrees Celsius vast
part of the global South will be
uninhabitable it's bad for Africa but it
also has massive implications for Europe
itself in security climate migration and
what have you so I think this adaptation
agenda cannot be overstated in terms of
its importance there have been some
pledges on the money side of things
today I'm saying to but but not very
much it doesn't look like anywhere near
enough money well the good thing is the
United Kingdom is the host of the cop 26
presidency they came forward last week
with a significant contribution to
Africa the day they came forward with a
very significant contribution to South
Asia what is now needed is that other
developed Nations step up and deliver on
their promises in 2015 in Paris what
have they said we develop Nations will
deliver a hundred billion a year of
which half would go to adaptation with
far off still so I think there's all to
play for in the coming days when we
build up pressure we see the build of
pressure to develop Nations to come
forward with more significant
announcements do you think there will be
more significant announcement because
we've had Finance day today's adaptation
day what's going to Spur it so when I
see evolving is this sort of buildup of
positive momentum where new commitments
are being put on the table every single
day whether it's on methane whether it's
on Forest whether it's on the mitigation
side of things today adaptation Finance
was front and center we've listened to
Denmark to Sweden to the Netherlands
they're coming forward and what they
said is we will put public use resources
to use what we now need is the private
sector to come in and that's exactly
this sort of new agenda which I think is
very promising we because again it makes
economic sense to invest in meditation
more jobs more security better water
security so I think this is all the
agenda to play for in the coming few
days in the coming few months afterwards
yeah we've been hearing from some of the
heads of the development Banks and it
looks like the new model for financing
is that the development banks will go in
first perhaps and absorb a lot of the
risk and then in doing so we'll attract
private investment off the back of that
is that what you see as the solution and
how long will that take to come in I
think it's vital that the MDB is the
multilateral development Banks Step Up
climate Finance we heard earlier today
that Akin are the senior president of
the African Development Bank said well
we will double climate finance and not
only double climate Finance we will even
double the adaptation component of
climate Finance these are the sort of
commitments we need because at the end
of the day this is a people's agenda
money has to flow where to the front
lines of where people live where they
smallholder Farmers where there's an
informal settlements in urban slums
that's exactly what is needed and it
needed at speed and scale all right well
we'll see what happens about me over the
next few days uh Patrick and thank you
very much for joining us here on Sky
News
now the second week of cop 26 has begun
and countries are being urged to put
loss and damage at the center of those
negotiations the former U.S president
Barack Obama has told the summit that
small island nations are the canaries in
the coal mine of climate change and that
big emitters must do more to help them
well earlier my colleague Anna Jones
spoke to climate Justice activist
Vanessa McCarty and Scotland's first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon about their
thoughts on the progress of this cop
I want leaders to acknowledge that loss
and damage is here with us now
communities from countries like mine in
the global South they're already on the
front lines of the climate crisis there
are things that we can no longer adapt
to we cannot adapt to Extinction we
cannot adapt to starvation we cannot
adapt to our lost cultures or our lost
Traditions or our lost identities so
right now I want the leaders to show us
the money to put a separate fund for
loss and damage because we are facing
the worst of the climate crisis right
now how confident are you that that
money will come a hundred billion
dollars was promised years ago it was
due to be delivered in 2020 last year
and it's still not there are you
confident there will be the commitments
that you want I'm not confident because
like I say that a hundred billion
dollars that was promised by the leaders
including President Obama has not yet
been delivered it has been delayed to
2023 which is unfair to communities that
are on the front lines of the climate
crisis and the most ironic and tragic
thing is that these communities didn't
cause the climate crisis they are not
responsible for the rising greenhouse
gas emissions so it's really
disappointing to see that the
Deliverance the implementation of the
100 billion dollars has not yet been
delivered more and more broken promises
more and more delays and what does this
lead to loss and damage for our
communities and you've spoke
passionately on this spoken passionately
on this subject both inside the
conference and out on the streets as
well so do you feel that you're being
listened to I don't know but I hope that
I'm being listened to and I know that
President Obama is at the cop and we as
young activists especially from the
global South we have been asking him
where is the money that was promised in
2009 I think I was just 13 years old but
now I am 24 and we haven't seen the
Deliverance of that money while our
communities continue to perish and
suffer because of the climate crisis so
we want the presidents we want the
leaders from the global North to show us
the money for loss and damage so do you
think Barack Obama could make a
difference on that
well it depends if he is to give us a
response we held uh we held an action in
the cop this morning we've put out
tweets so if he gives us a response on
the already promised climate Finance
then we will tell whether he can make a
difference Nicola surgeon um welcome to
you how do you feel about this 100
billion dollars I promised so many years
ago still not delivered how crucial is
that money if this Summit is going to be
a success it's shameful that 12 years
old it hasn't been delivered in full and
the money is really important but it's
also become a fundamental issue of trust
between the global South and the global
North and it's a key test of success of
this cup Summit to get to that 100
billion dollars a year not by 2023 but
now because it was meant to be delivered
last year in 2020 but even if that total
is delivered there's no commitment at
all to dedicate any of that money to
loss and damage yes it's important to
mitigate the climate change it's
important to adapt to climate change but
countries like Vanessa's are feeling the
impact right now they're suffering the
loss and damage right now and in many
cases that's loss of life it's loss of
livelihood it's not abstract it's real
Scotland has this week become the first
developed country in the world to commit
resources to loss and damage now
Scotland's a small country so it's a
relatively small sum of money in global
terms one million pounds but it's
intended also to send a message to other
developed countries that we caused
climate change we are responsible for
the impact that countries like Vanessa's
are experiencing right now so this is
not an act of Charity it's an obligation
and a responsibility of reparation that
we owe and I hope other Rich developed
countries step up and recognize that
obligation and I'm sure all money that's
contributed is very welcome but what
about trust in leaders meeting promises
I know that Scotland isn't officially
party to the UN climate convention but
the Scottish government did voluntarily
submit some ndcs that some nationally
determined contribution targets as all
the parties are required to do under
under the Paris agreement which is
laudable but Scotland hasn't met those
targets has it we set ourselves legally
binding annual targets so that we can
measure progress along the way to our 75
reduction Target by 2030 Net Zero by
2045 because they are annual targets
which most countries don't do yes
there'll be some years where we fall
short but let's put it in context we
were hopefully by now we would have
reduced our emissions by 55 we've Fallen
a bit short of that but we've reduced
our emissions by 51.5 so we've
decarbonized faster than any G20 country
and in Scotland we're already halfway to
Net Zero we've got much much more to do
and the bad of what would leadership is
too low it's too easy to be a world
leader but Scotland is leading by
example but do you understand the
frustration then of activists like
Vanessa who come here and they hear
politicians making promises and they
don't meet them well I would argue
Scotland is delivering on its
commitments but we've got to go much
further and much faster it's not an
accident that I'm standing here next to
Vanessa I've made a commitment and
actually it's a bigger commitment on
Vanessa's part for us to catch up during
cop so that I can listen to the voice of
Vanessa and the the many people across
the global South that she represents
because it's right that she challenges
people like me to go further and that
people like me listen and recognize the
massive responsibility that we have I'm
not standing here saying Scotland is
doing everything we should be doing or
as much as we need to do but I think we
are doing more than most we've got to
challenge ourselves to go further and
we've got to do as much as we can to
challenge others to go further too
Vanessa what do you make of the progress
that's been made at cops so far we're
one week in do you feel that things are
going in the right direction
we are getting commitments we are
getting targets but I just want to make
one thing clear commitments do not
reduce emissions targets do not stop
suffering Net Zero promises do not stop
Erasure of our histories or our
Traditions what will stop the suffering
of the people on the front lines what
will reduce emissions from rising will
be real action so until I see real
action until we activate still real
action come out of these commitment that
is when we will believe that we are
moving forward because we have seen in
the past hopes there have been
commitments there have been targets but
the emissions have continued to rise so
commitments won't reduce emissions real
action will reduce emissions so when you
hear about the agreements on reducing
methane Emissions on reducing coal
production and protecting forests are
you encouraged or do you think they're
meaningless until you see action what
what's your take do you think that we're
that that it shows willingness and
commitment I will be encouraged by real
action because for so long leaders have
been promising leaders have been
speaking governments have been putting
net zeros for their countries for their
communities but what will convince me is
real action what will convince me is
saying that reducing emissions not empty
promises but then empty actions
joining me now in the studio is Jim Hall
professor of climate and environmental
risk at Oxford University good to see
you Jim what have you made of what
you've heard today are the Ambitions
going far enough for adaptation
so today's adaptation day and we've
heard a lot about how much Finance
should be going into adaptation how much
assistance should be coming from rich
countries the question I'm asking is
well what should that actually be used
for we need the finance for sure but
adaptation's not easy there are many
different aspects to it there's floods
droughts wildfires heat waves
agricultural impacts impacts on
infrastructure and so actually putting
together the programs and the projects
building the capacity around that to
actually deliver an adaptation we have a
long way to go
from what you're describing I mean is
obviously dependent on where you are
geographically what what those
challenges are but are there are there
easy wins with adaptation are there
things that actually are relatively I
know we're still talking about hundreds
of millions if not billions of of
dollars of money are there things that
are relatively easy to put in place that
we're just already not doing yeah
um there's in particular the things
which don't actually cost you that much
up front of things like land zoning
regulations
which are really crucial to stop the
build up in vulnerability people know
about building in floodplains and they
know that if flood risk is going to get
worse than we should be avoiding doing
that but also think about buildings in
this country there isn't yet a standard
for to avoid overheating in buildings so
you can build a house which is just not
fit for the future temperatures it's
going to face so those kind of quite
straightforward regulatory instruments
and not costing much but they they make
a big difference
you've sort of made reference to it
there what did what did you make of the
Heat and building strategy which was
long awaited from the government
yeah uh great to see it out um I sat on
the committee on climate change for 10
years and we were pushing on this this
question around heating buildings for
for many years so at least we're seeing
some movement now so I'm I'm very
pleased to see that happening and you've
worked in projects and looking at
adaptations that are necessary for the
UK it just talk us through the sort of
work that's that's been going on
so in the UK If we think about climate
risk and adaptation
floods are top of the list both Inland
surface water flooding in cities so from
intense rainfall we saw that in London
over the summer and also the effects of
sea level rise and flooding on the coast
but there also impacts on water scarcity
particularly in the southeast of the
country where there's very high demand
and it's there's relatively less
rainfall we're worried about heat waves
and particularly the effect that might
have on on vulnerable people in Care
Homes and hospitals and we're very
worried about the impacts on the natural
environment on biodiversity that these
are ecosystems which are already under a
lot of pressure the areas available for
them has really been squeezed and yet
they need space if they're going to
adapt to a changing climate
we heard a few times mentioned in some
of the sessions today talk about article
6 and of course a lot of controversy
about carbon markets and their ability
you know effectively to use a market
solution to solve environmental problems
what do you think about that are we
wasting our time talking about carbon
markets do we just need to forget about
it
no I I we should be looking at ways of
using economic incentives and mobilizing
finance to which is needed to support
nature and is needed to to also to
invest in in the amount of nature
restoration of forestation that's going
to be needed so I I think that's needed
but um it's not the the whole story that
what matters is also what exactly
happens on the ground so if we're
talking about restoration exactly
how it's done where it's done how it's
tuned to particular places is really
important then how it's monitored so
that we can actually see that
restoration is achieving what it was set
out to do
there are countries which are really you
know it's it's as the Barbadian prime
minister herself said it is code red for
a lot of countries
um
other places where it's just too late
um so quite a lot of my work relates to
small island States we've been doing a
project in Jamaica under the auspices of
the Coalition for climate resilient
Investments
and that is is looking at where are the
vulnerabilities in the infrastructure
networks in Jamaica so where are they
going to hit get hit worst hardest first
and then that provides the basis for
prioritization for thinking about a more
resilient Island and it is possible to
think about resilient nations in in
Jamaica in this country as well around
the world but we're going to look ahead
and think in a really kind of purposeful
way what does resilience look like and
then what what's the sequence of steps
the pathway we need to go down in in
order to get there
yes that I mean we we can point to the
most vulnerable places the the really
low-lying small Islands yeah and I mean
the uh the uh the issue is that um
adapting to sea level rise in those
places is gonna
um technically it's just very difficult
and and you end up with places which
which don't which are completely
different to where they are at the
moment
um so there are places on Earth where
sea level wise will really threaten the
communities that live there so is it too
late for places like that well with sea
level rise the thing is that
um the sea level rises in some senses
locked in sea level responds really
pretty slowly to the to the heat in the
atmosphere takes a long time for the
ocean to expand when it heats up for ice
caps to melt and so the sea level rise
we're seeing now and Signal Rises is is
getting faster it was two millimeters a
year in the in the 1990s it's four
millimeters a year now and it's getting
faster and that unfortunately is pretty
much locked in for a large part of this
Century what really matters is that we
get we we get to Net Zero in the middle
of this Century so that sea level rise
is not still going up at the end of the
century for future generations to have
to cope with now you're somebody who has
been at the Forefront of the academic
side of environmental science
what's your gut feeling about this
conference is there enough momentum here
to actually make change
yeah and I'm I'm often asked that and
instinctively I think I I I am a an
optimist I hesitate to say that in the
context of of climate change because we
are facing
uh unparalleled challenges this is a
challenge to the likes of which humanity
is is never faced before and we're we're
really struggling
um
and yet I am prepared to see things
which I'm positive about at this
conference and I think we have to be
prepared to be a bit positive about the
the not only the commitments but some of
the the action we're seeing not and not
only at this conference but also uh we
could look at the way in which the the
renewable energy is so cheap now the way
in which the automotive sector is
basically tooling up for electric
vehicles so things are moving in a big
way and I think we we have to support
those positive things whilst being
realistic about the challenges that we
face all right Jim really good to talk
to you thank you for coming to see us
here I'm going to take you now uh to
another room here in the hydro building
and it's an event for the fashion
industry on that race to zero and much
talk there about eliminating waste let's
see what's going on
society exist in harmony with nature
and in that context knowing our industry
knowing how large it is with a turnover
of trillions of dollars millions of
people employed with Supply chains that
are intertwined and very complex and
with thousand different methods being
used to generate and produce fashion and
with fashion being used by basically
everybody on this planet are there to
say almost
it's very clear that fashion has a role
to play and we cannot ignore fashion and
fashion cannot ignore its own role here
our strategy is to bring together change
makers of all kinds to create consensus
and Spark action
we need everybody large and small to
play their parts that means enabling
manufacturers and Brands to make change
it means aligning on goals and on
targets across the global supply chain
and it also means involving stakeholders
outside our sectors governments to help
them enable and Implement policies that
will help us to decarbonize the industry
and consumers to drive demand
we knew this three years ago
today
three years and a pandemic later our
world have changed in ways that we never
thought was possible
yes we have all seen the disaster and
horror movies I believe contagion virus
the Crippen virus the flare virus that
we're running out of ideas for movies
and my favorite my favorite
favorite here the the Mad zombie disease
and for some reason when you make movies
about
pandemics you also
toss in a few zombies there but when the
real thing actually hit us covid-19 when
it started to run over the world closing
down Society all over
the zombies were actually replaced by
some calls the gun touting people were
replaced by medical mosques and the only
shots anybody really cares about are the
one that you take twice
but here is a point the pandemic was not
unpredictable in the last 15 years we
have had at least three instances of
almost pandemics the swine flu the bird
flu and the zika virus and the World
Health Organization told us over and
over again it's not a question of if but
when this is going to happen
you need to be prepared and we were not
prepared
now translate this to climate change
if covid-19 is like a small dinghier
boat that is shooting over the surface
of the oceans between countries and
affecting everything climate change is a
super tanker it's huge it's almost
immovable but for the last hundred years
we have been fueling and pushing this
super tanker forward towards the brink
of disaster
and
this is where we are today
but our Science Now is very very clear
99
with
99.8 certainty we know that the cost of
climate change are us we the humans our
society our way of living and
Manufacturing and wasting things
we know with equal certainty what is
going to happen with our ecosystem if we
don't stop this we know that the
ecosystems that are sustaining our
production system our food system our
health our Global ecology are going to
collapse fairly quickly and we also know
that if we want to avoid this and if we
want to meet the targets of the Paris
agreement
to keep temperature increase
as close as possible to 1.5 degrees
ideally far below 2 degrees then we need
to cut our emission by half in the next
nine years it's not even two digits nine
years 20 30 half emissions and by mid of
this Century we need to achieve a net
zero carbon neutral world
and this is why we have felt in the last
years in the shorter that even it was a
great scene to launch the shelter at
crop 24 and we started out with a number
of principles that we all thought were
quite reasonable we realized that it is
not enough any longer we need to make it
stronger more concrete more ambitious so
for that reason UNIF Triple C together
with all the signatures with the
steering committee and other partners
have had a conversation for the last
several months where we have been
looking at how can we make this shorter
better how can we make this shot really
align with what we know that we need to
achieve
and that is what we're launching today
this new iteration this new incarnation
of the shorter and I want to mention
just a few things I'm not going to read
the whole thing but just a few things
that I think are worth to highlight here
Central to this new iteration was
shorter is a call for companies to set
science-based targets or to halve their
emissions by 2030 with a pledge to
achieve Net Zero missions no later than
2050. this is an update on the previous
pledge which said 30 reduction by 2013.
further commitments and updates are to
include sourcing 100 of electricity from
renewable sources by 2030 sourcing of
environmentally friendly raw materials
and phasing out coal from the supply
chains also by 2030.
and recognizing that most brands have
most of the climate Footprints not at
home but in the supply chains
the charter is also asking all
signatories to create engagement
incentive mechanisms for their suppliers
to also take science-based targets by
2025.
now does this sound easy to anybody here
I don't think it sounds easy I think
it's
tantamount to getting that super tanker
to make a U-turn with skid marks on top
of that
and I would be lying if I said that all
signatories think that this is going to
be an easy Journey on the contrary there
have been a lot of discussion how are we
going to do this I mean we know where
we're going to go but how we're going to
do this and those of you who know me it
knows that I like to talk about moon
landing so I'm going to talk about moon
landings now a little bit so in 1962
when John F Kennedy was making his
famous speech about we're going to put a
man on the moon
they didn't know how to do that they
just knew that they wanted to do that
they some ways they needed to do that
and I'm going to paraphrase his speech
small part of it
but he said we choose to go to the moon
so actually not the moon we choose to
bring the fashion industry Into Climate
neutrality
and to do these other things that are
needed not because it is easy but
because they are hard because that God
will serve to organize and measure the
best of our energies and skills because
that challenge is one that we are
willing to accept and unwilling to
postpone
so
let me again repeat science is clear we
have to do this we do not have a choice
there is nothing like business as usual
yes we think you know there is but if
you look what's happened to our planet
over the last 10 20 30 50 years
there's nothing left of what was when
you and I when we were kids it's
completely different now it's going to
be completely different in a few short
years from now
the United Nations was created of the
two world wars with explicit purpose to
avoid future conflict destruction and
suffering of the two horrible world wars
and yet that is where we are heading
right now
and the United Nation is not as many
people believe the organization of
governments yes the governments
represent us but the U.N Charter doesn't
start with the world's we the
governments it starts with the worlds we
the peoples
so when we are coming together in an
initiative such as the fashion shelter
we are constituting the United Nations
we are giving the life we are doing what
it was set up to do
our fathers our mothers our grandfathers
and grandmothers create the United
Nations to give us a better life right
now on the streets our kids are
demonstrating calling for us to take
action to be ambitious in what we're
doing
and of course this is a call we cannot
ignore
we cannot be the generations that failed
so we have to do that
so let's not be that generation we're
going to come out of that session now
which is all about the fashion industry
and their impact on the environment and
what can be done to reduce those impacts
in that race towards net zero we'll take
you back to it a little later but in the
meantime from heat waves and storms to
floods and droughts in the last year we
have seen extreme weather raid all
across the world and while it's still
not possible to say whether all of these
events are linked to climate change
there is increasing evidence that they
have become more frequent and more
intense as the planet warms up well
joining me now is Kirsty McCabe she's
Sky weather presenter and a member of
the royal Meteorological Society Kirsty
really good to see you here in Glasgow
makes bit of a change isn't it from down
in London
um Talk us through the extreme weather
that we've seen here in the UK I mean in
the UK we've seen such extremes I think
for some people in the south of the
country we felt it wasn't a good summer
but up in Scotland in fact in Southwest
Scotland they had almost drought
conditions they had such a dry hot
summer had just been we've seen
temperatures in the UK reach much higher
values Northern Ireland set temperature
records this year other parts of the UK
were exceptionally how it may not have
been as long and hotter summer as some
we've had in recent years but it was
still signs that we are warming and
there have been studies now saying that
we are likely to hit 40 Celsius in the
UK within the next few years something
that we would never have expected to
happen is
you can't imagine temperatures like that
here and we are not set up for the
infrastructure isn't set up for which
brings me on to the next question which
is today is all about adaptation what
has already been taking place in terms
of being able to to cope with these
different weather patterns around the
country well we're a little bit um
behind the curve when it comes to
adaptation we've got to very quickly
catch up and we knew our scientists at
least knew 20 30 years ago and warned of
what was happening and only now and it's
great that we're doing it now but we've
got a lot of growing to make up so in
terms of adaptation we're having to
improve flood defenses much more rapidly
and when it comes to heat waves we need
buildings that can cope with the Heat
and the cool because we will still have
colder interludes known again transport
is going to be an issue in terms of
rails buckling in the Heat or in terms
of flooding so there's so many areas are
being looked at but we've it's almost
like trying to spin plates right now
we've got so many areas of concern yeah
and I suppose getting ready for 40
degree heat that's is going to be quite
a challenge isn't it and what about I
mean those are the big infrastructure
projects what about on more of a micro
level in terms of what you know
individuals can do with their houses
what small you know small small farm
farm owners can do as well I think um on
an individual level we can all do
something although we need the big
parties we need the governments and we
need the companies to step up and really
make a Mark at home you can just do
simple things like switching off a light
switch and really small things at home
can actually all help and make a
difference and what I found here is I've
been speaking to people within Glasgow
and a lot of them maybe aren't that
fussed about climate change and don't
see it affecting them and when you chat
to them and explain it they do agree
yeah when it has changed actually now
you come to mention it and then we do
all think actually maybe I can do
something and it is going to be some of
the little things will all add up and
hopefully have an effect so managing
business is better managing if you are
in a small farm just taking a look at
how you can maybe work in a more a
better way that not only maybe saves
money hopefully but also is better for
the planet it's just taking all the
advice on board and there's been lots of
events here trying to encourage that to
happen and I think there's been a huge
response I think there's been a lot of
promises made over the last week or so
but what you need though in order to get
individual households to to make
decisions that impact the way they live
that cost them money is to have very
clear government policy do you think
it's been cleared it's not been as clear
as it could be it's definitely heading
in the right way and I think in the UK
compared to some other countries we are
doing quite well we have all pretty much
got on board with the climate message no
we we agree climate change is happening
we agree it's getting warmer and we
agree it's a lot more unsettled I think
in the UK in terms of yes it might be
warmer which on the one hand doesn't
sound too bad but if that comes with
extreme storms and flooding and also the
health risks of heatwise we know that's
not good so I think we're all getting on
board with climate message and yes if we
did have clear directors from the
government that probably would help with
many things the other thing that helps
and we were hearing a bit about it from
Nadine zahari the new education
secretary of state is about get
improving climate education at in
schools absolutely and that's one of the
key things and as well as working at Sky
I also work for the Royal Meteorological
Society and we are passionate about
climate education and I've been
producing little videos here from copper
for the general public but I've got a
colleague who's the head of education
and Dr Sylvia Knight and she's been
producing videos that schools can use in
the morning to explain to the children
what's happening at Corp and some of the
themes and things behind it but it's not
just focused on schools we want climate
education to go all the way through life
because no matter what job you have in
the future it is going to be a part of
it we're all going to have to have much
Greener jobs and so educating everybody
including especially including
government and politicians we need to be
aware and it's such an important thing
and I'm really passionate about it and I
think I'm lucky because I've got the
meteorology and the weather presenting
side of it so I can help communicate the
climate risks so I'm hopefully able to
take that message and spread and keep
the climate education going and if you
want to see what we've been up to of
course there's the RMS the Royal
Meteorological Society website and
YouTube channel just to keep the message
going about climate change and just the
more you know about it the more you can
help with it all right Kirsty really
good to talk to you here in Glasgow
thank you very much for coming to look
us up
now coming up on Sky News climate live
we're going to bring you plenty more
coverage of what is happening here on
day one week two of cop26 here in
Glasgow
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back now earlier today the cop
26 president alok Sharma said the
country's must deliver on commitments
that have been made in the past week
let's have a listen
there needs to be a sense of urgency in
all our negotiations the science is
clear we have no time to lose and I will
ensure that negotiations proceed in a
timely manner whilst of course ensuring
transparency and inclusivity
last week countries made commitments
which will all help to protect our
planet but they must be delivered on and
accounted for
today on adaptation and loss and damage
day the spotlight will be on those
Nations and communities which are most
vulnerable to climate change those whose
voices are too often left unheard
and we know that even if we stopped
polluting our world tomorrow there will
be negative consequences for many
millions and that is why issues such as
adaptation are so important now I'm
pleased to see progress on these topics
today and particularly welcome the
commitments to the adaptation fund which
will be made in the next few hours
including from the UK to support
vulnerable communities to respond to
climate change
developed countries and development
Banks recognize they need to increase
levels of Finance or adaptation and I
hope we will be able to capture this
renewed commitment in the cop 26
negotiated outcome
those of you who have followed this
process will know that loss and damage
has historically been seen as a
polarizing issue
but I'm encouraged that the mood music
has changed somewhat and there is now a
practical recognition that action is
needed on this topic in the face of
growing impacts
the conclusion of discussions within the
subsidiary bodies on the Santiago
network is a testament to that and paved
the way for greater resources to avert
minimize and address loss and damage
climate vulnerable communities are
particularly at the Forefront of my mind
and will be so throughout these
negotiations they and the generations to
come will not forgive us if we fail to
deliver in Glasgow
well we're going to take you to another
session that's taking place now
happening in the atrium here in Glasgow
it's an event called building a climate
resilient future and we can take you
there now
another I find in school the other high
school bus then we now have still got
hitchhike no more because we have us
going to dang we have with this City
Community or Village so that is lack of
improvement for us it's a real
opportunity that we make inclusive
climate adaptation and economic
development a reality and not just words
this is vitally important for small
Nations such as police and it is a
responsibility that we ensure that we
continue to boost our resilience to
climate change
foreign
[Music]
you're the money man
so some of those adaptations were kind
of relatively uh cheap and expensive
straightforward and some were like
Rotterdam hugely expensive and complex
and the public sector whether it's the
government or the public communities
can't afford to build up climate
resilient future uh alone so how do we
mobilize private Finance to to drive
adaptation
sure thanks here I think before I go to
private sector I wouldn't emphasize that
the video we saw is looking at
adaptation of the road but what's
important is to recognize is just not
the asset that we are trying to protect
it's more the services that the asset
will help create so by protecting the
road in this case it might allow the
children to go to the school or the
families to access the health care or
agriculture producer is the market now
if you think from that perspective then
of course it becomes very critical to
involve the private sector and also
mobilize resources from the private
sector but for do for doing that I think
the critical thing is to improve the
enabling environment which will
facilitate the projects to come in and
put in additional resources and I think
from my perspective three things is
required to improve the enabling
environments number one is to make
available risk information to everybody
so a private sector knows what is at
risk where is the risk how much the risk
costs and accordingly they can decide
where to invest and where not to invest
so um in this case for example if you're
involving a public-private partnership
in the road projects if the private
sector knows how much maintenance costs
will increase because of every year
there will be increased rainfall then
they could factor that in in their
contract itself similarly we talked
looked at the video short about these
technology of slow protection which
could be a new kind of opportunity for
the Privacy to come in and explore new
kind of market for new technology so I
think understanding of risk is the first
most important Point second is uh
talking also building on what Emma and
Anand talked about
co-creating the vision of outcome so
what would resilience investing in
resilience look like for the private
sector how will it help my business plan
how will it help my ESR ratings it's
important to co-create the vision of
outcomes and third but not least is to
improve the policy and incentive
mechanisms for the private sex to come
in so for example there could be need at
times we need to provide concessional
resources specifically in talking about
small and medium Enterprises or micro
Enterprises which is a lot in in in most
developing countries and equally looking
at some tax benefits sometimes perhaps
or other kind of Blended Finance
mechanisms so for me understanding risk
you know improving the policy and
incentives and co-creating the vision
for the outcome is absolutely critical
to mobilize resources from private
sector we're going to hear that word
Cool Creation quite a lot quite rightly
and and it's interesting you you talked
you were really talking about both
systemic risk but systemic opportunities
on the flip side of that and we'll
definitely pick that up again but for
the moment we're going to go on our
final stop and we're going to uh go off
to uh Nepal to the highest mountains in
the world and and crucially a place
where uh for what you do when you you
can't plan for adaptation so here we go
let's hear Nepal
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
this video presents Nepal's efforts and
successes in implementing adaptation
actions to cope with the impacts of
climate change
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
well it is week two of the cop 26
climate Summit as negotiations continue
in an attempt to Halt global warming
you are watching a dedicated Channel
live here in the heart of the conference
this is Sky News climate live
[Music]
you're watching Sky News climate live
here at cop26 today's top stories
stop falling short President Obama says
there is a long way to go on tackling
climate change and world leaders must
put their own politics aside
we also need China and India leading on
this issue we need Russia leading on
this issue just as we need Indonesia and
South Africa and Brazil leading on this
issue we can't afford anybody on the
sidelines
the race is on the cup President says
pledges must be delivered as the summit
goes into its second week
[Music]
the UK government pledges 290 million
pounds to support countries dealing with
the impact of climate change
[Music]
very good afternoon to you now the
pressure is on here in Glasgow with less
than a week to go until these
negotiations wrap up and the cop 26
president alok Sharma has insisted that
pledges are delivered to meet the goal
of halting global warming at 1.5 degrees
there's a real Buzz in the room that's
with the arrival of the former U.S
president Barack Obama who has been
holding an event to encourage protection
of the small island nations that are
being affected by climate change well
it's all for a day looking into
adaptation loss and damage here at cop26
and we'll be here bringing you all of
the latest developments debate and
special guests and Analysis from not
only today but right the way through the
week so let's take a listen to the
former president who was speaking
earlier this afternoon
most Nations have failed to be as
ambitious as they need to be
the escalation the rapturing up of
ambition that we anticipated in Paris
six years ago
has not been uniformly realized
I have to confess it was particularly
discouraging to see the leaders of two
of the world's largest emitters
China and Russia declined to even attend
the proceedings
and their National plans so far reflect
what appears to be
a dangerous lack of urgency a
willingness to maintain the status quo
on the part of those governments and
that's a shame
we need advanced economies like the U.S
and Europe leading on this issue
but you know the facts we also need
China and India leading on this issue
we need Russia leading on this issue
just as we need Indonesia in South
Africa and Brazil leading on this issue
we can't afford anybody on the sidelines
I recognize we're living in a moment
when International cooperation has waned
a moment of Greater geopolitical tension
and stress in part because of the
pandemic
in part because of the rise of
nationalism and
tribal impulses around the world
and yes in part because of a lack of
leadership on America's part for four
years on a host of multilateral issues
I understand that it's harder to get
International cooperation there are more
Global tensions
but there is one thing that should
transcend our day-to-day politics and
normal geopolitics and that is climate
change
it's not just that we can't afford to go
backward we can't afford to stay where
we are
the world has to step up and it has to
step up now
so how's that going to happen
how do we close the gap between what's
necessary
for our survival and what seems
politically possible right now
I confess
I don't have all the answers
as I'm sure
is true for all of you out there those
of you who are steeped in this work who
are far more expert than me
there are times where I feel discouraged
there are times where the future seems
somewhat bleak
there are times where I am doubtful that
Humanity can get its act together before
it's too late
and and then images of dystopia start
creeping into my dreams
and yet whenever I feel such despondency
I remind myself that cynicism
is the recourse of cowards
we can't afford hopelessness
instead we are going to have to muster
the will and the passion
and the activism of citizens pushing
governments companies and everyone else
to meet this challenge
that's what allowed the U.S to do its
part over the last few years to meet our
climate goals even when we didn't have
much leadership on it
it wasn't just elected officials or CEOs
doing the right thing it was ordinary
Americans
making their voices heard making it
clear we need to solve this problem
regardless of the obstacles people who
organize and educated others in their
communities people who put pressure on
businesses and governments to do better
people who turn their passion into votes
that's the kind of commitment we're
going to need going forward
because let's face it this is not just
about
raw numbers this is not just about
science
this is about politics it's about
culture
it's about morality
it's about the human dynamic
how do we work together to get a big
thing done
and it's about participation
and Power
thinking back on my own experience as
president
I would have had the power to do even
more to fight climate change during my
time in office if I'd had a stable
Congressional majority that was willing
and eager to take action
and for the bulk of my presidency I
didn't have that majority
gaining such majorities require an
Engaged citizenry willing to do what it
takes to reward politicians who take
this problem seriously and send out of
office those who don't
I am convinced that President Biden's
build back better bill will be historic
and a huge
Plus for U.S action on climate change
but keep in mind Joe Biden wanted to do
even more
he's constrained by
the absence of a robust majority that's
needed to make that happen
both both of us have been constrained in
large part by the fact that one of our
two major parties
has decided not only to sit on the
sidelines but Express active hostility
toward climate science
and make climate change a partisan issue
well of course adaptation is one of the
big focuses of today with ministers and
leaders looking at how they can help
developing countries become more
resilient to our changing climate so
what does adaptation look like well here
to explain more is Miko olakainan head
of the adaptation fund good to see you
this afternoon Miko this day is all
about adaptation do you feel that within
the overall conference within the the
focus of world leaders the adaptation
has been taken seriously enough I do
think so and thank you for having me
here
I've been following these conferences
for more than 10 years now and I've
never seen such an in a focus on
adaptation and it's long overdue as we
see from the reports from the
intergovernmental panel of climate
change the impacts of climate change
around the world are increasing and that
increases the need for adaptation so
it's very important that the UK cup
presidency has put such a lot of effort
and focus on on the topic of adaptation
you're satisfied with the fact that it
is front and center of people's minds
um tell us a bit more about the
adaptation fund you've got a lot of
different projects going on as part of
that that's right well we've been
working for about 14 years now with
developing countries we're one of the
first funds internationally to fund
adaptation to climate change way before
it became popular and it it is a very
important topic for developing countries
we have been funding about 120 projects
around the world a total portfolio of
almost 900 million dollars and we really
see the need of developing countries in
different sectors to to get support to
adapt to the impacts of climate
resilience interesting I hear that
you're saying it's all over the world
but do you have a particular Focus where
do you think needs the most urgent
support is it Africa or is it island
nations
uh the the most vulnerable countries
probably have the the least capacity to
that after the impact of climate change
but let's say in all developing
countries are vulnerable uh the the
needs for adaptation Finance are several
times more than the available Finance
worldwide so so I would not single out
any country or group of countries but
but adaptation is very different in
different parts of the world and it
requires really a diverse set of
approaches that we applied and the
funding that goes into those projects
where does it come from originally
uh in fact the adaptation fund was
originally set up to be funded by an
international tax which was something
very Innovative tax on the climate
mitigation projects now unfortunately in
2011
the global carbon Market crashed and
since that we've relied on other sources
and that's been based basically uh
contributions voluntary contributions by
by developed country governments we have
about 20 developing countries just two
new governments announced their support
today and uh and and we are
increasing the the amount of work that
we do on the ground how long do you
think it's sustainable to rely on
voluntary contributions
uh I would say it's definitely not
sustainable and and that has been shown
by some of the independent evaluations
of the of the adaptation fund we've been
doing great work that's what we
uh independent evaluator say the problem
is that we don't have a sustainable
source of funding to support developing
countries in doing that and that's
that's one of the main challenges and
just in terms of making it real for our
viewers where you have had a big project
talk us through what you've done and
what the impact of it has been
adaptation is really really diverse so
it depends on whether we are talking
about coastlines that are being
submerged by rising sea levels
agriculture that's suffering from
droughts or floods or or cities one that
you're particularly proud of
I'm particularly proud of our first
project which is in Senegal and it's one
of the projects where the Senegalese
government took a lot of ownership in in
developing a project that focuses on the
coastline not far from Dakar the IT
addresses agriculture tourism and other
livelihoods and it based was based on a
strong partnership
with with local communities including
women's groups which is very important
in adaptation and that project was able
to protect some of the shoreline and
develop models that can be replicated
and have been replicated by other
funders which is which is how it should
be we test new approaches to adapt to
climate change and then we can mobilize
the the larger resources to uh to do
that and it's a question I'm asking
pretty much everybody I'm talking to
about your
your gut feeling about how successful
this conference has been
well it's too early to say
um I I've seen cops that looked very
good in the beginning and turned out not
so good in the end and vice versa I'm
I'm of course hopeful I'm eternally an
optimist and and I think that the
science that we see that the UK
government
has been taking these things very
seriously and and is doing the right
things in under these difficult
circumstances of the of the pandemic
that we are still going through so I I
have my hopes high up uh for for this uh
conference all right well really
interesting to talk to you thank you
very much for coming to see us here at
Sky News
now the Isles of silly have been picked
out by climate scientists as part of the
UK which could become uninhabitable if
action isn't taken to tackle climate
change well we can speak now to Dan
Whitehead who's in The isles of silly
forests uh tell us more Dan
yeah the council here on the Arts of
silly says it is one of the most at-risk
places in the UK when it comes to
climate change and that primarily is
because it is a network of very low
lying Islands five inhabited Islands
here we're on the main one Saint Mary's
but he's made up of 140 islands around
28 miles off the coast of Cornwall
what's been happening today here on the
Isles is a major cop 26 climate change
Summit because the council has published
it's climate change action plan for
public consultation essentially seeking
the opinions of the 2 000 people the
2000 residents here on the Arts of silly
of what they think they should do to
adapt and mitigate the problems of
climate change on This Island community
as I said the biggest issue is because
they are low lying but there are some
real threats and immediate threats that
climate change is causing here on the
Isles of City one of the big problems is
the fear of contamination of the water
supply here so we were filming at porth
hellick just up the further up the
island here where the freshwater lake
the only Lake which provides the Water
Source here for the Isles of silly it's
just meters away from the sea and
they're spending millions of pounds
they've been doing survey work this week
to increase the height of the sea
defenses there in terms of the
adaptation to prevent the sea over
topping and contaminating that water
source we've been speaking to Farmers on
Saint Agnes one of the smaller populated
Islands a population of just 80 there
and it's not just coastal flooding and
erosion that's concerning them the
farmers there are worried about the
changes in seasons and temperatures they
had an extremely hot summer and it's
ruins ruined some of their crops for the
essential oils and even gin which they
make there so it's making life difficult
for them there's also a wildlife impact
as well the hours of silly Wildlife
trust saying they're really starting to
see an impact on some of their work when
it comes to climate change seal pups
there's a lot of gray Atlantic seals on
some of the more remote Islands here and
in 2017 after a storm the storm what
they're noticing is the storms are
getting earlier so rather than November
they're happening at the end of
September October and back in 2017 there
was a really ferocious storm that washed
nearly a hundred percent of the seal
pups during popping season off the beach
too soon they weren't ready to be taken
out by their mothers to start to learn
swimming and they all died so that's one
issue which they're seeing as well as a
decline in certain bird populations you
can really sort of see where we are in
Hue town here if we look back if back at
some images from storms which took place
in 2014 Valentine's Day then there was a
huge storm and you can see from the
images huge waves and actually a storm
crashing over the whole of hue town
which is the main town here on the Isles
of silly just 130 meters wide and it's
essentially built on a sandbar and as
you can see behind me during High Tides
the water comes right up to the houses
the buildings and the properties so
coastal flooding ongoing erosion and
changes in weather patterns are really
causing a concern so what the eyes of
silly is doing and what it is suggesting
in its big climate change action and
plan which it has published today he
wants to be carbon Zero by 2030 he wants
to see adaptations like more electric
cars solar panels and so forth but it is
um sorry that's its mitigation but its
adaptation really is the millions of
pounds which it is spending on sea
defenses in these crucial areas it is
building up the defenses where there are
homes where there's infrastructure roads
water supply because they know and they
have said that if they don't take action
in 2030 or 100 years they may start to
see some of the islands become
uninhabitable and in the words of the
counselor they may have to evacuate some
islands if they don't start to take
action
now certainly looks beautiful behind you
this evening Dan thank you
now the second week of cop26 has begun
countries are being urged to put loss
and damage at the center of those
negotiations the former U.S president
Barack Obama has told the summit that
small island nations are the canaries in
the coal mine of climate change and that
the big emitters must do more to help
them well earlier my colleague Anna
Jones spoke to the climate Justice
activist Vanessa McCarty and Scotland's
first Minister Nicholas sturgeon about
their thoughts on the progress so far of
this call
I want leaders to acknowledge that loss
and damage is here with us now
communities from countries like mine in
the global South they're already on the
front lines of the climate crisis there
are things that we can no longer adapt
to we cannot adapt to Extinction we
cannot adapt to starvation we cannot
adapt to our lost cultures or our lost
Traditions or our lost identities so
right now I want the leaders to show us
the money to put a separate fund for
loss and damage because we are facing
the worst of the climate crisis right
now how confident are you that that
money will come a hundred billion
dollars was promised years ago it was
due to be delivered in 2020 last year
and it's still not there are you
confident there will be the commitments
that you want I'm not confident because
like you say that a hundred billion
dollars that was promised by the leaders
including President Obama has not yet
been delivered it has been delayed to
2023 which is unfair to communities that
are on the front lines of the climate
crisis and the most ironic and tragic
thing is that these communities didn't
cause the climate crisis they are not
responsible for the rising greenhouse
gas emissions so it's really
disappointing to see that the
Deliverance the implementation of the
100 billion dollars has not yet been
delivered more and more broken promises
more and more delays and what does this
lead to loss and damage for our
communities and you've spoke
passionately on this spoken passionately
on this subject both inside the
conference and out on the streets as
well so do you feel that you're being
listened to I don't know but I hope that
I'm being listened to and I know that
President Obama is at the cop and we as
young activists especially from the
global South we have been asking him
where is the money that was promised in
2009 I think I was just 13 years old but
now I am 24 and we haven't seen the
Deliverance of that money while our
communities continue to perish and
suffer because of the climate crisis so
we want the presidents we want the
leaders from the global North to show us
the money for loss and damage so do you
think Barack Obama could make a
difference on that
well it depends if he is to give us a
response we held uh we held an action in
the cop this morning we've put out
tweets so if he gives us a response on
the already promised climate Finance
then we will tell whether he can make a
difference Nicola surgeon um welcome to
you how
do you feel about this 100 billion
dollars I promised so many years ago
still not delivered how crucial is that
money if this Summit is going to be a
success it's shameful that 12 years old
it hasn't been delivered in full and the
money is really important but it's also
become a fundamental issue of trust
between the global South and the global
North and it's a key test of success of
this cup Summit to get to that 100
billion dollars a year not by 2023 but
now because it was meant to be delivered
last year in 2020 but even if that total
is delivered there's no commitment at
all to dedicate any of that money to
loss and damage yes it's important to
mitigate the climate change it's
important to adapt to climate change but
countries like Vanessa's are feeling the
impact right now they're suffering the
loss and damage right now and in many
cases that's loss of life it's loss of
livelihood it's not abstract it's real
Scotland has this week become the first
developed country in the world to commit
resources to us in damage now Scotland's
a small country so it's a relatively
small sum of money in global terms one
million pounds but it's intended also to
send a message to other developed
countries that we caused climate change
we are responsible for the impact that
countries like Vanessa's are
experiencing right now so this is not an
act of Charity it's an obligation and a
responsibility of reparation that we owe
and I hope other Rich developed
countries step up and recognize that
obligation and I'm sure all money that's
contributed is very welcome but what
about trust in leaders meeting promises
I know that Scotland isn't officially
party to the U.N climate convention but
the Scottish government did voluntarily
submit some ndcs that some nationally
determined contribution targets
um as all the parties are required to do
under under the Paris agreement which is
laudable but Scotland hasn't met those
targets has it we set ourselves legally
binding annual targets so that we can
measure progress along the way to our 75
reduction Target by 2030 Net Zero by
2045 because they are annual targets
which most countries don't do yes
there'll be some years where we fall
short but let's put it in context we
were hopefully by now we would have
reduced our emissions by 55 we've Fallen
a bit short of that but we've reduced
our emissions by 51.5 so we've
decarbonized faster than any G20 country
and in Scotland we're already halfway to
Net Zero we've got much much more to do
and the bad of what would leadership is
too low it's too easy to be a world
leader but Scotland is leading by the
example but do you understand the
frustration then of activists like
Vanessa who come here and they hear
politicians making promises and they
don't meet them well I would argue
Scotland is delivering on its
commitments but we've got to go much
further and much faster it's not an
accident that I'm standing here next to
Vanessa I've made a commitment and
actually it's a bigger commitment on
Vanessa's part for us to catch up during
pop so that I can listen to the voice of
Vanessa and the the many people across
the global South that she represents
because it's right that she challenges
people like me to go further and that
people like me listen and recognize the
massive responsibility that we have I'm
not standing here saying Scotland is
doing everything we should be doing or
as much as we need to do but I think we
are doing more than most we've got to
challenge ourselves to go further and
we've got to do as much as we can to
challenge others to go further too
Vanessa what do you make of the progress
that's been made at cops so far we're
one week in do you feel that things are
going in the right direction
we are getting commitments we are
getting targets but I just want to make
one thing clear commitments do not
reduce emissions targets do not stop
suffering Net Zero promises do not stop
Erasure of our histories or our
Traditions what will stop the suffering
of the people on the front lines what
will reduce emissions from rising will
be real action so until I see real
action until we activate still real
action come out of these commitment that
is when we will believe that we are
moving forward because we have seen in
the past hopes there have been
commitments there have been targets but
the emissions have continued to rise so
commitments won't reduce emissions real
action will reduce emissions so when you
hear about the agreements on reducing
methane Emissions on reducing coal
production and protecting forests are
you encouraged or do you think they're
meaningless until you see action what
what's your take do you think that we're
that that it shows willingness and
commitment I will be encouraged by real
action because for so long leaders have
been promising leaders have been
speaking governments have been putting
net zeros for their countries for their
communities but what will convince me is
real action what will convince me is
saying that reducing emissions not empty
promises but then empty actions
foreign
coming up on a Sky News climate live
we're going to be bringing you plenty
more coverage and Analysis to everything
that we've been hearing today and indeed
from the start of this conference last
week so do stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well it has been a very busy start to
the second week of cop26 here in Glasgow
inside the SEC let's take a look at some
of the key developments of the summit so
far well on Monday India the world's
third largest emitter put a date on
reaching Net Zero 2070 and Prime
Minister Modi promised that his country
very significantly would get half of its
energy from renewable sources by the end
of this decade Tuesday then saw more
than a hundred countries representing 85
percent of the world's forests signed up
to end deforestation by 2030. more than
100 Nations also promised methane
emission cuts by at least 30 percent by
the end of the decade well then
Wednesday that was the big money day and
financial institutions announced 130
trillion dollars in assets would be
available to invest in that push to Net
Zero then on Friday more more than 40
countries committed to phase out coal
the dirtiest fossil fuel around well the
biggest coal dependent countries some of
which including the US Australia and
China didn't sign up to that pledge and
45 countries pledged a shift to
sustainable farming methods that was
during nature day on Saturday
well here to analyze the summit so far
is Michael Jacobs professorial research
fellow at the Sheffield political
economy Research Institute at the
University of Sheffield Michael good to
see you I know that you've been
following all the the ins and outs the
twists and turns of what's been taking
place here at cop26 the newspaper
coverage at the weekend wasn't all that
favorable about what's been achieved
what do you think I think it was
inevitable that the weekend newspapers
would be looking for things that they
could pick holes in as you said there
are all these announcements during last
week it was a rather cleverly
choreographed week by the British hosts
of the cop the presidency getting these
individual announcements about different
issues Forest methane energy Finance as
you've said and by the weekend people
were looking to see if they were really
quite as good as the British and others
were cynical bumps and that's your job
and it did prove that some of them were
not quite as good as might have been
thought so for example as you said the
call announcement phasing out cold there
were a few countries that don't actually
have any coal and there were the biggest
coal users as you said China the US
Australia which didn't join it a lot of
people were very suspicious of some of
these business announcements a massive
amount of money apparently going towards
green technologies and in the
announcements made by Mark Carney on the
Wednesday and it turned out that
actually at least some of that money was
going to green things and many of the
banks and Pension funds that were saying
they were going green were in fact
continuing to fund fossil fuels so as
always the day after the budget is
always the day when we really find out
what's happened and it's unsurprising I
think that the day after these
announcements a few holes have been
found in them but I think many people
were still broadly speaking encouraged
by what was said last week yeah you have
to get under the Bonnet don't you once
you've got all these announcements now
with the Paris Summit it was really a
very last minute a Midnight Hour almost
wasn't it movement there to get that aim
of the 1.5 degree limit and that was
really pushed onto the agenda and fought
for by a lot of the island nations I'm
just wondering whether we might get
something like that again I think it's
very likely this is a very unusual
international meeting the cop because
decisions are made by consensus which
means that every country has to agree
and there are very large numbers of very
poor countries and many of them are
climate vulnerable and the island states
are the most vulnerable some of them
won't exist if sea levels rise as the
scientists predict they are so low lying
that climate change represents to them
an existential threat and so at these
important Corps in effect they have a
kind of veto in Paris these small island
States said we simply will not sign an
agreement unless you the big countries
the rich countries the emitters commit
to holding global warming to one and a
half degrees if possible and for example
to acknowledging that there is loss and
damage that they are experiencing now
not sometime in the future which has to
be recognized and I think they will
insist on this again and they have that
power in these kinds of gatherings in a
way they don't in most International
multilateral processes there was one bit
of analysis that I read that I thought
was very interesting it was talking
about really that the important almost
behind the scenes influence of Saudi
Arabia with all of this is talk about
there being more fossil fuel delegates
here than for any other countries team
of team of negotiators
influential is a country like Saudi
Arabia of course you know one of the
world's biggest suppliers of oil Saudi
Arabia is very influential it is very
powerful in one of the blocks here the
negotiation is all done in blocks of
countries and Saudi Arabia always plays
a very prominent role by and large it
has to be said to slow down the progress
on acting on climate change it's always
seen itself as threatened by action on
climate change because it is an oil a
big oil producer more recently it said
some better things it's also got a net
zero pledge but in the negotiations it
still acts to slow things down and
whereas last week all the leaders seem
to be saying the same thing we're all
terribly concerned and we're all acting
in this week when the negotiations get
going you see the difference between the
small island States who want stronger
action and countries like Saudi Arabia
which want less this lovely uh figure
that was produced today by one of the
non-governmental organizations here
noting that the oil and gas sector not
the countries the oil and gas sector has
more lobbyists at the cop than any
country has in its own delegation
read into that do you think you can read
that they're worried the fossil fuel
sector are the baddies in climate change
there's no two ways about it it's fossil
fuels that have largely caused the
problem of climate change and the
producers and the companies want to
carry on producing oil and gas for as
long as they can and so they are
lobbying here to weaken things they make
good statements about wanting to go Net
Zero themselves and some of them may be
serious but they don't want to see
faster action and so it isn't I'm afraid
surprising that they have such big
lobbying delegations here they're not of
course in the actual negotiations only
countries and the EU can negotiate but
this conference as you've seen is much
more than just a negotiation there are
thousands and thousands of people here
who are selling their Wares networking
presenting their point of view and the
oil and gas sector are still a very
powerful force in that yeah indeed I
mean they're appearing before Congress
aren't there to talk about the amount of
money that they've been spending on
spreading false messaging through social
media so that we know that they are the
tobacco companies of our time the
tobacco companies as we know new that
tobacco cause cancer very early on this
information wasn't it in the 50s and
repressed it and also cause cause
confusion a lot of what's happened in
the last few years isn't so much
outright denial as so in confusion about
what is actually the cause of climate
change and we know that a lot of money
not all of it above board has gone into
the climate denial World from the oil
companies so people are very suspicious
of their behavior but what's interesting
is that there are so many other voices
which are exposing that which are
arguing against it you know we have this
amazing Ted Talk in which the chief
executive of shell was on a panel with
one of the young climate activists and
she she asked him a direct question will
you stop the case which shell is taking
against the Netherlands uh on on court
on uh calling out the energy companies
as the cause of climate change and he
said no and she ripped off a mic and
walked out which of course has had
hundreds of thousands of views uh on
YouTube and there is a counter there is
a to wait now to the oil and gas
companies they don't get their own way
the other thing I'm interested to get
your perspective on is we had former
president Obama today making several
addresses and when he talks people
listen don't they and I'm just wondering
whether actually hearing from him about
the United States talking about how the
four years under his successor were an
absolute disaster but whether we're
hearing more and more compelling
language and Call to Arms in a way from
former president Obama than we are from
the current President Joe Biden as you
had before with former vice president Al
Gore who became a a great voice for
climate activism after he left office
it's obviously easier for an
ex-president or ex-vice president than
when you're serving the fact is that
under Joe Biden the US is trying to do
much more than it has ever done before
including I have to say under Obama we
hope
that because he has not quite control of
Congress but at least in theory he would
get a majority through the Senate which
Obama never could that he will get his
legislation through Congress we will see
the money flowing but any President of
the U.S is hampered by Congress
everything has to go through them so it
is difficult for U.S presidents it was
for Obama it will be for Biden but to be
perfectly honest the rest of the world
says we've got our difficulties too this
isn't easy in any country we've all got
our politics we've all got our
Parliament and basically they expect the
US to act and to be honest they expect
the U.S to act even more than Biden has
said he will act the U.S is the Lagarde
amongst the big countries the U.S hasn't
done nearly enough over the last 20
years not nearly as much as the EU which
of course is itself not doing enough so
people don't give American Presidents or
even vice presidents that much leeway
here no well we'll see what materializes
over the rest of the week and I've been
saying that we've been following all of
the twists and turns here I'm just
wondering if there's anything you think
that the media is in danger of missing
that could actually be quite pivotal
pivotal what might take place here over
the next few years actually because this
is called be called adaptation day and
loss and damage we're going to have a
much stronger Push by those small
islands that you mentioned in the most
vulnerable countries to ensure that much
more of the money goes towards
adaptation it can be sometimes difficult
for people to understand what meant by
that but basically a lot of the
attention in the UK is about reducing
our emissions and that is obviously
going to prevent climate change if it's
done enough in the future but many
countries are suffering really severe
impacts from climate change today and
they have to adapt to that they've got
to build sea wall defenses and flood
defenses they've got to have drought
resistant crops if they're experiencing
more droughts and so on and not enough
of the money that has so far gone from
the Richer countries of the world to the
poorer ones has gone for adaptation
and that's what they're demanding
they're saying the most vulnerable
saying we want half of the money to go
towards adaptation it's currently 20 to
25 so that's going to be a big demand
and they're saying some of it has to go
towards loss and damage even if they can
adapt they are still suffering huge
damage and that money they want a kind
of compensation if you look at who's
caused climate change it is the richest
countries of the world and it's what's
made us rich the reason we are rich
countries is we burn carbon for 200
years and yet it's the poorest countries
in the world which suffer the most and
they say not unreasonably we need to be
compensated for that there needs to be
some Finance which flows to us from the
rich world to the poorer countries
because we have suffered this loss in
this damage
Michael really good to get your analysis
here on Sky News thank you very much
indeed don't go away coming up here on
Sky News climate live we're going to be
bringing you the final stages of the
sessions taking place here today on the
first day of the second week here in
Glasgow the SEC cop 26 stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back well today's conference saw
a bold call coming from the former U.S
president Barack Obama for the big
carbon emitters to take a lead on
climate change well that call was echoed
Again by the cop 26th president Alex
Sharma who said that countries must
deliver on the commitments that they
made in the past week
there needs to be a sense of urgency in
all our negotiations the science is
clear we have no time to lose and I will
ensure that negotiations proceed in a
timely manner whilst of course ensuring
transparency and inclusivity
last week countries made commitments
which will all help to protect our
planet but they must be delivered on and
accounted for
today on adaptation and loss and damage
day the spotlight will be on those
Nations and communities which are most
vulnerable to climate change those whose
voices are too often left unheard
and we know that even if we stopped
polluting our world tomorrow there will
be negative consequences for many
millions and that is why issues such as
adaptation are so important now I'm
pleased to see progress on these topics
today and particularly welcome the
commitments to the adaptation fund which
we made in the next few hours including
from the UK to support vulnerable
communities to respond to climate change
developed countries and development
Banks recognize they need to increase
levels of Finance or adaptation and I
hope we will be able to capture this
renewed commitment in the cop 26
negotiated outcome
those of you who have followed this
process will know that loss and damage
has historically been seen as a
polarizing issue
but I'm encouraged that the mood music
has changed somewhat and there is now a
practical recognition that action is
needed on this topic in the face of
growing impacts
the conclusion of discussions within the
subsidiary bodies on the Santiago
network is a testament to that and paves
the way for greater resources to avert
minimize and address loss and damage
climate vulnerable communities are
particularly at the Forefront of my mind
and will be so throughout these
negotiations they and the generations to
come will not forgive us if we fail to
deliver in Glasgow
meanwhile the UN estimates that methane
gas has accounted for 30 of global
warming since the Industrial Revolution
the oil and gas industry are well known
to be big and unregulated emitters of
methane with the cattle industry too
often criticized but another key emitter
of the potent gas is our own rubbish
well Mark Stone reports from Texas where
they're trying new ways to capture the
methane from the mountains of refuse
that we all produce
we all contribute to landfill but up
close there is something overwhelming
about a place like this and in
consumer-obsessed America the scale is
quite something
so too the lack of effective recycling
just look at the plastic and the
cardboard here
space is cleared for more and more
because the average American produces
nearly a ton of rubbish every year
that's three times as much as the
average Britain
we are seemingly Unstoppable generators
of waste which is why management is so
vital so this is the most interesting
work I've ever done
Zachary Peterson manages this vast
landfill outside Houston America's
fourth largest city and he's proud of a
process that despite flaws caused by
consumer culture and poor regulation is
he says sustainable my passion for
landfills is I can affect change and it
affects you know our community it
affects you know being a good neighbor
it affects the environment you know I'm
directly affecting the
the world my daughter's going to grow up
in by doing proper landfilling
under this pasture is tons of waste
among the huge challenges of landfill is
methane without effective management
methane seeps out of the earth as the
waste decomposes and it is a greenhouse
gas that short-term warms our planet
faster than any other in America alone
landfill accounts for nearly 20 percent
of human-caused methane emissions but
here a solution we've watched the trucks
coming in through the morning tons and
tons of waste flattened and compacted on
top of a plastic shell that already
lines the landfill site eventually that
shell will be sealed the waste within it
will decompose and from that the methane
can then be extracted
these stumps are the methane Wells
dotted across the landscape they are the
heart of the operation and they are the
success story the example I like to use
being if you imagine a milkshake you
have a straw in the milkshake the
milkshakes or landfill the straw is the
extraction well you exert the vacuum
using your mouth or in our case a blower
system and you know the content is
removed at some point
on the edge of the site the gas which
would otherwise seep out of the earth is
piped into a Refinery cleaned and then
sold on to power cars and heat homes
this methane capture is a technology
used increasingly around the developed
world yet Beyond it is literally an
ever-growing Challenge and while this
may be a success of sorts the troubling
fact is that even here so much of this
will never decompose Mark Stone Sky News
in Texas
well the first day of the second week is
drawing to eclairs but we've still got
plenty more coverage to bring you here
on Sky News climate live so do stay with
us
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello again now the end of coal is in
sight that was the claim from the UK
government when it announced a new deal
pledging to phase out Coal Power the
business secretary quasi-quarting called
it a milestone moment but some are
skeptical pointing to China by far the
world's biggest user of coal that hasn't
signed up and many other countries have
yet to set a date for when they will
also stop using coal or Sky's Asia
correspondent Tom Cheshire asks whether
we're capable of kicking coal
coal powered us through the Industrial
Revolution
now it's powering us to an environmental
catastrophe
so why is it so hard to kick
the simplest answer is because it's the
status quo most Nations National Grids
are built to use it and many of the
world's economies are supported by its
production the technology does exist to
move away from coal
some countries have managed to stop
using it entirely and our alarm the sun
wind water nuclear or gas for power
but huge sways of the world still use
coal in fact in 2019 27 of the world's
energy came from it
and renewable energy can have huge
upfront costs and may not be as reliable
as the old coal-fired Power stations
the problem is coal is dirty minding it
like they are behind me damages local
ecosystems and pollutes air and water
but burning it is even worse when it
burns coal produces more CO2 than any
other fossil fuel that in turn has a
greenhouse effect around the planet and
causes it to heat up
[Music]
who's the biggest coal addict of all
China
at a time when most developed nations
are decommissioning their minds and
shutting down their coal-fired power
stations China is going in the opposite
direction
it is building coal-fired power plants
at a rate that outpaces the rest of the
world combined
last year China brought 38.4 gigawatts
of new coal-fired power into operation
that's more than three times what was
brought online anywhere else
in 2019 nearly 58 of its power came from
coal
ition
[Music]
and China's huge Reliance on coal is one
of the reasons it emitted 27 of the
world's greenhouse gases in 2019.
but it isn't just China's problem
in Australia coal is mined in every
state and in one month in 2021 the
government approved plans for three new
Coal Mine developments
the UK government is currently deciding
whether to open its first deep Coal Mine
in 30 years
and after the Fukushima nuclear disaster
of 2011 countries like Germany were
moving away from coal decommissioned
their nuclear power plants because of
safety fears which means they went
straight back to being reliant on coal
one reason that coal is so hard to kick
is that growing economies need a lot of
power and coal is a reliable and
affordable way of getting it
the Chinese government for example wants
the economy to grow by six percent every
year
one of their top concerns about reaching
that Target is not having enough energy
to drive the economy
and for those in power coal is a safe
bet a coal-fired power station will
deliver reliable affordable power to
your voters without needing to rely on a
sunny day or windy Seas so for the world
to kick its cold habit it's going to
take a massive shift in that status quo
[Music]
well meanwhile Australia has said that
it will continue to sell coal for
decades into the future after refusing
to sign up to that deal pledging to
phase out fossil fuels at [ __ ] 26 in
Glasgow
Australia produces just four percent of
the world's thermal coal it's some of
the world's highest quality and that's
why we'll continue to have markets for
decades into the future and if they're
buying Hamish well we are selling demand
is increasing prices are up and we
expect that that increase in demand to
continue out to around 2030. we don't
expect countries will immediately go and
close down their coal-fired generation
particularly where they're new and in
fact some are still under construction
and if we aren't still in that market
somebody else will I'd much rather it be
Australia's high quality product
well southeast Asia correspondent
Siobhan Robbins has all the latest on
this now from Sydney
well there's been a lot of pressure on
the Australian government coming into
cop 26 it was just days before the
conference kicked off that they finally
managed to announce a commitment to net
zero emissions by 2050 then last week in
the first week of the conference we saw
that they failed to sign up to the
methane cup pledge they failed to sign
up to the list of countries and
organizations which have pledged to
phase out for coal power and today the
resources Minister has said very clearly
in an interview that they will not be
closing coal mines and they will not be
closing coal powered fire stations now
he was speaking to ABC the broadcaster
here in Australia and he said that
there's still a huge demand for coal
around the world they said that they
expected that increasing demand to
continue till at least 2030 and in his
words if they want it we will sell it
and he said that if Australia wasn't
selling the coal which he claims is some
of the highest quality in the world than
other countries would step into the
breach he also doubled down saying that
they would meet the commitments that
they've made for 2050 but in his words
they wouldn't destroy the economy trying
to meet those commitments earlier and
that 300 000 people around the country
rely on coal now we've seen a very
similar message coming from the coal
communities that we've been visiting
over the last week saying that they
shouldn't be cutting coal mines now that
people need the money that is well paid
jobs that there's still demand that if
Australia steps back then someone else
will just step into the breach but the
big problem is that even though
Australia isn't a big Global emitter
emits around 1.3 percent of global
emissions it's a massive exporter of
coal it's the second biggest export of
coal in the world so in that sense
climate campaigners say it's essentially
like a world dealer of the dirtiest
fossil fuel in the world so how is the
rest of the world meant to step up and
meet emissions if Australia won't step
up and cut coal
coming up on Sky News climate live we're
going to bring you a highlights piece on
everything that's happened today
tomorrow all about science and
Innovation we're going to be hearing
from the country's Chief scientist
Patrick balance and also